Okay, Linda. We're live. All right. Seeing that the board members are now present, I
convened the September 10th, 2020 meeting. Karen, can you please call the roll to establish
a quorum? Sure. Sue? Here. Linda? Here. Zaid? Here. Linda?
Here. Cynthia? Here. Kim? Here. Pat? Here. Kim? Here. Aide? Here. Patricia? Here.
Dean? Here. Ting? Here. All present. All right. I hereby call the September 2020 meeting of the
State Board of Education to order at 846 a.m. and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strouss, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance? Yes.
Ready, begin. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
This is why it's so hard to do a choir on Zoom. Thank you very much. I am delighted to be able
to administer the oath of office to our new student board member, Zaid Fattah, and I'm going
to ask you, please, Zaid, to raise your right hand and repeat after me. I, Zaid Fattah. I,
Zaid Fattah. Do solemnly swear that I will support. Do solemnly swear that I will support. And defend
the Constitution of the United States. And defend the Constitution of the United States. Against all
enemies, foreign and domestic. Against all enemies, foreign and domestic. That I will bear true faith
and allegiance. That I will bear true faith and allegiance. To the Constitution of the United
States. To the Constitution of the United States. And the Constitution of the State of California.
And the Constitution of the State of California. That I take this obligation freely. That I take
this obligation freely. Without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion. Without any
mental reservation or purpose of evasion. And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties. Upon which I am about to enter. Upon
which I'm about to enter. Congratulations. Thank you. Welcome. We're delighted to have you here.
And look forward to this year with you. I'm delighted to introduce you now more formally to
Zaid, who is a senior at Monte Vista High School in San Ramon Valley Unified School District. And
would you like to share a little bit about your background so that we'll all get to know you a bit?
Definitely. Thank you so much. Thank you so much, President Darlene Kamen and good morning esteemed
board members and everyone. My name is Zaid Fattah and I'm a senior at Monte Vista High School in
the San Ramon Valley Unified School District. And I am incredibly honored and humbled to serve as
this year's student board member. This past year I served on my district's Local Control and
Accountability Plan Committee, LCAP. And it really changed the way I view education and the importance
of the student voice and the decision making process. It's really hard for me to articulate
how much this position means to me because it's something that I've been thinking about actively
since the eighth grade. I first heard of this position when I was in the eighth grade. I was
at a speech and debate tournament and I watched former board member Jaden Gray deliver an oration
at the speech tournament. And following the round, I kind of heard of this position and I had a chance
to talk to him. And ever since that day, I've kind of had this position at the forefront of my mind.
And so when I got the call from the governor's office a few weeks ago, it was a dream come true,
truly. And so I'm really excited to chart my own path with this position and will truly give it
100% to represent the nearly 6.3 students I represent. Perfect. Thank you very much and
welcome, welcome. I'd also like to announce that this is the last meeting that Chad Owes of the
CDE Executive Office will be serving as the CDE State Board Liaison. He has taken an administrative
position in the Instructional Measurement Branch. We'd like to thank him for all of his coordination
help over these last eight months. We look forward to working with him in his new role.
In addition, I want to share that after serving for seven and a half years, our executive director,
Karen Steph Walters, will leave after today's board meeting. We have a tribute plan for Karen
early this afternoon when we reopen the State Board priorities item after closed session.
She won't be going far. She'll be with the California County executives and we will be
working with her in a new role. And finally, this is the annual time of year when the fall
recruitment for the State Board Advisory Commissions and the 2021-22 student board
member position have begun. And applications can be found on our website and we're recruiting for
the following positions. The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools is seeking applications from
teachers who are employed by charter school. The Advisory Commission on Special Education is
recruiting for three positions. Strong preference will be given to parents of a child or a young
adult with disabilities and to a representative of the charter school community. The California
Practitioners Advisory Group is seeking applications to fill the specialized instructional support
personnel and paraprofessionals position. The Instructional Quality Commission is currently
seeking applications for their 2021-22 student member position. And lastly, the State Board is
currently accepting applications for the 2021-22 State Board student member position. Interested
students who will be high school seniors in good standing in any California public high school
during the 2021-22 school year and are available to participate in a virtual statewide conference,
which is being held from October 31st to November 2nd, are invited to apply for the position of
student member on the California State Board of Education. The final filing date for all
of these positions is 5 o'clock p.m. on Thursday, October the 8th. I do have a change in the agenda
to announce. There's an addendum for item five related to the state seal of civic engagement
evaluation criteria. And as mentioned, we'll reopen item one, which is State Board priorities
following closed session to pay a tribute to our executive director to take action on the
draft minutes and receive the State Board liaison reports. The board will go into closed session
right after the lunch break. And as a reminder to board members, there is a separate Zoom
line and access code set up for the closed session. There is one public hearing on the
agenda, which we will take up this afternoon. Item six is an appeal to transfer territory
from the Lawndale Elementary and Centinella Valley High School districts into Wiseburn Unified.
The proposed waiver consent items are W01 through W03 and W05 through W08. The proposed regular
consent items are items seven through 10. We'll take up both the waiver consent items and the
regular consent items later this afternoon. On public input, members of the public who
are wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream of the meeting
to know at what time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may be provided
by dialing the phone number and entering a participant access code. Upon dialing in,
callers will be added to a caller queue. The operator will notify callers when it is their
turn to provide public comment. We will also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume
of their computers if they are following the live webcast to avoid the echoing effect because there
is a slight lag. Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker. Item 11 is the
general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on any matters
that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda. And then I'd like to ask board members
to please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your cameras on at all times except
during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's virtual
meeting. For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand using
the zoom participant window if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment. So agenda item one
is our state board priorities item and we are opening item one to hear the superintendent's
report and the state board president's report at this time only. And then as I mentioned,
we will reopen the item after closed session for the remaining items and I'll now turn it over to
state superintendent Tony Thurmond for his report. Superintendent Thurmond. Thank you, madam president.
Thank you for your leadership in these challenging times. I think we're on zooms and calls almost
always and appreciate your stewardship and leadership during these challenging times.
I'm honored to see all of our board members. I hope that wherever you are, you are safe and well
during these very difficult times and grateful to be able to welcome our new student board member
Fatah. Welcome and great remarks and exciting that you've aspired towards this since you were
in eighth grade. Great speech. Who knows? Perhaps we'll see you at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue sometime
in our near future. So continue to dream and continue to lead and we're excited to have you
here especially since you worked on LCAP. Most people want to run away after they've worked on
LCAP matters and to hear that because it's so complicated but it's important to hear that you
are inspired to want to do more from it. We're grateful to have your perspectives here. I just
want to say how much I'm in awe of what our California schools and everyone in the education
community are doing right now. It goes without saying that we never imagined that we'd find
ourselves in this situation where all of our schools are open, most in distance learning,
trying to deal with the impacts of COVID-19, trying to deal with the impacts of a man-made
pandemic, of racism and police brutality as it plays out on our streets as we watch it and think
of the impact that it has on our students. We know that we need to continue to lead with education
to promote change for all and now to see as our schools finally are in a place where they can open
some in person most in distance learning to add to it fires and issues with air quality on top of
that. Our schools are dealing with the most difficult circumstances. There aren't words to
describe it. Our hearts go out to those who've lost loved ones. Many have lost their home.
We know that in Butte County, which has had its own share of challenges over the years,
we've lost schools. We've lost Berry Creek School that was destroyed. We know that there are other
schools that maybe not fully destroyed have been severely damaged. This is a tough time and this
is a time for us to all lean in and to help in any way that we can. Obviously, we're doing all we can
to defer any kind of requirements that these schools would have to provide. We've met with
all the county superintendents to say that we will expedite any J-13A waiver request. These are the
waivers that school districts who are impacted by disaster can use to be held harmless and to
receive their ADA even when they're dealing with these types of disasters that make it impossible
for our students to be in school. Our team and I have worked on ways to send face coverings
to communities that are impacted. We sent some N95 masks to a community in Tulare County
where many of the children of farm workers have been impacted and their parents as well are working
under the worst air quality conditions that we've probably seen. We know that these challenges
persist and we are doing all we can to offer our support to our school districts but need to
commend our students, their parents and family members, our educators, our administrators,
our entire education community for its resilience under these conditions. On yesterday, we held a
webinar for all 1,000 school districts to go over the latest guidance for when schools can be open
and when they need to be closed. Well over 1,000 participants on that Zoom with lots of great
questions hosted. We hosted it but we're honored to be joined by Ben Chita, the deputy chief cabinet
secretary in the governor's office and by Dr. Erica Pond who leads the team at the California
Department of Public Health. And we are just staying synchronized with our partners in the
health arena to make sure that our schools are getting the information as best that we can get
to them. We continue to work with school districts on making sure that they have the tools that they
need for distance learning. As you know, the governor and the legislature provided a learning
loss mitigation fund that provides $5.3 billion for school districts to use for computing devices,
for counseling programs and social emotional programs, and for training and professional
development for educators around distance learning. And the CDE administers those dollars. We've been
in touch with every district about exactly how much money they can have. We've even tried to
play matchmaker between schools that are looking for computing devices and companies that still
have supply because as you know, there is a worldwide shortage for computing devices
at this time. And so we've inventoried what exists for every manufacturer who has it.
A big shout out to Mary Nicely who has been leading our effort and has almost single-handedly
inventoried what every school district needs and has figured out a way to get distributors like
Office Depot and Staples to hold on devices just for our students. You know, Apple and T-Mobile
have done the same in the face of a shortage of devices. They've held on to hundreds of thousands
of devices for our students that are internet enabled. And so while it is a challenge and
districts are still scrambling, we are leaning all the way in. By this time, I can say that
through our work with a number of partners, we've probably helped to get shipped out hundreds of
thousands of devices to school districts. Many of you have been involved in asking for donations.
Obviously, our board president has been a leader in asking for donations and securing donations.
We've worked very closely with the CBE Foundation, which is a 501C3 that can accept donations
and then move them to the school communities where they are needed. We announced that PG&E
has made a $500,000 contribution through this process to support schools in Humboldt County
who are in deep need of computers. Literally, we are working on these kinds of connections
all across the state. We've reached out to 100 different companies to really ask them to make
financial donations to support our students. We will be announcing in the days to come
many companies who've made donations to help us support tribal communities,
rural communities, urban communities, suburban communities, and frontier communities.
But yet we know the bigger question still looms. How do we create the infrastructure
so there can be broadband in rural communities? And we're working with the legislature and other
entities on how to create a new way for California, how to create innovation that results in helping
California close the digital divide. You'll hear me talk about that quite a bit. I created a task
force on closing the digital divide. As we speak, we're talking with business leaders and technology
leaders to identify how we need to innovate in California to once and for all close the digital
divide. And so these are some of the things that we're continuing to work with our districts on.
The California Department of Education did release new guidance to support moving into
distance learning to make sure that there is a balance between live instruction to make sure
that students are supported. They're seeing their teachers and staff to make sure that there is
content that teachers can use in distance learning. We did a survey asking teachers,
what worked for you during distance learning in the first round? What did it work? What worked
for our students and what didn't work? We've heard from more than 300 teachers across the state who
sent innovative lesson plans and content that we can share with other educators on how to support
our students. I can tell you, I've heard from most, our educators are really leaning in here,
recognizing that while in-person instruction is the most important thing, safety warrants us being
in distance learning and that it's important for us to do things in a way that we can offset
learning gaps that occur and were exacerbated in the first round of distance learning. And so
big shout out to the team at the California Department of Education who put on probably
70 or 80 webinars by now since the first round of distance learning. And to TSD, the division
that's hosting us today, they've hosted all those webinars and they continue to dig deep and to
provide more. You'll hear from some new staff today. Again, we welcome a board member to this
board. You'll hear from some new staff. We're introducing for the first time a new special
education director, Heather Calamiz, who has already started. Heather is previously the
executive director for special education at the Illinois State Department of Education.
Great reputation for work that she has done with a high emphasis on equity and we're excited to
have her join our team. You'll hear from her often in our meetings. We want to thank Chad for
his work as serving in this role as liaison to the State Board of Education. We're grateful that he
will be continuing on at CDE in a new role, working very closely with our deputy superintendent,
Rachel Mage, who we've announced to you, but I want to reintroduce to you today and you'll
hear from her today and you'll hear from her often. She will be presenting to you often because she
oversees the branch that has many of the items that come before the board, like our curriculum
frameworks and assessment, accountability, education data management, and educator
excellence. And so you'll hear her often and we'll be reintroducing her to you today. She's
already leaned in in just a few several weeks that she's been on board and we're excited
to have her here. And I'm happy to tell you of who the new liaison will be to the State Board and
he also is no stranger to you or to CDE. It's Dr. Alex Moos who's been working at the Department of
Education for seven years on our computer science test on our science testing work and he will be
joining us in the new role as liaison to the State Board. And so we are excited to welcome new faces.
I want to acknowledge the new executive director who will join us in Brooks Allen.
I want to acknowledge Deborah Brown in her appointment and I want to say my deep thanks
to Karen Staff Walters who has led with class and grace in the most difficult of times and from whom
I've learned a great deal. You know sometimes she doesn't say anything but she's always saying
something that is useful and helpful to the conversation and if you never get a chance
to do this I suggest that you just ask her what do you think about this problem. Since my days in
the legislature I've had the chance to watch her work through really complicated formulas and
programs and protocols to help our students and I always feel like she gets what's at the heart of
what we do. It's not about the complicated protocols. It's about what we do for our
students. It's about do they lead us towards a positive outcome for our students and I'm
grateful for your servant leadership Karen and while you'll be missed in this role I am grateful
that you're not going far and that we can continue to bug you. I mean consult with you in your new
role at SESSA. So thank you for your service here. Thank you for your service at SESSA.
And Madam President this completes my report. Thank you very much and I co-sign those comments
about Karen knows that I still intend to talk with her regularly as we as we do now.
Well I just want to reinforce a couple of points that State Superintendent Thurman made. We've come
a long way in California in terms of figuring out how to provide high quality distance learning
and the efforts that are underway that were just enumerated about getting closing that digital
divide are continuous. They're persevering. We've been working together as a team to just keep the
resources coming to schools, the connectivity expanding and the devices in that supply chain
challenge moving across and I know there's State Superintendent announced just about a month ago
a million devices from Apple and T-Mobile that will be on their way as soon as we can get through
the supply chain issues. So I believe that we will in fact get to the place where we close the digital
divide soon in this state. Districts have been enormously creative. County offices have been
stepping up to launch a distance learning consortium to provide curriculum units and
lesson plans as well as training for teachers. Districts of course have been doing that.
Many have reached out to parents to say what do you want? What worked for you in the spring? What
do you need? Many have found ways to connect to families in a one-on-one way to figure out what
the specific family needs are. I hope that we continue some of the practices that are
being invented now. It's a time for invention and sharing when we get back to what may never be
regular school as we knew it but what will become the new normal in the schools. Places like
San Diego and Elk Hills really designed their new systems around what parents wanted.
We're hearing from across the state, I'm talking to teachers and superintendents and parents,
what a good start we're off to in distance learning in so many districts this year,
many of them reporting 95, 98, 100% attendance, kids showing up bright and shiny in front of
their computers when they can't be there in person and teachers understanding how to work with them
in and out of the zoom breakout rooms and with projects that are going on and small group
instruction to help kids catch up and one-on-one instruction where it's needed. As you know, the
state has developed a plan for districts to be able to bring back small groups for instruction
and targeted services, particularly students who special education needs, students who could not
easily connect. Districts like San Francisco have started learning hubs with their Department of
Family, Youth and Children so that they can provide spaces for kids who need to do distance
learning from a place other than the home where they can be online, get support, get food and
other supports during that time. So it's an extraordinary moment to see educators, cities,
communities stepping up in the face of all of the challenges that Tony enumerated
both from the pandemic and from the fires that are going on now. The other thing that I am very
heartened by is the recognition of the importance of social and emotional learning. Virtually every
district I connect with says we're starting out with a social and emotional learning agenda,
a platform, a way to figure out what supports students need and also to engage in social,
emotional learning and practices on a regular basis. There are so many that in the wake of the
shootings that occurred by police have begun to move away from policing towards restorative
practices in schools and are continuing their learning about how to create more inclusive and
supportive environments for students. I think the key issue for us in the state is the issue of
how to deal both with the ongoing chasm of inequality outside the schools as well as the
issues that we deal with inside with loss of employment, with loss of
housing, food security and so on. Our governor and our legislature have stepped up over and over
again to try to build back a safety net to the extent that it's possible, but we really need
to continue to work as we are in the federal environment for the kind of recovery that will
allow us to see all of our children adequately supported both inside and outside of schools.
The schools have been doing heroic work, heroic work to step up into those gaps and be sure that
kids are getting as much of what they need as the education system can provide. The final
thing I'll just say is that I think in moments like this, there are moments of social upheaval
like this and we've had them in history. We see tremendous moments of social progress
following. If you think back to the 1930s when the Great Depression
emerged, think back to the 1960s in the middle of intensive civil rights gains and issues,
assassinations, all kinds of things were triggering social mobilization.
We transformed that into progressive policy that supported equity, that supported
empowering education. We're at that moment. We are in that inflection point. We are working
on that agenda in California and we need to continue to double down on that. People are
inventing ways to strengthen the relationships between schools, families, and communities,
as well as the work that goes on within them, and we need to share across in all of the ways that
the defense, the CCE, state board, and others are seeking to make sure that that sharing goes on.
With that, I think we need to get into our agenda for the day. We're going to move us
of agenda one and move us on to agenda number two, which is our accountability item.
I'm going to ask that Cindy Kazanis appear on our screen. Agenda two is
a recommendation from CDE that the state board adopt the following new career measures for
inclusion in the college career indicator. Actually, I'll let them come to that in a moment
and detail all of those measures. We'll also receive an update on the development of the
growth model and the implementation of some statutory provisions. Cindy, I see your slides.
I assume you are there, so please begin. Good morning. Cindy Kazanis with the
Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division. I just wanted to echo
Superintendent Thurmond's comments about Karen Staff Walters and her tenure here at the board.
We would not have gotten to the place we have with accountability without her leadership.
Seven and a half years meant the birth of LCFF, the new assessment system, the new accountability
system, and the system of support. You have fought so hard for that and have been a great supporter.
You even made a trip to Washington, D.C. to fight for the ESSA state plan with us. I do
appreciate your support and your leadership. Congratulations on your new endeavor. We will
miss you. We're really looking forward to having Brooks Allen back. It's nice to see a familiar
face and somebody who's so steeped, of course, in LCFF. We're looking forward to working with Brooks
again. I wanted to get us started today. We're going to actually take our attachments out of
order. We do have some meaty things to talk about today, but we only have one action item.
So I'll walk through the attachments individually, and I'll be joined at the podium by Jenny Singh
and others to present this item. So the recommendation for today is the adoption
that the state board adopt the following new career measures for the inclusion in the college
career indicator, pre-apprenticeships, state and federal job programs, transition work-based
learning experiences, transition classroom-based learning experiences. And before we get into that,
we wanted to talk a little bit about what we've been doing. So in order to bring any item to the
board when it comes to accountability, we go through an extensive stakeholder outreach process.
And while we've all been working remotely since around St. Patrick's Day, we have been really
getting out there in terms of accountability to make sure that the field understands things
about the waiver that's been approved by the federal government around accountability,
the subsequent legislation from the state that supports that, and then the items before you
today. And so between April and August, end of August, we have had six work groups, which for
us have been focused primarily on the college career indicator and advisory meetings. And with
those meetings, about 190 participants, 13 virtual presentations with over 2,000 participants. And
then some work that we've started on that you're going to hear about at the next board meeting
is around AB 1505. And that was the accountability hosted webinar that we did back in late June,
where we had nearly 400 participants. So attachment one walks us through the
options before you for the college career indicator. I will stop after I present this
material for clarifying questions, and we'll do the same for the other attachments because there's
a lot of material here to cover. So to begin, this has been a work in progress for many years.
You all had an actual study session just around the college career indicator last year in May.
And so we are at a place where we're ready to propose new career measures. And we'd like to
publicly report out in these career measures in fall of 2020. Why that's important is because
we want to make sure that schools get recognized for the work that they've done to prepare students
for not only college but career. And we've known this indicator has been lacking on the career
side. And so we've really spent the last year or so focused on collecting this data, analyzing
this data, and what you see before you today for the recommendations. The data, it's important to
note, will not be used on the dashboard to determine a color because of the legislation
that's referenced in the second bullet, SB 98. We are required under that provision to report
valid and reliable data that would have been included in the dashboard. And so we will be
able to report out on our additional reports the measures in which students demonstrate that they
were prepared or approaching prepared for the college career indicator. And I think for the
first time this spring, we are working towards a solution where we can provide this information
back to school districts at the student level. I also wanted to note, and I think we put this in
the item, that this by adopting these measures, this takes us to the ultimate goal that I think
you have all expressed to us in previous meetings to make this not only a college career indicator
but a college and career indicator. And also to the place where we can actually have a category
that's called well prepared. So there are four items that we are bringing before you for adoption.
The first is pre-apprenticeships, and there's a nice summary chart if it's easier for you to look
at. It's on page two of the attachment. The pre-apprenticeship piece would be available to
both traditional and our dashboard alternative school status schools or DAS schools. The second
is the state and federal job programs, which is limited to DAS schools. The third transition
work-based learning experiences that would be available only to students with individualized
education programs or IEPs. And then finally the transition classroom-based learning experiences
available only to students with IEPs and who have earned a certificate of completion.
It's important to note that many of these measures were collected for the first time
in 2018-19, and we're currently collecting our second year of this data as we speak.
The collection is scheduled to close tomorrow, and so we'll have I think some robust data to
be able to share with districts around this. So at your May 2019 study session you provided,
there was a very robust discussion. I think we had about a four-hour session with you prior to your
May board meeting, and there was a lot of talk around how we can start to bring on career
measures and not tying them to how we do our college measures, which is to the smarter balance
some of the assessments. So in order to do that, what we've been working on to make sure that we
followed your directive was to base our proposed career measures on research and the completion of
career technical education coursework. So we've looked at local, state, national research on the
programs that are before you today, and you have them summarized in the item.
So if you're following along on the board item, we're on page 14, and the two pieces that fall
under the pre-apprenticeship program are registered pre-apprenticeships and non-registered
pre-apprenticeships. And registered pre-apprenticeships are recognized by businesses and our industry,
and are registered at the state or national level, and the non-registered ones simply are not
registered at the state or national level, but are recognized by businesses or industry.
So for the first, there's actually two slides for this. The first slide is around traditional schools,
and the second slide is around dashboard alternative school status schools, because there's a slight
variation on the non-registered pre-apprenticeship piece. So the recommendation is for the registered
pre-apprenticeship for traditional schools that in order to be in the prepared category, they've
completed the program. There is no recommendation for approaching prepared. Well, this is similar
to the state's syllabi literacy, so by earning that seal, you are determined to be prepared.
For the non-registered, it's not only completion of the program, but also the completion of a CTE
pathway. The approaching prepared criteria is completion of a program.
So I think it's important to note that overall, by adding this measure, what we've found is that
over nearly 700 students, or 679, would shift into the prepared category. Of those students,
80% are in traditional schools, and about 20 in the DAS schools. So while we're moving the needle
for a small number of students of over 400,000 students in our cohort, it's important that we
recognize where to meet students, where they're at. Not all students are on the college path,
and so this captures some of the students who may not be being able to demonstrate that they're
prepared under the college career indicator. So for DAS, again, the same for the pre-registered
criteria, completion of the program. The difference is for the non-registered
pre-apprenticeship, we not only have the completion of the program, plus the completion of one semester,
two quarters, two trimesters of a CTE course, and then adding in with a C-minus or better.
The same category, or rather, approaching prepared criteria is for DAS as it is for
the traditional schools. Moving on to the state or federal job program, and we're recommending
this be limited to DAS schools. Many of the programs that we reviewed really actually are
at DAS schools. So the first is the Job Corps, which is a U.S. Department of Labor sponsored
program. We know that there are several DAS schools, if not actually charter schools,
that work with this program. The WIOA youth program has a lot of the same students as well,
again sponsored by the Department of Labor. I know that there was a letter of support
specifically on this from SciTech, because they've been strong in this area and actually have
a long-standing history with the WIOA program. The other piece that we looked at for the state
and federal job programs is YouthBuild. Again, there are a couple of charter schools that
focus on YouthBuild, and then the California Conservation Corps, which of course is a state
program, RCOP as well. And so we do not have discrete data on each of these programs because
of the way the collection was done in CALPADS, but beginning this year or moving forward,
we will start to collect them for each of the programs. So the recommendation for this is to,
for prepared, is the completion of the program plus completion of one semester, two quarters,
two trimesters of a CTE course with a C minus or better, and then the approaching prepared criteria
is completion of a program. This measure would add 403 students to prepared from either approaching
prepared or not prepared. And so it's, again, small amounts, but moving the margin for a really
critical piece of students, many students who are over 18 and are trying to come back and
earn their high school diploma or earn a GED. And then the final group is based on students who
are students who have an IEP, so this is limited to an even smaller universe of students, but a
universe that is very hard to demonstrate college or career preparedness. And so this data collection
and how we looked at this was done from the old special education data system called CASEMIS,
and this information has been transferred over to our student level data system or CALPADS.
We are looking at for classroom or work-based experiences, the prepared criteria would be
completion of 100 hours of work experience and the equivalent of four semesters of college and
career exploration, preparation, designed to prepare the student with an IEP for employment
and independent living, and then the approaching prepared criteria would be completion of the 100
hours of work experience or the equivalent of four semesters of college and career exploration
or preparation. It's important to note that all of these measures have support ultimately from
both the policy work groups that we have been developing the college career indicator under,
which is the college career subgroup for accountability, and then the alternative
school work group. And they had a meeting not only in February, but they came back in May,
and then some came back even in August to work through these. We also had the support of the
California practitioners advisory group, and really there's not been a lot of
discussion. These seem to be things that folks generally are ready to move on with and bring
on board to the college career indicator. So with that, I'm happy to turn it over
to President Darling-Hammond to ask any clarifying questions,
and then from here we'll move over to the growth model discussion.
Yeah, we'll just see if anyone has clarifying questions, and I
need to make my screen function so I can see everyone again.
So give me just a second here, sorry.
Linda, Cynthia has her hand up.
Okay, please, Cynthia, go ahead. I'm still trying to figure out how to get my screen to work.
Good morning, thank you so much. I just had a quick clarifying question in regards to the
CTE coursework that would be aligned to the apprenticeship program. Can you clarify,
in order to be approaching, would the CTE course for the traditional school need to be aligned
to the content or the focus of the pre-apprenticeship?
I'm going to turn it over to Jenny Singh, who's been diligently working on this for a long time.
So as we were working with our CCI work group, they were very clear that if students are in
an apprenticeship, they are traditionally also taking CTE courses that are aligned to that.
I will say that when we do our programming and we pull out the CTE courses, we will not
be determining if those courses are actually aligned. But if they complete a CTE pathway and
a pre-apprenticeship, we've been assured that those are aligned very well at the local level.
Okay, so pretty much the likelihood of that, of the alignment, is in place right now based upon
what has been seen, but there isn't any measure to ensure that that would indeed occur. Is that
accurate, Jenny? Yeah, it would be extremely difficult to do that in our program. But as we
start to collect courses a little bit differently, we may be able to do that in the future.
Thank you.
So yeah, my question. So these indicators that are being asked, or that you're asking us to adopt,
when they, sorry, I'm not forming my question correctly. Some of the indicators on our college
career readiness are coupled with others, right, to be prepared. So these that you're recommending,
are they standalone? They're not coupled with anything else? I know we were trying to stay away
from academic and just have sole CTE, or career rather, based indicators.
So some of the measures that we're asking you to approve are standalone, and some of them are
coupled with the completion of CTE pathways or courses in some way or another. Okay, and so the
department has a really great chart that on the career readiness indicator right now, and so
these will be woven in. It's starting to become complex, and so I worry a little bit about
communication, about how all of these indicators work with each other. You're correct. It is a very
complex indicator because we do have lots of measures in there, and we will be working with
our contractor, the Sacramento County Office of Education, to update the chart and hopefully make
it as clear as possible. So there's as little confusion as possible out in the field. Thank you.
I'm not seeing other hands at the moment. Trisha Rucker has her hand up, Linda. Oh great, thank you.
Thank you. I hope you can hear me. I want, my question was, I wanted to get some clarification
about how the courses that the students are going to receive credit for in this indicator
are being reviewed or certified, and I hope this does not either add complexity or confusion
to what you said, but I want to make sure I heard you say that you have not vetted or reviewed,
or there is not criteria for vetting and reviewing these courses to make sure that they either are
parallel and rigor or contain and are aligned to the standards that we're expecting, and I understand
that because these are approved either meet industry standard or have been approved in various
ways by different agencies, is there a way over time to grow what the matrix is for considering
these courses? Because there are, right now we're approving this based on courses that currently
exist. As we continue to mature not only the indicator, but continue based on the plans we
have for the overall development and upgrade of CTE, we're looking at also approving courses that
currently are not in place, so I want to understand, I understand how the courses that you currently
identified have been selected and approved, but what is going to be the criteria going forward
for either refining or improving what is collected or called out of the student database
as additional courses are identified and brought in? Sure, so let me, let me start to answer that
question and then Jenny can help if I miss something. Each of these courses are collected
at the student level in CALPADS, and so like I mentioned, if I take for example the state and
federal program job programs typically done through the course collection process, so the
certification is done at the local level. I think, I want to make sure I understand the question, but
the question that I heard previously was about the alignment of the specific courses within
the pre-apprenticeship and to the CTE pathway, and that's what Jenny was mentioning was a little
more difficult to be that discreet. We recently went through an overhaul of our course,
courses, and how we're looking at courses in CALPADS, and so we are hopeful that we are going
to have better data quality moving forward. We also know that there's not only with the college
career indicator, but other things at the state level related to the cradle to career
work group that the governor has sponsored, that there's a lot of interest in just knowing
a lot more about courses, and of course I know your work with the community college system and
that work group, there's just keen interest on the courses, but ultimately courses are
submitted by local educational agencies and certified through CALPADS.
Okay, yes, and you did tag on to exactly what I was seeking and asking that question, because a
lot of what you have reported to me today or to the board today is very important to board member
Sun and I because of the work we're doing on the California joint workforce pathways advisory
committee, and it informs some of the conversations we've been trying to have, not only about the
content for the plans for the development of the overall CTE statewide plan, but also on what we're
looking for and evaluating and understanding the programs that are being funded for CTE and
multiple sources. So thank you for clarifying what was stated about how the courses are identified
and certified at the local level, and also thank you for clarifying how this work broadens out or
can be connected to the other ongoing activities for the project. So like board member Sun,
I'm having some problem this morning, it seems, trying to make sure I put my question out there
correctly, but you clearly, you answered what I was asking, you answered and gave the information
for what I was seeking, so thank you, and I believe I have lowered my hand.
Okay, great. Seeing no other clarifying questions, we will have a chance to come back for board
discussion, but I'm going to encourage Cindy to go ahead with the growth model discussion.
I'm going to turn this over to Jenny Singh and to our partners at ETS to take over this piece of
the presentation. Good morning board members. As Cindy said, we do have some of our colleagues
from ETS who are online. I am going to start out the presentation, and then we'll have staff from
ETS take over after a few slides. So I'm just going to do a really brief overview about how
we're exploring the empirical best linear prediction calculations for the aggregate growth measures.
So I just wanted to start out with the timeline because I think it's really important to remember
that this has been a very long process. We've invested a lot of time into the growth model.
We started work in March of 2015 looking at various growth models that we should explore,
and then we started the technical work in September 2015. Then in March of 2016,
we started collaborating with the Education Testing Services or ETS.
Then in January of 2017, we had a conversation with the board members about the criteria that
we should be looking at when we're selecting a growth model, and then in April we actually
contracted with ETS for an evaluation study. So in 2018, in February, ETS explored three models,
the residual gain, the change in distance to met, and the conditional percentile ranking.
These were models that were recommended by various groups as we were going out and
asking for input. I have a chart that will explain what that study looked at.
Then in June, ETS submitted part two of the study, which was done at the request of the board members
because they wanted to look at data over time for the growth model.
So for the three models that they looked at, they looked at three different criteria,
strength or relationship with background characteristics,
X, sensitivity to school configuration and assessment content area, and statistical precision.
So it's really important when you read this chart that you understand that if it's blank,
it means that it performed well, and if it's got an X, it means it performed worse on that measure
than the other two models. So based on this information,
so in July of 2018, the board asked us to put a pause on our growth model work,
and that's because the student-level growth model really didn't align with the requirements
that we established for our multiple measures accountability system. The stability of the
growth model over time, it wasn't what we wanted it to be. And we were getting a lot of questions
from the field and a lot of input from stakeholders about how the information from the residual gain
model may not really be answering the questions that they wanted to have answered from a growth model.
So, in 2019, at the request of the state board, we put together a growth model stakeholder group,
and we had four meetings with them, and we did that in partnership with WestEd.
And so the work from these meetings did influence the CDE and the SBE to continue to pursue the
residual gain student growth model. And that brings us to 2020.
A great year that it has been. We worked on the technical modifications with ETS and the
technical design group, or TDG. So one of the first things we did was we revised the highest
obtainable scale score, and we presented that to you last time, and then at the last July meeting,
and then we developed a new regression formula to increase accuracy and stability.
And that's the work that ETS has been doing for us.
So with that, I would like to turn it over to our colleagues at ETS,
and I believe JR Lockwood is going to be presenting this material. JR?
Yes, I'm here. Thank you for the opportunity to present. If anyone cannot hear me clearly,
please speak up. I feel like I'm unmuted now. The goals for this presentation are to give a brief
overview of the empirical best linear prediction, or what will be called the EBLUP method of
computing aggregate growth measures for schools and LEAs, and also to summarize findings of our
empirical study of this method using growth data from California. Next slide, please.
So I can give a very brief background on how we got here. These aggregate growth measures,
which I'll abbreviate AGMs, are intended to summarize student achievement progress for
schools and local educational agencies. And a standard approach to computing AGMs is a
simple average of all the individual student growth scores available for a school or LEA
in a particular school in a particular school year for a particular subject. For example,
if a school had 100 students with mathematics growth scores in spring 2019, the simplest method
to compute the mathematics AGM for that school in 2019 is just the average or mean of those 100
growth scores. Of course, this method is straightforward, but it does have a downside.
Specifically, simple averages that are based on very few scores are less accurate than those based
on many scores. As a result, AGMs for schools or LEAs serving smaller numbers of students
are less accurate than those who are serving larger numbers of students. So I want to provide
a concrete example that I hope will help to convey what I mean by accuracy of a simple average.
And for this example, we're going to consider school level average mathematics growth in spring
2019. So I went into the California growth data and I found two schools that both had average
mathematics growth on the scale of the residual gains of 22 points. One of these schools, which
I'll label school A, is very large and had over 1200 students with mathematics growth scores in
spring 2019. And alternatively, school B, is a very small school, had only 15 students with
mathematics growth scores in 2019. So these are two schools, the same average growth score,
but where that average is based on vastly different numbers of students. And I considered
what would happen to these averages if we were to think about removing just one of the growth
scores from the average. For example, suppose that a student was ill during the testing period in
2019 and didn't have a test score, or even more distantly, suppose that one student just happened
to miss testing back in 2018 and so wouldn't have a growth score in 2019. So for school A,
with where there's over 1200 growth scores, there's little sensitivity to just one score
being removed. And in fact, depending on exactly which score is removed, the possible values of
the AGM for the school range from 21.9 to 22.3. So very close to the original average of 22.
Thus, the presence or absence of a single individual growth score has a very minor
impact on the AGM for school A, because there's so many scores contributing to the average.
Next, please. For school B, it's a totally different story. If we think about taking away
just one of those 15 growth scores, you can make that average go anywhere from 11 up to 28,
depending on which specific score is taken out. So while the actual average based on all 15 is 22,
you can see very big changes to this average, resulting from just one score being removed.
So the idea is that average growth scores for smaller schools are much more sensitive to the
specific set of scores that are included in the average than averages for larger schools.
And this is roughly what we mean when we say that the accuracy of simple averages is lower
for smaller schools than it is for larger schools. Next slide.
So why do we care about accuracy? One of the most problematic side effects of low accuracy is that
it can cause excessive year to year fluctuation in the AGMs for the same school or LEA. For example,
a small school AGMs might bounce around a lot from year to year. And in fact, this issue was noted as
a key concern for CDE when examining simple average AGMs in the past. If the AGMs for a
school or LEA are very inconsistent from one year to the next, it can leave educators unsure about
how to make changes in response to the measures because they're sending inconsistent signals.
And this ultimately could cause people to lose trust in the measures because
they behave in ways that feel capricious. And a related problem caused by low accuracy is
that because accuracy is driven by the number of growth scores included in the AGMs, the measures
behave differently across schools or LEAs of different sizes. So think back to schools A and
B in the previous example. The AGMs for school B, which has very few student growth scores each year,
are almost certainly going to fluctuate a lot more from year to year than those for school A.
And these kinds of disparities can again erode credibility and perceived fairness
of the reporting system. In addition, these problems caused by low accuracy can be even
more pronounced for AGMs that are computed for specific student groups within schools and LEAs,
such as students with disabilities or socioeconomically disadvantaged students,
because there may be many schools or LEAs serving relatively small numbers of students in particular
groups. Thus, for relatively rare student groups, low accuracy can be severe and widespread.
So given this background, next slide please. Given this background, I and some colleagues at ETS
have been developing an approach to improve the accuracy of AGMs. It's called the Empirical Best
Linear Prediction Approach, or EBLUP for short. Not the best acronym, but it is well established
in the statistical literature. The idea for EBLUP is that it is intended to improve accuracy of the
AGMs for each school in each year. And if we can improve accuracy, hopefully it also will improve
year-to-year stability as a result. And in addition to that, hopefully reduce disparities
in both accuracy and stability of the AGMs between small and large schools or LEAs. Next slide.
I'm going to briefly summarize what the EBLUP method is and how it works.
First, just like simple averages, it starts with the raw material of individual student-level
growth scores, here residual gains in mathematics and ELA. The method doesn't alter these growth
scores at all. In other words, EBLUP is not a new or different growth model. It takes the same input
that the simple averages do, but it is a method for computing AGMs from these individual growth
scores that goes beyond simple averages with the goal of improving accuracy and ultimately
year-to-year stability of the measures. Next. So to describe how this method works,
I'm going to imagine the goal of computing the mathematics AGM for one school in the 2018-19
school year. And as I said previously, the simple average method of computing the AGM would just
take the average of the mathematics growth scores for the school students in the 2018-19
school year. Alternatively, the EBLUP combines that information with not only the mathematics
growth scores for those students as well as the ELA growth scores for those students in 2018-19
and mathematics and ELA growth scores for those school students in one or more prior school years.
And more concretely, the EBLUP is approximately a weighted average of all of these sources
information. And the reason that a weighted average can improve accuracy is because these
other sources of information indirectly contain information about the school's average mathematics
growth in 2019. For example, go back, I'm still on the previous slide.
For example, if we look across the whole state, we can observe that schools that have high average
mathematics growth in 2018-19 also tend to have high average ELA growth. Thus, ELA growth is
indirectly informative about math growth. And likewise, if we look across the whole state,
we can observe that schools with high average mathematics growth in spring 2019 also tend to
have high average mathematics growth in the previous school year. So again, a school's
average growth from the prior school year is indirectly informative about its average growth
in the current school year. And so EBLUP is a method for incorporating this indirect information
via a weighted average when it is needed to improve accuracy. Next slide.
So this naturally leads to the question of how the method determines the weights to use for this
weighted average. And in short, the weights are tailored to each individual school or LEA and are
determined using a mathematical formula that provides the weights that attempt to maximize
the accuracy of the AGM for each school and LEA. For example, when calculating the mathematics
AGM for a particular school in 2018-19, the EBLUP method uses mathematical formulas to determine a
set of weights specific to this school and specific to mathematics that tries to make the resulting
mathematics AGM for the school as accurate as possible. And probably the most important thing
to understand about the weights is that they're adaptive to sample size. Specifically, when an
AGM for a given year and subject is an average over many students, like sports or sports,
is an average over many students, like school A, that average gets almost all of the weight in the
EBLUP and this indirect information is largely ignored. But when the AGM would be based on
fewer students, more weight is given to the other sources of information to try to make up for the
fact that the simple average based on few students has low accuracy. Next slide.
I thought it would be useful to actually provide a concrete example, returning back to this example
of school A and school B. These are, again, two schools that had the same average mathematics
growth in 2018-19, but school A had over 1,200 student growth scores contributing to that average
where school B had only 15. And the table shows how the EBLUP method allocates weight to different
sources of information when computing the mathematics AGM for each of these two schools in 2018-19.
There are four rows and one for each source of growth data and the top row is the mathematics
growth scores from 2018-19. These are the scores that would be used in the simple average and the
other three rows are the indirect growth data that EBLUP tries to use to improve accuracy.
So we have the ELA growth data from 18-19 as well as the mathematics and ELA growth data from the
previous school year. For school A, the EBLUP puts almost all of the weight on the first row.
As a result, for this school, the EBLUP is almost exactly equal to the simple average of the school's
mathematics growth scores from 2018-19. And the reason it allocates weight in this way is because
the simple average based on over 1,200 students is already very accurate and there is almost nothing
to be gained by incorporating the indirect information. And this is in contrast to school B
where just over 50 percent of the weight is on the first row and the remaining weight is split
across the other sources of indirect information. This is because school B with only 15 growth
scores and the simple average of these scores has fairly low accuracy and so the EBLUP tries
to put extra weight on these other sources of indirect information in an attempt to make
the AGM mathematics measure for the school as accurate as possible. Next slide please.
Next slide please. So with this background, I want to discuss some key findings of a study
in which we analyzed over 17 million individual growth scores from California students
to compare the EBLUP weighted averages to simple averages to understand whether and how much the
EBLUP method improves accuracy and improves year-to-year stability. We provided a technical
report and presentation of these studies findings to the technical design group last month and today
I'm just going to summarize some of the key findings. The first thing we wanted to look at
is to what extent does using the EBLUP weighted averages improve cross-year stability of AGMs
relative to simple averages? In other words, to what extent does EBLUP weighted averages,
what to what extent do they fluctuate less from year to year for the same school or LEA
than simple averages fluctuate? And as noted previously, this issue of cross-year stability
has been a core concern when developing the growth model and associated reporting and so
it was a key part of our evaluation. So this table summarizes some of the results regarding
year-to-year stability at the school level and this is just a slice of the full results and
more details are available in the attachment that we've submitted to the board.
The three rows of the table correspond to splitting schools into three size categories
based on the number of students with mathematics growth scores they had in 2018-19.
The first row is for small schools quote-unquote where the number of growth measures is between
11 and 29 and just to be clear schools with 10 or fewer growth measures are not considered here
because AGMs for these schools wouldn't be reported. The next row is for the medium-sized
schools and the last row contains all of the larger schools and now look at the middle column.
The middle column is for simple averages and the numbers here are correlations
between a school's simple average mathematics AGM from spring 2018 and the school's simple
average mathematics AGM from spring 2019. The correlation can be thought of as a measure of
stability of the AGMs across years and larger values of the correlation mean stability is
higher or that fluctuation is lower and looking at the middle column for the simple averages we
see that the correlation is lowest for the smallest schools and highest for the largest schools
which is consistent with the fact that simple averages are less accurate for smaller schools
and we know that lower accuracy decreases year-to-year stability. The last column provides
the corresponding correlations for the e-blups and we see that these correlations are larger
for all the school size categories meaning that the e-blup measures fluctuate less from year to
year for the same school than the simple averages do and also note that looking at the first row
e-blup creates the largest improvements in stability for the smallest schools which is what we want
because what this does is decrease the disparity in year-to-year stability across schools of
different sizes so e-blup hit the school level improves stability overall and reduces disparities
in stability across schools serving different sizes of student populations. Next slide please.
This is analogous but this is at the LEA level rather than school level and again we broke the
LEAs into three size categories and we consider in the middle column the year-to-year correlations
of the simple averages and in the last column the year-to-year correlations of the e-blups
and very similar to what we saw with schools, e-blup improves cross-year stability particularly
for smaller LEAs. It has almost no effect on stability for large LEAs because in that case
the e-blups are extremely similar to the simple averages because as many of the sample sizes there
are extremely large. Next slide. So those are the key findings regarding year-to-year stability. Now
I want to present some results on accuracy. e-blup is a method that theoretically is designed to
improve accuracy and we wanted to see to what extent these theoretical benefits were actually
realized with California growth data. And as before here's a slice of results for school level
mathematics AGMs and again we broke the schools into size categories and for each size category
we computed the percentage of schools for which the e-blup method improves accuracy
relative to the simple average. And these percentages are in the last column and make
clear that e-blup is actually improving accuracy for all schools regardless of size.
The attachment to the board agenda provides some more details about the actual magnitudes of these
accuracy improvements but just to summarize, consistent with the theory, e-blup has relatively
large accuracy improvements for smaller schools and then the size of the accuracy improvement
goes down as school size gets larger. So next slide. So the story is actually less clean at
the LEA level. This table here is analogous to the previous one but is now at the LEA level and again
we use three size categories. And we see that e-blup does improve accuracy for all the smaller
LEAs but unfortunately this is not the case for larger LEAs. Specifically there are some larger
LEAs for which the e-blup is actually less accurate than the simple average. To be clear,
the simple averages in e-blups are extremely similar for large LEAs so it's not as if the
e-blup method is producing bad or misleading results, it's just that whatever additional
changes or adjustments it's making to the simple averages don't appear to provide any benefit in
terms of accuracy and in fact for many large LEAs are reducing accuracy by a small amount.
So next slide, last slide actually.
Next slide please. So as a result of these findings CDE is recommending further evaluation
of options for reporting AGMs for large LEAs because the goal is to provide the most accurate
possible AGMs for all LEAs and right now the e-blup is not quite there. And with that I will stop and
take questions. Well we do have one more slide before we go to questions. Oh sorry. I just wanted
to point out though that the TDG is in alignment with the department's recommendation. So if we
if ETS does this additional work that's going to modify our timeline. So I wanted to be very clear
that this additional work will push the timeline for when we can release the growth model. So
with this additional work we will not be bringing a growth model to the board for approval until
the March 2021. That means we'll release the data based on prior CAFS data from 2016 to 2019 for
informational purposes only in April of 2021. And then from April 2021 through November 2022
we will work with LEAs and stakeholders on communications trying to figure out the best
way to display the data, provide hopefully some tools for LEAs to use as they talk with their
schools and with their parents and community. Then when we produced the dashboard in December
of 2021 it's really important to understand that we will not have another set of growth scores
and that we will continue to use the academic indicator methodology that is currently on the
dashboard and this is because in order to get a growth score you have to have two consecutive years
of data. So we won't have that until December of 2022 and that's when we will have the CAFS data
from 21 and from 22 and that's how we'll get that growth score. So with that we'll open it up for
technical questions. All right are there clarifying questions from anyone?
I'm going to use wait time. I know you've all been calculating. Here we go Patricia and then Sue
and then Cynthia. Patricia. Well I want to begin by thanking you for doing this presentation
and for trying to lower the register of English that you used for explaining the statistical model.
So my clarifying question is and I'm especially concerned and first of all I'm impressed but I'm
especially concerned about the differences on how the model works between small schools and large
schools. On some previous developments on the conversation about growth models we've heard from
department staff about the fluctuations or the instability that does happen for these smaller
schools. I want to be clear that what you're recommending that this eBLIP could do is over
time smooth there would be smoothing in the growth curve over time that would take care
of these fluctuations for the differences when students drop in or drop out at small schools
so that or are you saying that the model would not be intended to allow comparisons
among schools and that the data for small schools has to be considered separate and differently
from the data that this would report for larger schools. Okay I'll take that there were actually
two questions there the first question is was about what effect this method would have on
the annual measures provided for smaller schools and yes there were two questions I'm that good so
yeah okay so the first question is from what we've seen so far the method will reduce the
amount of fluctuation that is observed from year to year in measures provided to small schools
and the second question was about comparability these measures ought to be as comparable at
least as comparable across schools of different sizes as simple averages would be and one might
argue that they are even more comparable because the method reduces the disparity in accuracy of
the measures across large and small schools now you can't get around the fact that you're always
going to have more accuracy in school in schools like school a with 1200 growth scores versus
schools like school b if you compare the simple averages for those two types of schools you don't
really know what you're going to get because the simple average for school b is so unstable and low
accuracy the e-blop method does reduce that disparity to some extent and so I don't think
that there is any more or less uh comparability across schools with the e-blop method and if
anything it would probably make numbers more comparable okay and then my final question so
when I see this report what I'm supposed to understand or what I'm supposed to be able
to glean and conclude from the information the report will give us is growth over time
at the school or the student level based on the scores that were used to create it
it's the inferences at the school level would be inferences about the average growth for students
in that school in a particular year in a particular subject and go ahead go ahead no go I'm sorry I
interrupted you I haven't a little bit of an echo go ahead okay the the method um is not intended to
alter or uh make reporting down at the student level any more or less reliable because it doesn't
alter the growth scores for individual students it just changes how they're aggregated to produce
average growth score measures for lea's and schools and subgroups within those entities
okay thank you very much this was very helpful for me thank you okay thank you so I just want
to clarify that we would not be reporting growth at the student level but at the student group level
just to be clear
uh the next person I have in the queue is Cynthia and Sue did you have your hand up earlier yeah
right right after Cynthia then Cynthia thank you thank you very much and I believe Sue had
her hand up before me okay that's modeling a good etiquette
so you're next
you want me to go yeah please so I would just say um echo what uh member Rucker said
I really appreciate the presentation it helped to clarify many questions for me um so these are
sort of future questions assuming that we do additional study I wonder whether you've looked
at um how this model affects student growth I mean for student group changes
whether it helps in that regard or if you've modeled that at all and then the second question
is I assume that if we were to adopt this that when we have science test scores we potentially
have the same challenge and we'd have to do some kind of weighted average smoothing once those
science test scores become available thank you okay I'll take both of those questions
on the first one our report did look at the performance of the method for estimating
average growth for socioeconomically disadvantaged students and students with disabilities
not surprisingly since many schools have small counts of those particular groups of students
um the method does greatly improve year-to-year stability for the averages for
those uh subgroups of students and that is detailed in our attachment as well as our report to the
tpg um if there are regarding science scores if there is a way to use the science scores to
compute growth in science uh the method theoretically has no limitation with respect to
stacking together individual growth scores across multiple subjects
I don't know enough about the details of how science is going to be
fielded to know whether science growth scores would be possible to compute
okay um I think next we have Cynthia and then I have Ting and I have Eileen thank you um again
just appreciate the information and really the efforts being made to increase the accuracy
and stability of the scores I know I may be preaching to the choir to say um the accuracy
of the scores is so critical as LEAs are writing their plans on how to best address student group
performance and individual students so again the data is as stable and as accurate as the data is
as good as the plans can be to support students overall so again just appreciate just the continual
look at how to make that happen I was concerned and appreciative of the indication on I believe
the last couple of slides about the impact of the EBLIP to larger LEAs and how that level of accuracy
is not as high as we would see for the moderate and the medium and the smaller LEAs
you did mention JR that there were some additional evaluation measures that
would be looked into to really look at how to best increase the accuracy of using the EBLIP
with larger LEAs okay do you have any information right now on what some of those additional
evaluation measures might be that will be explored yes um we haven't done the work yet but
the idea of the EBLIP is that it is intended to improve accuracy when you're starting with a simple
average that wouldn't be very accurate it is not intended to make the averages for large school
districts where growth scores may be based across tens of thousands of students it is not intended
to make those growth scores more accurate so the things that we are considering are figuring out
ways of simply not using the EBLIP for really large districts and there are a couple ways
of implementing that type of decision rule but the idea is that the method wasn't designed to improve
simple averages for very large school districts therefore we shouldn't be using this method to
report simple averages for large school districts so we are exploring ways of coming up with a
decision rule to decide when a district is large enough we wouldn't use the EBLIP would rather
just stick with a simple average but we have not explored the implications of those decision rules
yet thank you and i had one other question it actually is more a question for clarification
for jenny um you mentioned uh that the timeline would be uh let's say pushed out a bit to provide
more opportunity for exploration can you repeat for me the impact of this timeline change on
the dashboard and when districts may begin to see the growth measures in the dashboard
and again the goals that have been set out from doing this work
just some clarification jenny you said it i'm sure i just want to hear it again sure um so
we had intended to release the growth scores in january for informational purposes only
so instead we'll be releasing them in april that will give districts some time to um to look at
um and to look at the growth scores and we can have conversations with them about how we could
report it so that it's easy for people to understand and we actually had a meeting with
kabe a couple of weeks ago and they have offered to help us put together some parent groups
when this comes out so that we would have some parent groups from kabe for parents who have
children who are english learners and then they can help us try to come up with a model for
communicating this out to parents as well so we're really excited about that
but for the it the soonest that it could be incorporated into the dashboard
would be december of 2022 because that's when we would have our next set of growth scores
based on 20 21 spring assessments and 2022 spring assessments
okay um next i have ting eileen and matt ting i i just want to um echo all of my colleagues
and thank you for the presentation it was actually one of the more clear
and concise explanation of the e-blip um that i've heard so far so thank you
um i have a couple of questions and one comment um related to um what cynthia just said
um what cynthia just said with questions about the release in 2021 22 so first let me go to that
first the i'm you know we're all concerned i'm sure that uh because of the skipping of the 2020
administration of the test it's we won't know what we get in 2021 and so i wonder that you know we
will be looking at um approving the model based on the the 2016 2019 scores so that we can kind
of see how the model works on those scores um but then you know i think we might get very different
results for 21 22 um just because we may not be comparing apples and apples given that we've got
this one year skipping and i just don't understand you know i don't know how you know technically
what that would mean and maybe we just need to wait and see what happens um with that and
before we make any policy decisions um the other um the other question i had i think i may have
under misunderstood um i was really disappointed in the conversation at the last board meeting
because i thought we would not get individual student growth scores but it does sound like
we will have individual student growth scores upon which to base these averages we're just not
publicizing them so uh or we're not not reporting them but are we going to report them at um the
school level or we're not even going to report them in the individual student reports and um
or is that an ongoing conversation we need to have so i was curious about that so let me
address the first question about the one year skipping of assessments of course when we get
the new growth scores in we would have to come back to the board to take up and we would take
a look at them and do some analysis to determine if we want to move forward with incorporating
into the 20 um the 2022 dashboard or if we want to make adjustments or if we want to delay
so it will not be put into the dashboard unless we have another conversation
based on the results that we see from 21 and 22.
In regards to your second question i don't think that we've made a decision about
student level data and providing it to LEAs
we we will not be putting that information on the student growth report students already have a
growth report that that our assessment division has put a lot of thought in and has been well
received and is well understood by parents now we are not going to make adjustments to those
student growth reports there is some discussion about whether we will put it in the data file
that we give to LEAs but if a decision has not been made on that there are some concerns that
were expressed by people in the field that if districts receive that they would use that to do
evaluations on teachers and of course districts aren't allowed to use that data to do to do teacher
evaluations so i think that's an ongoing conversation that we're going to be having
over the next few months um i hope that answers your questions team it does it just um i i you
know i'm hoping that this doesn't just tell us what um more on student aggregate but i was hoping
that this growth model might help provide actionable data on a student level for LEAs
and classrooms and so i um you know i don't know i know we need to have more conversations on that
so i appreciate it okay we will come back to those topics i am quite sure um eileen um thank you um i
just first um thank you so much for this presentation and for the ongoing work to try
to get this right um i have a question jenny about um the disaggregate um for the student
suburbs so my understanding from the presentation is that we um in the analysis it was disaggregated
for students with disabilities and socioeconomically disadvantaged did we also um do any disaggregation
around all our other our english learners our our febs are to see if this is actually reliable
and accurate around the subgroup data that's my first question and secondly you said that the
plan is to release subgroup data um when we release this data so i just want you to expand on that
i can take that if you wish jenny
sure um so we looked at uh those are the two groups of students that we did look at in addition to
all students and we we did this only because we had a limited number of limited resources
to do the analysis and we're still in the stage of sort of finalizing the methodology and making
sure it makes sense and for example the decision rule about how to report these numbers for large
lea's is still pending the method absolutely does apply and can be applied to all the student
subgroups that are important to track in california and we have intention to use the method to produce
those numbers as soon as we finalize the exact under the hood details of the method i have started
to look at it a little bit for um some of the less prevalent uh racial ethnic subgroups and so far i
have seen no indication that the method is doing anything other than very much helping the accuracy
of those numbers okay um and i'm sorry jenny yeah i just jenny what's the plan at this point for what
data would be then released and reported would all the subgroup data for all the groups that we
report on be available to lea's we would we would we would release the data for all the student
groups that we currently provide data on and that also includes um separating out
as you know right now um on our detailed report we do provide data separately for el's rfx and
english-only students and we would provide that same in april so all student groups thank you
thank you okay i have matt and then patricia and i day thank you so i'll be really quick as
board member sung and board member glover had had covered the questions i initially had but i do
want to thank you for this report this it was immensely helpful for me the growth model has
been a long time coming and local educators have been asking for this for some time and it's amazing
when you go back into the timeline jenny how hard and how long cd has been working to get this right
and i appreciate the reality that we're trying to improve the accuracy of these these scores
prior to putting it in front of our districts where they're going to make decisions about how
to improve so i appreciate it very much and the only comment i would add would be to board member
sun's comment that i know that we have a decision decision to make about individual student scores
and i know that there's some concern as jenny as you'd pointed out around how those scores might
be used but i think that we my food for thought would be just consideration for the reality that
if we want districts to be able to improve and support their students i don't necessarily believe
that it's in in in their best interest or students best interest to hold back data that could be
helpful well that's all i have to say thank you for the report though it's very good very nice
very very informative great patricia and then i day
and hopefully at that point we can move on to the next item
with respect president darling ham and since i'm asking a question for the second time i'd i'd let
i i would like to let i day go first and then i'll i'll come back all right we are modeling good
etiquette this morning i day thank you so much board member wrecker and thank you for the
presentation and i just want to what i was going to say has been said but i just want to echo how
important it is to you know be able to break down the data so it'll be useful for us especially
with our large english learner population that we're able to see you know the the data broken down
with you know the rfs and the el within this model and i'm glad to see that it's
that this was just a sample but that it can all be done so thank you terrific and patricia
okay thank you very much i just want to just ask a clarifying question and also make a comment
concerning the how the data that's being reported at the individual student level
if i heard correctly and i'm asking the um either the staff or the presenter who i explained the
model to us to clarify this because i believe i'm going to make a misstatement here there is
this issue about the model and how it works with very large school districts and i think i heard
in the presentation that some consideration has to be made for deciding whether or not to use this
model at all with very large school districts by define by creating criteria that defines very large
is that did i misunderstand that oh that's exactly accurate okay so this would be my concern about
what i'm hearing my colleagues on the board saying about what is good what could be given
to school district there is a possibility going forward with this model that we're already going
to be differentiating what what is reported for all school districts in the state so i'm not sure
what is the utility for providing data to some schools that will be whose data and statistics
about student performance will be analyzed by this model while other school districts that
serve very large and significantly a significantly large portion of our student population overall
will not have that same information so while i think it's important to have that conversation
i think it's also equally important to be aware of what we're differentiating and what we're
trying to provide in a uniform and consistent way so that the conversation about student performance
is also uniform and consistent across the models that we're trying to implement here so that's the
only thing i wanted to say about that chair go ahead okay i was going to take this i i apologize
if i was not clear there the idea for large school districts wouldn't be to simply not report
averages it's just a matter of which exact methodology is going to be used to compute the
average that's reported right the idea for a large school district is just taking the simple average
of the growth scores either for all students or even particular subgroups of students those numbers
are already going to be highly accurate so that is what would be reported and the e-blot method
would just not be used to produce the averages but it wouldn't be the case that districts
wouldn't get those averages reported it's just a matter of changing the count switching back
to the sort of simple average approach for that reporting rather than relying on the e-blot method
which is designed to improve accuracy for cases where the averages would not be based on many
students so just to underscore everybody gets the same data yeah yeah everyone yes okay so no that's
helpful uh let me uh if if by the time you are ready to start writing this report and producing
this information the thing i love about you mathematicians and statisticians you love to
use those big 24 dollar words so if i'm still on the board when you are are putting this report
together as a former high school english teacher let me help you write it in english for the rest
of us who don't understand or translate it for you for into english for a standardized english
for the rest of us who don't understand what you just explained i get it but that's not going to
be clear going forward and lost somehow in the details of all this technical stuff so i think
it's very important for us to think about not only what you're reporting but how that's framed
i understood what you were saying and i missed that point so thank you very much
all right i think we have gotten our clarifying questions in thank you again for that wonderful
and clear presentation and um we have one more set of um accountability items
great i'm gonna turn this over to jonathan isler in just a moment but before we get started on on
the specifics of this education code section i just wanted to provide some framing remarks
based on the correspondence we continue to receive on this this section of code and the first data
set that we're going to talk about that's available it's it's evident to us that reporting out on on
data around teachers is is very important to to the field and to of course the board and so it
it's not only limited to this code section we have an obligation to report this out because of the
sark we have an obligation to report this out to help districts with their local control and
accountability plans and so i want to make sure that the framing of this is much broader than
just this one code section and we know based on prior experience specifically around discipline
data and the release for the first time of suspension data by student groups how much
of an impact that makes for the field it doesn't have to be part of an accountability system
to make um to make differences in schools and districts we saw with the release of that data
file prior to coming even into the accountability system actionable uh practices that affected
students and we saw we've seen a steady decrease over the last several years if not
since the data was first put out of suspension um suspensions of students for specific student
groups and so just to put that framing in mind um we're really excited about the data set that
jonathan's going to talk about today um but we just need to get the data set out and i think
that that will be the start of the conversation around this education code section and our
obligations to implement it great thank you hopefully everyone can hear me good morning
everyone members of the board president darling hammon i just wanted to personally wish karen
staff walters well we miss you a lot and i've really enjoyed working with you the last several
years so good luck to you so i'm jonathan eisler i am the administrator for the data visualization
and reporting office at the cde and i work directly with cindy in the accountability division
wanted to talk this morning about california education code section 52064.5 as all of you
know this was passed many years ago and required the state board on or before october 1st 2016
to adopt what were then known as evaluation rubrics of course now we know better known
as the california school dashboard as a tool to help districts and schools identify strengths and
weaknesses and to provide assistance to county superintendents in identifying school districts
and charter schools that needed technical assistance as part of this context these
state and local measures are actually drawn from the 10 priority areas of the local control funding
formula or lcff which is also required in california education code 52064.5 last year in 2019
california senate bill 75 updated that education code with additional information about local
indicators so just as a refresher for everyone these are the list of the different priority
areas and local indicators under lcff obviously all of these are important but this morning our
focus is going to be really primarily on priority one the basics and looking at text textbook access
and availability school facilities and good repair and in particular talking about appropriately
assigned and fully credentialed teachers as cindy mentioned it's really important to note
that this information is required annually in the school accountability report cards or sarx
and that information is going to continue to be reported this this current year and ongoing so
just wanted to provide that additional background and context for the state and local indicators
so senate bill 75 like i said was passed in 2019 it does provide a time frame and some direction
on the consideration for inclusion of indicators in our accountability system quote no later than
january 31st 2021 local indicators shall reflect school level data to the extent the department
collects or otherwise has access to relevant and reliable school level data for all schools
statewide and what's really important here is that relevant and reliable
school level data which we'll talk about in a little bit so the cd has been reviewing the
different local indicators and in particular we identified priority area one that appropriate
assigned and fully credentialed teachers as a data set that could potentially be it is being
collected for the first time right now and we're looking into the fact that it may meet the
standards under sb 75 for local indicators so again right now very much in an exploratory phase
of looking how this how this may may be an important part of sb 75 for local indicators
so we're going to talk through in the coming slides just make clear that we do not currently
have a current full data set to do analyses to determine how reliable these data are for all
schools statewide so in 2018 the cd and the california commission on teacher credentialing
or ctc we entered into a data sharing agreement or mou for teacher and credential data and by
which we provide them with staffing information and they were they will now enter that information
into their california statewide assignment accountability system or cal sas in order to
conduct teacher monitoring the ctc when they receive these data will match these with their
credential data and provide indicators to the cd in order to meet our essa or every student
succeeds act reporting requirements and this is based on the what was approved by the state board
in their november 2019 meeting so this is an exchange timeline of what has been going on
since 2018 i do have really good news to report for that last item in just a minute here so in
october 2018 we did sign a memorandum of understanding a data sharing agreement formalizing our data
sharing last year in july we implemented an overhaul of our course codes in calpads
so in our longitudinal data system so this basically changed the way that these course
data was entered into calpads by lea's that was originally scheduled to close in march of 2020
and then as i mentioned in november of 2019 the state board adopted the teacher equity definitions
under essa as well as made recommendations about state reporting requirements and then of course
march 2020 comes and covid 19 hits so there were delays in the reporting of the calpads data
the fall 2 submission deadline was then extended to april 24th then this spring and summer april
through july cde spent extracting the data and then the last couple months so july into just
recently cde staff including from our accountability division have been working with calpads staff with
our it folks to extract the calpads data and the good news is as of this week so just a couple days
ago the cde was able to successfully transfer these data over to the ctc so we're very excited
about that the last slide i just wanted to present here in terms of the process is now that we have
provided the data to ctc they have a two-phase process by which they can then produce the final
data that they can send back to us in terms of assignment of staff so the first phase is for each
assignment in the initial calpads assignment data set they indicate whether the educator was
properly assigned or misassigned and if in and if there is a misassignment which dimensions of of
that that is indicated this is it's really important to note that that first phase of the
of the data processing the cd ctc conducts is not sufficient for what we need to do for essa
reporting so i just want to make that really clear that's the first phase of the data processing
after they are able to accomplish phase one phase two will occur where they will then match the
data with their credential data and provide necessary indicators to back to cde in order
to meet our essa reporting requirements so as of right now we anticipate that the ctc will accomplish
these by early next year and then at that point the cde will have access to that data to begin
doing simulations to look into the validity and reliability of that data so that is my portion
of the presentation
we open it up to questions so we can i think either open up to questions or we can open up
the whole item to to questions whatever your preference is president helman do you have
anything else in this section or prior to public comment the item sorry it concludes the item
right okay great so what i'd like to do is just take clarifying questions on this portion
and then we'll get hear from our liaisons we'll open to public comment and then we'll have a
fuller discussion so that we save our full discussion until after we have our public comment
um so are there uh any um questions clarifying questions on this i see patricia's hand is up
patricia
did you intend for your hand to be up for this
i'm not hearing patricia where did she go i'm not seeing patricia i'm here
oh i i'm what i said was i apologize i had put my raised my hand because he was as he was closing
down his comments but he answered my question about what the next steps from the commission
were going to be so i don't the question i don't have that question anymore i apologize i didn't
lower my hand that's okay thanks um i do have a question and um anybody else does i'll keep the
matt will have one also um so first of all jonathan uh thanks so much for the very good news
you know i'm extremely excited about this uh when i was chair of the commission on teacher
credentialing we were having these conversations about sharing the data the fact that the data has
been successfully shared for those of you who have been watching this gripping um you know uh drama
that has been unfolding for several years is a big big deal so thank you jonathan i know you've
played an important role in that um and i just wanted to um return not only to the um state law
around reporting in priority one but to the essa plan where we also will need to be reporting
based on our educator equity plan um the proportion of teachers who are on waivers permits
um and then according to our educator equity plan interns fully credentialed and among
fairly credentialed teachers those who are um assigned properly and misassigned
so i just want to clarify that while those analyses are going on the all of that will
be happening uh in that time frame
thank you yeah so um thank you president don hamman so um as of right now um we do not
anticipate that we're going to be able to to report that for the equity plan until
following year right no um next year i think is what is what you're asking about um whether or
not the essa reporting requirements would extend out to priority one so essa has um more components
than um basics does on priority one and and i i was trying to to preempt that with my opening
comment that um we we anticipate that uh what what is needed to report out on not only sarc and
and and essa and then this component that we report on on the full data set that is available
and the first step of course is simply to meet our federal reporting requirements
and that deadline is is february of this coming this coming year so 2021 um you know assuming
that we get um these two phases of the ctc is able to complete them in a timely manner
they do have an extensive process ahead of them to to work with the data it's very complex data
but our goal is to get out a complete data set that could be used for a variety of purposes
right and isn't it um don't go away cindy because i just want to be sure we're i've understood this
part um yeah part of our requirement to the feds is also to be able to say we had a had to tell
them how we were going to identify ineffective teachers etc inexperienced teachers and teachers
who are out of field and we defined an effective as teachers on waivers and permits um who are you
know not preliminarily credentialed so that is actually easier to analyze than the
misassignment data which requires matching up by course codes that i know that's very complicated
and the ctc has those data readily available so am i understanding you that that will be
analyzed by them in this same round of analyses yes so the the first phase is of course to engage
with this new system that that ctc has um piloted in in the i think this this past spring to have um
lea's you know proactively talk about um whether or not the educator was properly assigned the the
greater detail and the amendments that you made to the estate plan last november is on the ctc's
plate for phase two so there i know that they're trying to do this in a somewhat parallel process
but um we understand you know they know the requirements that that you have laid out under
essa this is the the careful dance between state agencies um where we we work together
but i anticipate we'll have that that full file um you know whether it's the end of this year or
early next year to meet all the components that you have to meet all the components and then when
we do our sark we'll be able to you know we have these requirements coming in we've we've put them
in place in different plans and in different places under esa under our educator equity plan
under the state priorities but it makes sense to kind of put them all together in one reporting
place um in the sark i assume is where that would be is that your understanding
so the sark is always one year in a rear so we do already have the sark data so that that data will
be provided but i think what she's asking she's suggesting jonathan is to have an extended a
report out of what's currently in the sark um so that you know the board has the responsibility
of adopting that template every july and so we'll bring that back to you in july of 2021
if you decide to expand out on on you know the legal statute around that um but i think it
makes sense to have the same data set available in each of the places in which it lives instead of
you know like like i mentioned this is a data set and if we're going to have just a portion of it
someplace and another portion in another place it's not it's not really easy to find so no that is
work that would be ahead of us this spring as we prepared it to get the data set out just period
out on on data quests and then from there figure out where else we can populate it into those
areas where we know we have to report out on some version of staffing information right yeah that's
great i mean this has been a you know long time figuring it out but um the uh the ctc routinely
reports um in its own reports the teachers on waivers permits internships preliminary credentials
full clear credentials you know schools and districts need those data in order to understand
what they need to be doing in their educator equity plans which we're going to be asked
to approve shortly in this meeting um the plans that come up from the locals there's a lot of
desire for us to be able to give a clear rendering of what's going on on that very very important
component of equity if we don't know where we have to make investments to get a well-qualified
teaching force it's hard to figure out how we're going to make progress on those those agendas and
mrs simon is identified as one thing but it is actually the tiniest portion of the problem
it is not the major concern that a lot of communities have around um getting plans in
place to strengthen the teaching force so i just want to be sure that we're maintaining a clear
focus on how to bring all these pieces together because they've been living as you said jonathan
in different places and we have to figure out how to put them together in a way that is useful
for the state and for local communities to address this really pressing set of issues so
thank you for the progress you're making um and we'll look forward to the pieces coming out
hopefully um as quickly as possible i know the ctc is working um as hard as they can on it so
eager for the next report and i know are there any other i was just going to say one other thing
and i know you know that we're in very regular contact with ctc staff on all of these items so
yeah yeah and we appreciate that and thank you so much for your report are there any other
clarifying questions before we begin to move to public comment all right um i'm going to ask that
you go ahead and put the public comment slide up um and then uh we will when that comes up we'll
open the phone line for the public comment uh queue and members can call in is that is that
there i've got so many screens open the dialing in number there yes linda it's up okay okay great
i have multiple screens covering each other so that i can see the people in the hands and the
and the slides um so while we're waiting for members of the public to call in because there
is a little bit of a lag time i want to ask super first and then eileen strouse as our accountability
liaisons if they have any initial framing comments and then we'll take public comment and then we'll
come back for discussion so thank you yeah sure um so first of all i just um sorry to remember
the very beginning but i would like to reinforce i think what cindy led with and i think it's so
important for all of us to realize the level and depth of outreach that the department staff and
the board staff do with our various stakeholder groups is really to be commended and they're very
thoughtful collaborative they take you know every minute of time that they have to try to make sure
that they're understanding people's concerns and to the extent they can addressing them in the
very complicated area so just wanted to say that as a as a start um and i think i don't need to
go into a lot of other detail i think we've had a full discussion actually of each one of the
components and when you're ready linda i'm happy to make a motion to approve the criteria for the
career measures terrific thank you eileen well let me just say um to cindy and jenny and the
entire cd team i just so appreciate how hard and how detailed focused and how clearly they're just
pursuing getting all of these um details correct and and relevant in our system and i just think
the outreach the communication just the work they did at cpeg and helping to explain everything
they just are just persistent and i just so appreciate all the work we're doing to get it
right um and i would make the second when we get ready for a motion okay you have dibs uh and so
now i'm going to see if there are public comments um for those who are making public comments we
encourage you please state your name and affiliation for the record please remember
to turn down the speaker volume of your computer if you're following the live feed
and speakers will be limited to one minute each are there public comments yes we currently have
13 people signed up for public comment i will go ahead and open the phone lines now
good morning caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
we have unmuted you and your time starts now i'm martin and i'm this executive director of
californians together one of our strategic priorities for the past few years is supporting
an accountability system that is coherent and effective for english learners for the past eight
months we have worked studied with dr pete goldschmidt he is a professor at cal state
northridge who has served as the assistant secretary for assessment and accountability
for the new mexico public education department as senior researcher at ucla crest focusing on
the use of growth models for accountability and evaluations and for the past three years
with the council of chief state school officers to provide state departments of education support
to develop and utilize growth models to monitor programs for english learners he has followed the
work of the growth model advisory committee and the state board and has submitted a paper with
recommendations that we are supporting and hope the board will recommend while further developing
california's future growth model thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
now
caller are you there
hello superintendent board members i'm pete goldschmidt professor in the school of education
at california state university in arthur my comments are based on the brief that was submitted
to you and considering your growth model is important to not only consider technical issues
about the model and potential adjustments such as smoothing but equally important to consider the
context in which it would be used and its purpose if goals are to monitor progress gaps and generate
actionable results and it is paramount that results are reported by substantively meaningful
subgroups specifically evidence suggests that the relationship between prior and current performance
is different for english language learners and reclassified english language proficient students
and their english-only classmates there are knowable differences as to why eels and rfps
may or may not progress like eos on academic content thus is important that all preliminary
as well as operational results are reported separately for eels and rfps el student success
does not end with reclassification so it is important to continue to monitor academic progress
so potential language barriers and progress can be identified effectively and efficiently thank you
thank you
next caller you're unmuted and your time starts now thank you good morning madame president of
the board dr linda harley and darlin hamans and members of the board superintendent of the schools
my name is carlina gilera fort and i am the superintendent of the schools of the author
school district i would like to advocate for the board to make sure that the reporting
of this process and this model separates eels from rfps as a school district superintendent i
really need the information for each year's staff and myself separated so that we can see
which one is the real progress of our eels and rfps and then determine what kind of instructional
strategies we will need including those two groups together will not allow us to look at
the different points of data and strengths in areas of need for the two different groups so i
really urge the board to look at the report and the thank you for your time with us two groups
separate thank you thank you
next caller you are in the you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning president darlin hamann and board members i'm dr marlene batista director of english
learner services for our school district in ventura county and an active board member of
cave i'm here to urge the board in their consideration of a growth model for california's
accountability system that english language proficiency be included in the calculations for
this model in a state like california and districts like ours where we have a little
less than half of our students are english learners utilizing lpac scores within the model
allows for better interpretation of residual performance gaps and changing gaps it is important
that we recognize that some of these gaps are largely due to the insufficient english language
knowledge skills and abilities of our english learners by including the lpac scores within the
growth model we will increase the coherence of the accountability system and showing progression
the lpac is important because it both informs us of the progress of our students english language
learning as well as how this language learning contributes to academic content learning i thank
you for your consideration and urge you to do the right thing by our english learners of california
and the many school districts who serve them thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
board president arlingham and members i'm shelly spiegel-kohler strategic advisor for californians
together and i want to address one of the recommendations from dr bolster's paper
in about including the english language proficiency level from lpac in the calculation of the growth
model for current english learners i continue to serve on the growth model stakeholder group
and understand the decision not to include demographics but we believe language proficiency
is different and that there is clear research that indicates language proficiency affects
academic achievement similar to the presentation that we had about the relationship of math and
lea scores setting growth for el's without considering their language proficiency
makes that unrealistic targets until english learners were reclassified we urge you to direct
the staff to do some modeling of the data without english with english language proficiency and
without to see the current implications on our current english learners which might suggest
the return of the definition of the el subgroup for accountability thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now good morning president darneen hammon and
members of the board i'm russ barajas with californians together i appreciate the leadership
of superintendent thurman and the cd staff for their great work and to dr goldschmidt to raise
some important points here the federal law mandates not only that we provide english language
development to el's but that we also monitor their progress and once they are reclassified
we monitor them for four years and more to effectively evaluate their progress we must
consider the expected growth trajectory for our reclassified students separate from el's
federal law also requires schools that have a function to have a functioning elac made up
of parents of english learners to advise the principal staff in the development of a site
plan that is responsive to the needs of the el's how will our parents be able to do this
without disaggregating data for el's how will they know if there are set students are meeting
expected growth targets parents want transparency so it's encouraging to hear that the cde is
working with cave and others to put together parent groups for engagement so now we have
the opportunity to adopt thank you callers model let's make it work thank you thank you
next caller you are muted and your time starts now state board members i'm evita armas director
at lmu center for equity for english learners i offer these comments in support of the brief
submitted by dr goldschmidt in operationalizing the residual gain model we urge the board to
avoid the unintended consequences of our current system that aggregates el's and our feds for the
academic indicator english learner subgroup although it's been stated that disaggregated
subgroup data can be reported we need to consider modifying the definition of the el subgroup for
academic indicators our examination of el dashboard results for this subgroup revealed that many
districts in the yellow category had high percentages of current el's in orange or red
thus diminishing the urgency for districts addressing their el's in the outcast only 57
inclusive of 14 coes receive differentiated assistance focused on el monitoring and reporting
our grip and el progress has separate subgroups has the potential to rebuild in targeted support
to address the needs of el students and foster intentional programs and services
time those opportunity and achievement gaps thank you for your time thank you
next caller you are needed and your time starts now
board president darling hammond and board members my name is martha martinez and i'm
the director of research and evaluation for steel i'm here to support the recommendations
described in dr goldschmidt's brief by including english proficiency levels in the growth model for
el the state would strengthen the validity of using english assessments of language arts and
mathematics for el a test in english is a test of english this has long been the rightful critique
of using english academic assessments to monitor el academic progress and this is a major reason why
rfp performance on s back test is so different from current el performance by taking el english
proficiency into account in academic progress as dr goldschmidt proposes we can create more
appropriate expectations for el and rfp progress and identify which schools are helping current
el's and rfp meet appropriate benchmarks and which schools are not thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning board president darley hammond and board members i am
policy associate at california together i'm calling her in regards to the recommendation
in goldschmidt's paper regarding the proposed empirical best linear prediction method
the sb should examine various options for stabilizing year-to-year growth
estimates before deciding on the best method it's important to consider the impact and trade-offs
between the eblp method and other methods specifically within the context of california
consideration should include overall stability stability by subgroups including both el's
and rfp relationship between any single year transparency and implementation factors and
interpretation for intended uses it may it may work it may very well be that the eblp method is
the most effective but it is important to present and review trade-offs against other potential
solutions for results presented by all relevant subjects thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now good morning martha ziragosa dies representing
the california association for bilingual education and californians together
dr goldschmidt's brief on the rg growth growth model reflects a broader vision of what it can
and should do please accept the recommendations contained in the brief including reporting
current el's and rfp separately including LPAC scores and the calculation of the model
and analyzing the impact of the model and stabilization techniques for current english
learners and rfs implementation of these recommendations in the development of the
rg growth model are critical in order to provide a more accurate analysis and data
regarding the growth and performance of our english learners let's make this work thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
now
hi my name is adam karenza mountain view elementary board of education
the el cap should be written to address our current el statewide and in our district there
is a need to accelerate and enhance the academic achievement of the el in our classrooms by only
including a performance level of rfs plus el the academic indicator will hide the urgent need to
be targeted with our approach to program services and allocation with our el cap funds focusing on
our current el mountain school district has done just that with a research-based pre-k to third
grade academic language model district wide but now we need to be able to follow those students
into the upper grades and see the success and possible remaining challenges by seeing year-to-year
match scores distinct for english learners and rfps in the growth model we would be able to
document growth and design what is needed for our el pre-k through eighth grade thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
my name is lexi lopez from ed voice and i'm commenting on the student growth model
thank you for releasing district level school level and subgroup data in december but we
encourage the board to release historic individual student growth records to districts and schools
using 2017-18 and 2018-19 data to help educators better understand how the growth measure works
ed voice also requests the board to require disaggregated english learner data english
learner and reclassified fluent english proficient subgroups have significantly different support
needs re-designated students are generally not likely to experience as much backside
as english learners recent reports from the la times have highlighted the inequities these
students groups have experienced during the pandemic and it's critical to state does all
it can to adequately track and support over 1 million el students we also recommend the
board direct staff to evaluate the use of a two-year residual gain measure of growth
that students made from spring 2019 to spring 2021 allow for comparison to past growth value
of the analysis would help the state and districts better understand the overall
learning loss and loss that individual students and subgroups may have experienced
including low english learners thank you so much thank you
next caller you are muted and your time starts now
good morning my name is jessica saco with children now i would first like to urge the
state board and cde to begin the process of developing objective criteria for both fully
credentialed and misassigned metrics of future quality as identified in priority one for the
release of the 21-22 dashboard the data would be is going to be available via our essay
reporting and it's critical that this information make its way to the dashboard and be incorporated
into the LCAP process next i'd like to thank you for the excellent technical work done around the
e-blip model i appreciate the presentation and the clarifications that have been provided today
we would like to suggest that the board does not have to wait to see actual data in order to talk
about communicating about the growth model or the use of growth data nor does it need the data in
order to have a conversation about how individual student data might be shared and the safeguards
that might be need to be put into place in order to be sure that it is used appropriately
finally measuring learning loss is going to be a critical need this year we need the board to
direct time to develop methods to ensure learning loss and include possibly looking at individual
student growth thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning uh president dollingham and board members john afel from public advocates
the i want to talk about the establishment of objective criteria for local indicators
the reporting in the sark and elsewhere is critical no doubt but what's important about
ed code section 52064.5 is that there be objective criteria established
for local indicators so that means both for misassignments and for fully credential
the state has the cd has data sets now on fully credentialed teachers in every school in the
state and we should be getting those objective criteria working now the misassignment data
we're glad to see that that is moving forward and it seems like with that time fully operational
in 2021 we want the board to take action at this meeting to make sure time that criteria get
established on september 2021 board meeting for next year's dashboard thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning president dollingham and superintendent thurman and members of the state board
i'm ishri aru senior director of field action and advocacy for link learning alliance the alliance
leads an education movement proven to help more students stay in school graduate on time and
develop the knowledge and skills employers seek for the future we submitted a letter but i would
like to reiterate how much we appreciate the work the state board of education and california
department of education staff have done on the college career indicator in particular we support
the continued efforts to add more robust career measures to the cci and we encourage consideration
of additional ways to provide recognition for students who complete both a college measure
and a career measure in the cci as opposed to one or the other as the build out of the cci moves
forward please know we are here to support your work and hope you will see us as a resource we
are happy to share our data research and other support materials whatever would be helpful as
you continue to develop a strong comprehensive and inclusive cci thank you thank you
you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning my name is lorraine richards and i represent california teachers association
we appreciate the cda's update and work plan regarding the implementation of education code
section 52064.5 related to local indicators as laid out in the item the cda's plan to process
analyze and report out the initial set of data under priority one is a thoughtful approach to
fulfilling the requirements of sb75 and the revised ed code priority one is comprehensive in nature
and the ability to have high quality data points for its local indicators is important to fulfilling
the basic services and conditions for the benefit of students cta supports the cte's plan approach
and we look forward to having additional discussions on the implementation of education
code section 52064.5 related to local indicators thank you thank you next caller you are unmuted
and your time starts now hello madam president this is brian reeves calling on behalf of the
education trust west about the growth measure we think this is one of the most important things
that you can add to the dashboard it's going to get a lot of attention when it comes out
and i think to that end to be most productive we would recommend that you take steps to ensure
broad consensus and buy-in to the methodology so we're requesting a lot of stakeholder input
lots of communication a lot of opportunities to ask questions about the eblip we don't want
to be in a situation when the data comes out of having disputes over the methodology we want
the emphasis to be at that point about supports to lea's that are showing problems and really
talking about what we need to do as a state to accelerate growth our partners at kabe and keltog
have been opinion leaders in this space so please work with them and listen to them which i think
you're already doing time and we support the recommendation to disaggregate english learners
and rfx thanks thank you next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good morning this is sarah lillis with teach plus california we just wanted to associate our
comments with those of our colleagues public advocates and children now to focus on to urge
the board to set recommendations for identifying objective criteria now on priority one the local
indicator we appreciate the really thoughtful conversation you had about the data but we believe
that we could begin discussions with stakeholders right now about what that objective criteria might
look like for fully credentials and misassigned metrics of teacher quality in priority one to be
included then in the 21-22 dashboard we also associate our we also want to support the
recommendations of our partners at keltog and kabe about again disaggregating english learners
and rfx in the growth model thank you thank you and next caller you are unmuted and your time starts
now good morning um dr sarla hammond and state board members my name is diane avu with the
association of california school administrators and we want to state our support for the inclusion
of dde's recommended career measures in the college career indicator we believe that these
measures will be will provide schools with districts and districts with the possibility of
reaching realistic but meaningful marks based on the well-earned humans of students particularly
the work-based programs further these additions for the cci advance the goals of ensuring the
indicator reflects both college and career readiness while we support the inclusion of
additional work-based post metrics and item two we urge the board to review and incorporate other
important metrics particularly for students who pursue less traditional path in college and career
this includes recognizing students as college and career ready and when they enroll in college
courses through dual enrollment and alternative education programs in addition as the board
reviews additional changes to the accountability system act to request the board consider active
time published in may 2019 thank you thank you uh next caller you're unmuted and your time starts now
good morning uh president darling hammond and members of the board this is liz dian
the public advocate and i'm testifying to reinforce a point from the equity coalition's letter
to talk about the two-year residual gain model there has been a lot said and done policy-wise
about learning loss the state will be investing billions of dollars targeting this learning loss
we think it's critical that there be a temperature check on the experience of learning loss and we
would like the board to direct staff to evaluate the use of a two-year residual gain measure of
growth that students had made from spring 2019 to spring 2021 and allow for comparison to pass
growth while this data would only be provided once the value of the analysis seems critical to
understand learning loss that students have experienced we also want to align our comments
around the english learner inclusion time with learner data thank you thank you
that concludes public comment for item number two
all right uh we're now open for board discussion uh so who would like to kick us off
well i i have some questions for staff oh here goes a hand uh patricia do you want to start us off
sure um the first of all i want to thank all the
stakeholders who called in on the to give public comment i know this process is kind of unwieldy
and so i appreciate not only the effort that was made to make the calls but also to participate
and offer the feedback i want to also express my um uh thanks my appreciation for californians
together i received i'm sure along with the other board members a copy of the information brief
that was prepared concerning the data system and the upgrade on what can be reported concerning
english learners and i read the full report with great interest and in listening to the
presentation that was made today it clearly there's a lot of new things that have happened
and a lot of new and exciting considerations on the development of the growth model that we didn't
have prior to today's meeting or at least that i wasn't aware of and i think a lot of work has gone
on moving forward to address this and some of the requests that they've made specifically was
what type of data can be reported about english learners is worth thinking about and considering
that got at the base that their their paper gets at the root of the question that i really
want to understand is what is the growth model actually going to report and what is what is it
that we're considering useful information there is a difference between what is useful and reported
to us about all students and what is useful and actionable when we start looking at disaggregated
student subgroups and so in listening to the reports and the information from the staff about
what their next steps were and are going to be i'm very clear that there's a lot of other work
that they're looking at on what the growth model will report and how it will function
at the student group level so the request that i'm reading in this paper and some of the
recommendations that i'm reading are not incompatible with some of the efforts that they
are proposing for their data models and the data runs that they are going to be making to
continue building out and testing the strength and the stability of what is reportable and doable
in this growth model so i'm going and and in saying i said all of this as a way of background
to suggest that maybe there are some things in this document in the brief that we receive
that are not incompatible with what the department staff are looking at doing
and continuing looking at the work and experimenting with reporting and the statistical modeling
for data and assessment information that will be in the model so i would ask the staff to take a
look at some of those recommendations and where there's clear alignment and opportunity to take
a look at what is reportable about english learners and what can be reported differently
in a way that disaggregates more actionable information as specifically as as was report
reported and requested from the representative from several of the lea's i think something worth
considering patricia can you turn your camera back on we can't see you before
my camera my camera's on i'm having fluctuating bandwidth problems so when that happens it
switches off so it'll come back on all by itself i haven't been turning my camera off my camera's on
okay i don't see any other hands up so i'd like to oh cynthia go ahead thank you i just wanted to
reiterate and echo board member rucker's statements i think as we continue to look at how
to best look at the e blip and how it can really help with accuracy and stability
since there are going to need to be some additional runs if you will especially related to large lea's
it would be helpful to see some information and some data related to looking at possibly
additional assessment measures like the l path what does that look like as it relates to accuracy
and stability and any other runs that might be helpful in us knowing that the stability
for particular student groups is in place as well there's been a lot of work done and i know again
the goal is to make sure that we're able to get this right when we start implementing and
showing this information on the dashboard so as we are continuing to explore it would be helpful
to see some of that additional information in our next conversation
great i wanted to pursue some of the same questions and i wonder if cindy might
come back or i don't know if this would be cindy jenny are you there
maybe you could take down the stop sharing your screen and then we can
see other that we can see things there you are great so i am curious about as others have
suggested this notion of including lpac scores is that something that's come up at all with our
technical advisory group not to buy knowledge i mean the first that we heard of dr goldsmith's
work was when the information was shared on friday as part of the public comments so
we have been trying to review it just as quickly as you all have and i think if anything we can
take this back and look at it further you know any additional work that is added to ets will
have to consult with our assessment office because the contract is very limited in scope
there's a very tight timeline and work scope for ets to do this work on our behalf and so
expanding that scope could lead to additional costs that we're we may not have the funding for
so we just need to to take back and look through this a bit more but it has not come up to my
knowledge it has not definitely definitely not come up in any of the technical conversations
especially with our technical design group okay well i hear some enthusiasm for learning more
about it so it'll be great to see what can be explored i also heard a lot of the commentary
about reporting el's and rfps separately i know that's a question that comes down the road when
we get to reporting you may or not be able to help me with this but but i have this challenge
in thinking about i can understand why we would want to see how rfps are progressing
after they become reclassified and they are a stable group at that point when they become
reclassified so you can watch over time the dilemma we always have with the el group is
that as soon as you are reclassified you leave the group so the group itself is not a stable group
and it's hard for me to understand how we would let's say we have an el student in that group they
become reclassified in that year if we report the el group by itself without that student the
fact that that student main gains that student gets lost then because they they've jumped over
the style so to speak into the reclassified group so they're no longer represented in the el group
which means their their aggregate trend is inaccurate because some people have left
is that something that's been discussed at all are there any strategies to address that fundamental
dilemma absolutely that prior to you coming on board discussed this extensively and actually
voted to have the el group for the academic indicators structured as it is to include rfps
for an additional four years it seems to us that there's there continues to be confusion in the
field on what this measure will report out on and we will be we have committed to being consistent
with what we're currently doing with the academic indicator reporting out by student groups and then
for the el student group reporting out additionally between rfps and english english only so it with
the additional disaggregation of data for this student group is is very unique but it's something
that the board committed to several years back and nothing has changed so there just appears to be
some confusion in the field that that for some reason we wouldn't be reporting on this data and
we absolutely are committed to to getting that information out to the field we know it's important
to folks that are especially at paying attention to so we would be reporting the rfps you know
as a separate group so they could be tracked in addition to the el group as current instructor
there's a disaggregation that is one click away from that student group on the dashboard so we
would one click away okay thank you this was a long long discussion um a couple years back yeah
yeah and i just wanted to you know kind of you know make sure that we were
thinking about it and and clarifying what we're planning to do um on the objective criteria for
teacher data that was called for um for priority one the percentage of teachers who are fully
certified as well as those who are certified but misassigned um we really um should be making some
movement toward that can we look to the next meeting for some recommendation on
how to establish some objective criteria we can definitely provide you an update at the next
meeting i think my my hesitation is i don't think by the next meeting we're going to have data back
so your next meeting is in november we have a time frame right now that ctc won't be able to
give us the full data set back until december at the earliest and objective criteria to me means
looking at this from an accountability standpoint which we all know we want to look at more than
one year's worth of data to establish those kinds of criteria those high stakes kinds of measures
and so i i can't report out on a data set i don't have yet um and i'm that's my my hesitation and
even um exploring objective criteria when i haven't even seen the data set so the data are report you
know it is one of these the the data on the percentage of teachers who are fully certified
uh in districts is routinely collected and reported by ctc so again this is a cross agency
question so that we could talk more about what it will take to get from here to there but i think
it's a useful point that we should be moving towards some objective criteria i just want to
make one last comment on the question of learning loss that many people brought up
and simply remind folks that the department and the board work together to
provide some guidance on formative assessments diagnostic assessments
that have already been approved by the board and are listed in a guidance document from cde
that allows you to track students learning gains and losses over time actually in a more
specific way using tools that are specifically designed for diagnostic formative assessment
and so there is a deep seated desire and need on the part of districts and schools to figure out
where kids are where they've been where they're going how to get them there what progress they're
making and those other tools which include the smarter balanced formative and diagnostic tools
the interim assessments which have been made much more specific and there's a whole new
variety of those tools as well as other diagnostic assessment tools that many districts are already
using that we've encouraged all districts to take up this year if they haven't in the past
should be being used and we encourage them to be used for looking at this question of learning loss
now without waiting you know for a whole other reporting cycle of the summative state test
are there any other questions or comments before we make a i see zade is ready to contribute
zade yes this is closing off of what president darlin cammon was just saying in regards to
learning loss at least i know that in my school district we've been taking i'm not 100 sure what
the test is called but we've been taking a test to track learning loss and to make sure that that's
accounted for so i thought that that would just be something interesting to throw into the conversation
yeah i hope that your district's experience is happening across the
state sometime in these next you know coming coming weeks with that matt you want to make a comment
you know i do but we've we probably need to keep moving on and i can
cover it later okay yeah no worries all right so i'm ready for a motion i think
um and we have dibs on that soon do you want to make a motion thank you
i would move the department's recommendation to adopt the career measures
for inclusion in the cci that are shown on the slide for us terrific and uh second eileen
second it i second the motion thank you uh any further discussion all in favor of the motion say
aye no linda we have to do the roll call we have to do the roll call sorry thank you
yep so sue
yes yes
aye linda
aye zayed
aye cynthia
aye kim
yes matt
yes kim
yes aye
aye
aye dave
aye tricia
yes eileen
yes thing
aye motion passes thank you wonderful um we're going to take a 10 minute break
uh it is 11 30 we'll be back promptly by 11 40 uh and we'll resume at that time i'll let you know
we're about an hour later than we had thought we might be at this moment so we're going to
try to pick up the pace after we get back see you in 10 minutes don't leave the room
well linda did you want to get started i'm i'm guessing they're gonna
do we have a quorum i think yes here we do okay so i need to um you need to
reestablish the core role yeah so i'll do that are we rolling
okay okay um ting
ting
sorry here eileen here
patricia here i day here him
okay matt here jim here cynthia
okay zade here linda here sue here you have a quorum
all right um cynthia i think needs to recuse from this item in any event and so
it's just as well she's not here um item three is a request that the state board
approve the local control and accountability plan federal agenda addenda uh submitted and
reviewed by the cde uh and rachel maves of the cde will present this item rachel you may begin
good morning president superintendent thurmond chief deputy gregson and state board members
i would like to first echo the comments shared about karen staff walters while i have only worked
with karen for a short time i have greatly appreciated her thoughtful calm strategic
leadership her passion and desire to collaborate and build organizational bridges to serve our
students in california it is inspiring and invaluable i look forward to continuing to
work together karen as you transition to secessa it is a pleasure to come before you today to
discuss the federal addendum i am joined by cde staff josh strong barbara murchison veronica
aguila as this item has spanned branches and divisions within cde each of my colleagues
holds an admirable depth of knowledge and expertise in their respective fields so i
will likely defer most questions to them this is the first time i've appeared appeared before the
state board of education you have my title as deputy superintendent of instruction but i wanted
to give you the briefest sense of who i am and what i care about my name is rachel maves i grew
up in minnesota but all of my professional career has been here in california i have been a high
school english teacher a curriculum writer an instructional coach a principal a district
superintendent and most recently directed continuous improvement at the sonoma county
office of education i'm married to a wonderful man and we have three children all of us
and our dog are making the adjustment of having moved to sacramento friends it is hot here
this is my 101st day at cde but given the current circumstances seems much longer i think many of us
would agree these last few months have felt like years my teenager continues to point out that
even my eyebrows are starting to go gray my hair was dark when i first interviewed for this position
for this position a few years ago i was asked to tell colleagues in only five words
my educational why and this is what i said to see the invisible child
to see the invisible child let me tell you why i grew up in abject poverty
in a violent and abusive home i understand the feeling of safety at school as the eldest of four
my focus was not on school it was on survival i remember one of the houses we lived in the
upstairs was condemned and two of my siblings and i slept together on a mattress on the floor
when i was in second grade i received my report card and was terrified to show my parents
on the bus ride home i crumpled it into the tiniest ball and shoved it between the seat
and the metal wall no one noticed it was at that moment i realized the freedom of never having to
bring home another report card along the way i experienced teachers that were my champions
and teachers that placed me in the corner of the classroom as if i were invisible
for me education is not just a profession it is a deep seated call to see the students we serve
to be their champion and we need to be effective champions when i took this position one of the
first people i contacted was a man who has been my professional champion who saw me and he said
rachel to those who have been given much much is required you are leading at a state level
lead well you have been given a platform speak well you have been given a charge
knock down walls well that is my commitment and aspiration as i join the cde team to lead well
to speak well and with your collective support and collaboration to knock down walls together
and without apology and on that note i will transition to the agenda item before you
the approval of the local education agency plans as required by the every student succeed act
through the completion of the l cap federal addendum during this presentation i will provide
you with an overview of the l cap federal addendum as the plan requirements an overview of the
approval process as well as a deeper examination of our processes from one of our title leaders
in march of 2018 the board developed and approved the process outlined today
as required by essa your action is significant as a substantially
approvable plan is a requirement for an lea to receive any title funding
the essa requires leas that apply for essa funds to complete an lea plan that addresses
the required provisions of the essa programs for which the lea is applying for funding
to ensure alignment between the local and federal law california requires leas that apply for essa
funds to complete a local control and accountability plan federal addendum and the consolidated
application in california the l cap serves as the primary strategic planning document for each lea
within the l cap lea set goals plan actions and leverage resources in consultation with
stakeholders to improve student outcomes with specific activities to address the local control
funding formula state and local priorities the addendum is intended to supplement the l cap
while ensuring the eligible leas have the opportunity to meet all of the lea plan provisions
of essa as a quick timeline and refresher essa was signed into law on december 15 2015
in september of 2017 california submitted essa consolidated state plan in december of 2017
representatives from the cde and sbe participated in a phone conference with the u.s department of
education to discuss california's proposed state plan in january 2018 the sbe discussed ed's feedback
proposed revisions and approved california state plan pending the sbe executive director's approval
of final revisions requested at its march 2018 meeting the sbe adopted the l cap federal
addendum template and the approval process for leas that apply for essa funding
lea submitted their l cap federal addendum to cde through the online system in april 2019
beginning in april 2019 and continuing through the present the cde has provided ongoing technical
assistance and support to complete an approvable l cap federal addendum as per the cde review
and approval process together the l cap l cap federal addendum and con app serve as the essa
lea plan aligning state and federal resources and reducing duplication efforts for leas
in march of 2018 the board approved the process and template for the l cap federal addendum
consistent with the intent of california education code section 52064 the addendum allows an lea to
complete a single plan together with the consolidated federal the consolidated funding application
to meet both state and federal requirements align state and federal resources and help
minimize duplication of effort at the local level leas must submit an lea plan for approval
by the state educational agency wants within california the california state board of education
serves as the sea additional review and modifications to an lea plan consistent with
specific essa title program requirements resultant of program changes or availability of new data such
as the educated educator equity data are made at the local level to reflect the most current information
lea's are also required to annually review their lea lea plans and update them as necessary
at this point i'd like to provide an overview of the approval process
for the federal addendum lea submitted their federal addendum to cde
via its online system to apply for essa funds for the 2019-20 school year lea's are required
to address the strategy and alignment prompts in the addendum template explaining how their
federal addendum aligns to their l cap lea's are required to address each provision for
each essa program for which they are applying for funding unless the provision is not applicable
to the lea lea's must provide a narrative that addresses the provision within the l cap federal
addendum template the addendum approval process is an iterative process for each individual essa
title program each program office work directly with lea's through the federal addendum system
with emails and phone calls to provide individualized technical assistance and
coaching as needed to ensure an lea's response to each of the provisions for the specific title
programs reached a substantially approvable form the cde provided initial guidance on completing
and submitting the addendum during a tuesdays at two webinar in april 2019 and posted guidance
for completing the addendum prompts specific to each title program on its website i think it is
also important to note that each title office holds deep expertise in their areas of focus
their primary work at cde is to support districts on an ongoing basis as they address the varied
requirements for federal funding reviewing the federal addendum is one component of the services
they provide including ongoing support services and guidance to lea's webinars to ensure districts
are receiving the most current information about program requirements and available resources
conducting federal program monitoring reviews and much more they truly are the experts in their area
of focus and used that expertise to review each component of the addendum to ensure that it met
the requirements of federal law on august 26 2020 the cde sent a letter to lea's informing them
that their l cap federal addendum met the necessary requirements for approval
and would be brought forth to the state board for for approval in the letter cde strongly
encouraged lea's to post their addendum on their webpage with their adopted l cap to provide
transparent to transparency to their stakeholders which at that time was all that was within our
authority to do as there was no mandatory requirement that addendum be posted following
the approval of the addenda cde will notify lea's of the approval of their l cap federal addendum
and we are pleased to share pending the governor's signature to sb 820
we will also inform them of the new requirement to post their approved addendum on their website
to provide a clear understanding of the rigorous process cde engaged in with districts
i have asked barbara merchantson to join us as her team led the reviews for title one educator
equity section of the addendum each of our title offices holds a deep abiding knowledge of federal
requirements in their respective fields and engage in the same rigorous process you will hear from
process you will hear from barb today and with that i will transition to barb
thank you rachel and good morning president arling hamond
chief deputy gregson board members i'm barbara merchantson director of the educator excellence
and equity division here at the cde i really appreciate having the opportunity to speak with
you today about the l cap federal addendum review process my division reviewed several
sections of the addenda that were submitted by local educational agencies or lea's we reviewed
the title two part a sections the title four part a section and the section that i'll be talking
with you about today the educator equity section under title one but i do want to be really clear
dozens of staff across the department including staff in the english learner support division
and the student achievement and support division were involved in the review of federal addenda
over the course of more than a year before i get into my presentation i really do want to
acknowledge all of the work on the part of those staff and the support that the cde received from
the region 15 comprehensive center at west ed and the county regional el specialists to complete
this work so we're going to go way back to 1965 i promise i'll move quickly but the elementary and
secondary education act or esea which was first signed in 1965 really does represent the federal
government's commitment to educational equity for historically underserved groups i can't really
speak to the authorizations before 2001 but i do know that the esea is authorized under no child
left behind and the current authorization under esse both have provisions related to ensuring that
low income and minority children are not disproportionately served by teachers who are
inexperienced or not appropriately credentialed for the students or content that they are teaching
we refer to these disproportionalities as equity gaps under no child left behind states were required
to identify and address equity gap california did this through implementation of the compliance
monitoring intervention and sanctions program under that program the cde required lea's with
identified gaps to convene local stakeholders to examine data and develop local equitable
distribution plans lea's were required to adopt board policies around addressing gaps
if gaps did not close after a couple of years sanctions came into play and lea's were required
to direct their title to part a funds to activities that would address those gaps like paying for
additional coursework for teachers well a couple of things changed when the esea was reauthorized
as esea in 2015 first under no child left behind the educator equity language referred
to unqualified teachers recall that for many years the system paid a lot of attention
to whether or not teachers were highly qualified or hqt hqt sunset along with nclb
and now under ese states are required to report on which students are being taught by ineffective
teachers before ese did california did not have a definition for ineffective
and the board and the department have spent considerable time addressing this new requirement
the other big change under ese is that the responsibility for identifying and addressing
equity gaps has shifted from the state level to the local level this is more consistent with
california's local control system as well under ese the state evaluates and reports
and lea's identify and address so here's the ese provision that describes what lea's are required
to do around educator equity to address those gaps each lea must submit a plan to the state
educational agency that describes how it will identify and address any disparities that result
in low income and minority students being taught at higher rates than other students by ineffective
inexperienced and out-of-field teachers the cde moving from a compliance role under nclb to one
of support has developed the promoting equitable access to teachers or pete program to help
districts identify and address equity gap pete which is housed in the educator excellence and
equity division is a suite of tools guidance and technical assistance i'm not going to go
into too much detail around pete now because i don't want to get too far afield from the l cap
addendum but i do feel that it is important for everyone to have this additional context we spend
a lot of time talking about accountability through teacher data which is a key part of
this system but i feel it's important for everyone to know that we see our work reviewing
the l cap federal addenda as a key piece of the pete program the addenda work is embedded into
a larger body of ongoing work which includes ongoing technical assistance and support
and ongoing accountability through data sharing and federal program monitoring
much more information regarding past and current efforts to provide low-income and minority
students equitable access to teachers under the e sea is available on our web pages and
president darling hammond made note of california's educator equity plans you'll see that on these
web pages on these links which we get to from i think it's the main pete page we do have a
i think it's the main pete page we do have two information memoranda we provide those to the
board annually providing updates on implementation of these efforts and also providing the most
current data and we will continue to provide that as required by our e sea plan and also i
think it's really good institutional historical knowledge to to review the annual educator equity
plans that were required under no child left behind multiple years for those are available on
the pete web page so if you have time you know teacher data is is going to be a big discussion
for the board moving forward and i think again having some expertise around some of
these efforts as we move forward will be very helpful
so we partner really closely with the commission on teacher credentialing on all matters related
to educators as cindy and jonathan mentioned during their presentation of item two we are
currently working with them to streamline the collection of teacher data with the intent that
we will have better data quality and have it more readily available in one system we also in spring
of 2019 partnered with our colleagues at the commission to provide trainings on a few key
topics we shared updates around calpads we had just updated all of the course codes as
miss assignment's become more consequential to the larger education system we looked at the course
codes and realized they hadn't been updated since before the adoption of the common core
so it was very much time to take a good look at all of those course codes and bring them into
alignment with our current standards so we did that work and wanted to go out and talk to folks
in schools and districts directly about the changes to those course codes and how they would
need to be entered into the calpads system so our colleagues in the calpads office
were partners in this endeavor as well we talked to them about the new california state assignment
accountability system or cal sass just so folks knew the changes that were coming around how data
would be collected and shared and finally and most relevant for teachers and teachers is
relevant for today we shared information regarding the educator equity section of the l cap federal
addendum we provided an overview of what would be required and information about the tools that
could be used to successfully complete the section the team conducted 31 in-person trainings across
the state and presented webinars to ensure that everyone could participate so we partnered with
our counties and our county office of education colleagues and conducted 31 in-person trainings
across the state there and after the training series was complete we followed up by offering
weekly office hours so that people could ask specific questions on any of these topics and
receive more personalized technical assistance more than 5 000 people participated in these
trainings last spring and the recorded webinars are still available for anyone who is interested
so if we were in person today i would probably take the chance of going out to the internet
to show you some of these pete tools but since we're zooming i'm just going to give you a
screenshot you can see on this slide that we have all kinds of information on our pete page
to help people understand how to calculate equity gaps how to address equity gaps we've got updated
teacher equity definitions as mentioned earlier the board adopted some updated definitions
in november 2019 a big piece of work that we're working on is diversification of the teacher
workforce click on that link there's all kinds of great information about why that's a good thing
and some strategies through which to do it link to our pete training webinars educator equity
data instructions tools how to do a root cause analysis engaging your equity stakeholders
and research-based strategies for recruiting teachers and retaining teachers and as you get
to the bottom of the page you can see that information around how to complete the educator
equity section of the addendum is embedded into the pete page and if you click on that
you can see the guidance that would lead you step by step through completing the addendum
behind each one of these links are tools and worksheets and research that people can download
and use to move through the process of completing the educator equity section
of the l cap addendum successfully so i know that there's a lot on cde web pages
and over the years have heard that people are sometimes challenged to find what they are
looking for but to be really clear we shared information regarding these web pages tools
and l cap addendum requirements with more than 5 000 people to get them ready to complete this
section of their agenda so we didn't just post something and put it up and hope for the best
we posted we created these tools and then went out and shared with thousands of folks
the availability of these tools and how to use them
so i very quickly moved us from 1965 to the summer of 2019 which i referred to
as the summer of l cap addenda as i mentioned the educator excellence and equity division was
responsible for reviewing multiple sections of the addenda so my entire 50 plus person team was
engaged in some way we had a big kickoff lots of training lots of treats we're going to do these
addenda all told 12 reviewers reviewed the educator equity section submitted by more than
1700 lea's and again i need to thank our colleagues at the comprehensive center who provided
support to help us with this task all reviewers were trained and calibrated on essa requirements
the suite of pete tools how to provide the actionable feedback and tracking responses
each one of our reviewers adhered to a rubric and written responses were standardized
so here are the elements we used to assess the lea responses these are taken straight from the
essa provision that i described earlier in this presentation did the lea describe its data collection
process for identifying disparities did the lea describe the distribution of ineffective
misassigned inexperienced and out-of-field teachers working with low-income students
did the lea describe the distribution of ineffective inexperienced and out-of-field
teachers working with minority students did the lea describe how it engaged stakeholders
in its process for identifying strategies for addressing those discovered equity gaps
and did the lea describe the actions it will take to address any disparities discovered during the
data analysis process if any of these questions was not answered completely the section was
returned to the lea for more information so as i hinted at before the summer of el cap adenda
lasted much longer than anticipated it turned out to be really a year of el cap agenda
after each submission the reviewer provided actionable written feedback to the lea via
the addendum system many of the addendas you can see were approved after the first submission
so folks submitted something and for some folks it was complete and considered substantially
approvable and i should qualify here this the the cde did not approve el cap sections we approved
them to move forward to the board for actual approval so substantially approvable
many more of them were approved after two submissions so they got some feedback from
us around what was missing and they were able to make those revisions and resubmit something
that was substantially approvable we provided much more intensive technical assistance
to leas with sections that were not approvable after two submissions for these leas in addition
to specific actionable written feedback cde staff called the lea to help them to better understand
the requirement and to complete the success the section successfully so quite a bit of
individualized coaching happened if after the second submission the lea was not substantially
approvable as you can see more than 300 leas received this intensive technical assistance
with 55 of them submitting five or more times before being approved so and this again is for
the educator equity sections this was happening for all of the sections in the el cap federal
agenda in a variety of divisions at the department as challenges as challenging as it was to provide
these supports over the course of many many months in addition to lots of other projects that staff
have assigned to them i know my team is really grateful for the experience ultimately it was
very rewarding to connect with our colleagues in districts to learn more about their workforce
challenges and to ensure that they understood the requirements of the law and the tools that were
available to them the hard work of building and maintaining a strong stable well-prepared and
supported workforce is ongoing and in the spirit of continuous improvement we adjust as we go
so in september 2017 i mean november no september 2017 the board approved definitions for ineffective
inexperienced and out-of-field teachers as part of the s estate plan approval
lea's used these definitions to develop their el cap federal agenda educator equity responses
and then last november in 2019 the board approved updated definitions for ineffective and out-of-field
teachers to include more specificity around permits and authorizations that fall under each
one of the definitions and now lea's will need to update their section of the el cap federal
addendum related to educator equity with using these new definitions i think we've been very
clear in writing both in the november 2019 item that presented the updated definitions and in the
august 2020 educator data information memo that lea's will need to update this section
with these new definitions all along lea's have been encouraged to review the el cap federal
addendum annually with their el cap as s of funding should be considered in yearly strategic
planning we're optimistic that with the new cal sass coming online in early 2021 and with all of
the training supports and technical assistance that we've provided to lea's to get their section
for educator equity substantially approvable to you today lea's will find it much easier
to locate the data they need and be able to update this section relatively easily and then
they'll update their agenda in tandem with their el caps as they undertake that next spring and of
course cde's federal program monitors will continue to review the federal agenda to ensure that
they're updated as part of the monitoring process so to help lea's understand these
expectations we're developing a set of recorded webinars that people can access on demand you
know like scheduling webinars for a certain time and place has proven to be challenging as much of
our lives moved into the internet so we're going to record these webinars these videos and release
them this fall to help people be ready to update their el cap federal agenda but also to address
equity gaps moving forward we this is an ongoing piece of work and the el cap federal agenda
in our mind represents how things are going in a particular space and time
so our goal is to have this set of videos posted and available by the end of this year and to
reestablish weekly office hours in early 2021 as the new data becomes available in cal sass
and folks are undertaking the update of this section of their addendum we're confident that
these additional supports will help lea successfully update their agenda and address any equity gaps
moving forward so i hope all this information has been helpful and rachel and i and our colleagues
online are here to support with any questions that you may have the recommendation is that the cde
recommends that the state board of education approve the lea's addendum list referenced in
attachment one of item three thank you very much um we're going to get to public comment
quickly but if there are any clarifying questions that was a very thorough and clear presentation
thank you so much barbara um we'll get the public comment slide up there i don't see any
clarifying questions so let me turn to our liaisons um sue burr and eileen to um get us started with
framing this sue thank you linda um i just want to express my very deep appreciation to both
rachel and to barb for an incredibly comprehensive overview of how this process has worked
um and also just to reinforce as probably the person who's been around the longest year
this is the way our federal work has taken place for many many years
we rely on the department staff as you can tell and i'm proud to see the expertise
and depth of knowledge that they present and the incredible process that they go through
including enlisting the help of the comprehensive center on this work so just a hooray of great
kudos for this work and i'm ready to make a motion when you're ready for it all right so
did you want to add anything so let me just say again i'm just to support what's good
um
rachel and barb and i just appreciated the data that showed how many lea's went back a second
time third time to get this line the way it needed to be so i have confidence in the thoroughness
and also responsiveness to support individual districts and i also appreciate the recorded
webinars and the continued support from the district so this money is tied to this and
there's clear expectations of what districts need to do so i just really want to thank the
department for their ongoing work in this area thank you really impressive um with that uh we
want to see if we have any public comment there are four people signed up currently for public
comments i will open the phone line now um next caller you are you are unmuted and your time starts
now my name is lexy lopez from ed voice i've always supported the removal of this item from
july's agenda and we remain concerned and strongly urge the board to refrain from approving lea
agenda this 90 page item only includes three examples of agenda with no links to the other
nearly 2000 lea's which are recommended for approval very few districts have followed cd
guidance to make their agenda public and of the few lea plans stakeholders have reviewed
most do not meet federal essay requirements to identify and address inexperienced teachers
teaching students of color and low-income students as noted in our letter ed voice urges the board to
request how and why lea's are recommended for approval when they are providing inaccurate
information to the federal government we believe it's improper to condone cd staff
passively allowing lea's to obfuscate stakeholder engagement and recommend approval without
verifying that cd guidance is followed by each individual lea in order to be accountable to
address the needs of disadvantaged students and English learners thank you thank you
next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good afternoon caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
okay we're going to move on muted
good afternoon caller you are unmuted and your hello i'm calling from los angeles
hello can you hear me yes we can
hello can you hear me we can hear you go ahead caller your time starts now
i don't know if you can hear me but on the live feed on my computer there's no audio
that's that was my only comment i see the uh the powerpoint slides but i don't hear the audio i
have to go to my phone for that i'm not sure if that's how you're supposed to set it up
okay thank you we will look into that problem thank you for letting us know
did you have a comment
okay we'll move hello can you hear me yes we can hear you did you have a public comment for item three
hello okay i'm sorry we can hear you but apparently you cannot hear us so we are going to move on to
the next caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
good afternoon caller
you're unmuted and your time starts now
i wonder if there's a technical problem hello i think you can hear me but i can't hear you
please yes we can hear you
we can hear you go ahead and proceed my only comment has to do with trying to get the audio
to come through on the live feed thank you okay thank you
good afternoon caller you are unmuted and your time starts now
and your time starts now
good afternoon john afro from public advocates i appreciate the training that the department
has gone around the state on the teacher unmuted and the pete system the problem is that those
5 000 individuals were trained on the wrong definition the currently outdated definition
of an ineffective teacher and that they need to be affirmatively informed that the
definition has been updated and that they have the obligation to
lea's have the obligation to update their educator equity plan people don't all read august memos and
board items as as many of us do so we need the department to affirmatively send a letter to
lea's informing them that they are obligated to update their educator equity plans according to
the new ineffective definition by june 30th time thank you caller thanks
good afternoon you are unmuted and your time starts now
okay it looks like that concludes public comment for item three
okay thank you very much do we have um discussion from the board
oh i see matt and i see i day i'll just uh i just want to add i appreciate the callers i appreciate
the um sentiments about being very thorough about this i i do however believe and uh really
appreciate the efforts of rachel and barbara and their staff on being incredibly thorough
and supporting the local lea's in meeting the requirements of this so i appreciate that very
much and i appreciate the presentation is very clear and i'm willing to move a motion one way
all right i day
um yeah i'm on mute um i was actually going to say what board member navo said and i also wanted
to ask about the um adding the uh definition of teacher in the report just updating that
from the alley aids the con the last comment that was made by public advocates
the last comment that was made by public advocates
rachel or barb do you want to respond to that how that's being handled
yeah sure thank you so as soon as the board approved the updated um definitions we posted
them on our webpage we've updated all of our tools around with with with the updated more
refined definitions and as you can see on this slide or i hope you can see on this slide out in
zoom a huge piece we're going to lead our technical assistance with how the educator equity
definitions have changed right this is i think most lea's are aware we will continue our
communications around this after the l cap agenda are approved by the board we will continue to
communicate with lea's our county office of education partners who support lea's and anyone
who will listen the education have been updated and that lea's will need to update this section
of the plan and that we encourage them to do that using the new data that will be available
through the cal sass system and with our support as they develop their l caps next year so yes
a big part of our work is the outreach and helping lea's understand what is
required and providing them with the support to meet those expectations thank you thank you thank
i just want to add my thanks um barbara for both the history of esda which was a wonderful trip
down memory road and the um you know description of this process um you know as i i know you
believe the educator equity gaps are a really important part of getting to equity in this state
it's so useful to raise consciousness about these issues i know there are glitches in the
process sometimes but the various ways in which the data are coming online which allow us to
um you know both at the local level and the state level to make policy decisions that will
you know support as you said a well-prepared you know well-supported educator workforce are
just critically important so i know you've been working on this for many years and your passion
and commitment come through and i appreciate both how challenging this process was but how
much you're gathering it together and moving it forward to keep that consciousness raising and
those policy steps moving forward are there any other comments before we go ahead and take a motion
i know matt said he would like to make the motion if that's okay i'm happy to let sue make the motion
okay we are so polite today that's great so would you like to make a motion sure thanks matt um i
would move the department recommendation to approve the lea agenda as listed in the agenda item
agenda item terrific and matt would you like to second i'll second all right all any further
discussion all in favor say aye oh we have to roll the roll say aye to um to karen as she goes around
okay ting i eileen
i patricia i i day i um kim i think she had to step off matt hi jim
i senthya that's why she's recused zade aye linda hi sue
i all right thank you very much uh what we're going to do now is postpone uh agenda item for the mega
agenda item for the mega assessment item until after lunch we are going to break uh for lunch
i'm gonna ask that you take 15 minutes to get your lunch stretch your legs you can continue to eat
lunch in the closed session um board members will come into closed session we'd love to see you there
by 12 45 and you can disconnect from this zoom link and then after lunch you're going to use
the closed session zoom link that was provided to you by the state board staff and then when we
adjourn the closed session we'll we'll come back and report on that shortly thereafter so it's
12 30 we will see you in closed session at 12 45 please disconnect from this link
and connect with the closed session link you're allowed to leave the room
that you have to leave the room at this point
all right
we're returning to open session and karen please establish the quorum ting
ting no ting sorry i was on the field hi i'm here sorry eileen here patricia
yeah hi day here kim not back yet okay matt here jim here cynthia here zade here linda here
su here okay so we do have a quorum okay uh so i'm going to start by reporting out from closed
session uh yesterday governor newsom announced brooks allen as his education policy advisor
and nominated brooks as executive director of the state board of education
in closed session in a unanimous vote the board ratified the governor's nomination
and appointed brooks allen as executive director of the state board of education
and i think we have to report the roll call but since there were not any no votes do we have to
do that no you just need to say it was unanimous i did say that i'll say it again it was a unanimous
and the board also discussed the msc litigation much less exciting so i want to start by saying
congratulations brooks we're delighted you're here and maybe you'd like to say a few words
to us sure uh thank you dr donald and um just very briefly just i want to express how grateful
and honored i am uh to serve the governor and this board that's filled with so many mentors and
friends and respected leaders and colleagues at this critical time when we're all collectively
seeking to turn these immense challenges into opportunities to ensure that all children
to echo president darlin hamlin receive the support and opportunities that they need
and deserve as we all know inside and outside of school and in whatever form that may need to take
moreover i i just want to say that i'm really excited and humbled to following karen's footsteps
and to rejoin the fantastic team that she has built thrilled to be rejoined by colleagues there
and of course our wonderful partners colleagues and friends at the department of ed
many of whom long deep relationships with and of course led by our our great state superintendent
tony thurman so i'm just i'm thrilled i'm really excited and thank you and in service to the
children across the state i look forward to joining you all on october 1st we are eager to
welcome you and thank you so much for taking a moment here and you may want to stay for our
next item which is we're reopening number one item one we begin with a tribute to karen staff
walters we've already begun tributing karen but we're going to continue in a more formal way
she has served as executive director of the state board special advisor to the governor for the last
seven and a half years and then after that we'll take action on our draft 2020 and july 2020
meeting minutes and our liaison assignments so i would like to start us off by noting some of
karen's amazing abilities i know that many of you are aware of her high level of competence
her unyielding perseverance her quiet determination that have produced so much important education
policy on behalf of the children of california but did you know that karen can keep 22 plates
twirling on 22 sticks without any of them ever falling off and she can do that while she's
walking a tightrope over the heads of the lion tamers the flame throwers and the elephant riders
below as they are drafting bills lobbying for and against and sometimes crashing loudly into each
other she does all of this without a net below her and as far as i can tell without engaging in
common mortal activities such as sleep as our daily phone calls and emails that start early
in the morning and go into the evening seven days a week reveal you will always see that she does
this with a smile on her face and with a long list in her hand and as you talk to her she's always
adding to that list and the only person i know who actually manages to get through and cross off
everything on her list i'm not sure how she does that i can go on at length but i know that many
people want to speak and i'll only note a few of her most notable accomplishments over the last
seven and a half years among along with key members of the state board she has helped to
implement the local control funding formula overseeing the establishment of new state standards
curriculum frameworks and instructional materials estate resources for strengthening instruction
and maximizing student learning and those are standards and frameworks of which i know we are
very very proud she's provided leadership in getting legislation passed over all the system
of assessments not only for the content areas of english language arts math and science
but also for supporting english learners all in support of teaching and learning guided the
development of the california school dashboard and the local control and accountability plan template
and helped shape the development of california's statewide system of support partnering with the
county offices of education of the cce and the california department of education and as someone
said earlier this morning she has been a wonderful collaborator with the cde which is our key partner
and with whom all of these things need to be done jointly and as she transitions to her new role
as executive director of the california county superintendent's educational services association
we want to extend to her our heartfelt thanks for her tireless commitment her wisdom her sense of
humor that has made this journey in improving the conditions of public education all the more
pleasant as well as effective karen we have been trying to sneak around you but it's not that easy
so you probably know most of what's about to happen but we have a group card which we have
signed for you and many current and past state board members some of our colleagues in the
governor's office and elsewhere and i think that patricia dicas who was the guru of the card
development is showing that on her screen right now and patricia did you want to say anything
at this point i'm not hearing patricia
so maybe we're just seeing the card at this moment but you will see many many many many
tributes inside of it i would like to invite eileen strouse to say a few words
and then we'll give everyone a chance who wants to add on after state superintendent also speaks
after state superintendent also speaks so so i have to i have to say um you know i've been on
the board for a long time and when i first came on the board we didn't have an executive director
and then sue was executive director and then sue stepped down to join us as colleagues on the board
and karen came on and i have to say she's been a model for as a leader and someone who can
collaborate and stay calm no matter what's happening and i think linda made a long list
of the things that we accomplished but just the calmness the effectiveness she'll call you back
she'll explain something she'll say no that's not your role or yes that's what the board does she
had a real strategic approach to things i have to say i love sitting down in karen's office to
visit with her and also to eat her peanut butter cups which are deadly for me but wonderful
just strategic the relationships i just feel so lucky that we got to work for with karen
and i think she sets a great model going forward for how to collaborate with all the separate
board members and divisions and pieces that it takes to move things forward
and i just think from the days where we were drawing on a whiteboard the effective indicators
for accountability and the first dashboard was a spreadsheet you might remember that and
and now what it looks like i think we can be so proud of where we are and we have a clear roadmap
of where we're going and it's to karen's leadership so i just have to say karen we look forward to
collaborating with you in your new role i think you can really help too in the work with the system
of support in the counties and i feel so lucky to have had the opportunity to spend so much time
working with you on important work for the students of california thanks that's great and
let's invite state superintendent thurmond to say a few words
madam president thank you welcome back to the state board brooks looking forward to working with
you i think that president darling hammon's comments really captured so many great
accomplishments that karen has helped to to bring into to fruition i would i would add just one
and that is a piece of legislation that she worked on to help districts that find themselves
facing receivership to get support in a way where they don't have to pay it back meaning
districts that are already in financial stress you know happen to pay back loans only adds to
their distress and karen worked on a very important policy that helps districts in this way as someone
who came from one of those districts a district that was in receivership for 20 years before it
could pay off all of its debt yeah i really appreciate that i also appreciate what president
darling hammon said about karen's sense of humor it kind of sneaks up on you you know i think that
i think that karen you're an example of i think of you as a quiet leader but an effective leader
and it tells me that you don't have to be yelling and screaming to get things done
you know that quiet leadership should not be mistaken for not being a strong leader you are
a strong leader and a strong leader knows when to use you know a laughter or a quiet voice and also
knows how to get their message across regardless of what the speed or the cadence is of what's
happening in the room and i've appreciated that sense of humor because let's face it we we live
in times that would just bring you to tears and bring you to your knees and the ability to have
some levity in those moments is greatly appreciated and i'm sure it will serve you well you went from
having to report to a board now you have to report the 58 county superintendents and so i would
encourage you to continue to use that sense of humor but but i'll just say again i'm grateful
for the time we've had to work together and looking forward to working with you in your next
in your next capacity and obviously we're available to you in any way that we can be
helpful so congratulations and thank you for your service all right i'm guessing that su
burr you would like to kick off the rest of the comments i would love to thank you so much
you know i've had the distinct pleasure of knowing karen i won't tell how many years because it might
age both of us and worked with her in a variety of roles when i got ready to retire governor
brown said to me you can only go if you find your replacement and so i went oh i know the first
person top of my list and that was karen and i certainly know that none of us are that we're
all grateful that we had the opportunity to bring karen into work on the board i will say just kind
of building on what superintendent thurman said that one of my greatest mentor was gary hart who
was a longtime senate chair of the senate education committee and the trait he valued most in people
was their ability to listen and i at the time that he shared that with me i probably didn't
think about it as carefully as i should have but over the years i certainly have and that's one
of karen's number one traits and characteristics that i think makes her that very effective quiet
leader that superintendent thurman just described so i'm just thrilled karen for your next challenge
you're sort of following me around all the time just kidding i know it will be a great
you'll enjoy the experience and they will certainly value having you in that role and all of us on the
state board will value having you in that role because the county superintendents are such key
partners in all that we do along with the department of education so i will certainly miss you greatly
in this role you know i'm always just a phone call away and look forward to working with you
in your new endeavor thank you awesome are there others who would like to say a word
i guess i'm not looking at the hand raising i should be patricia and matt
patricia well first of all i'm grateful that i'm making this comment and my camera is still
working so that karen can see me as i'm speaking karen like sue i have i although i have not known
you as long as sue i have i first met you when i stepped out of my classroom and began working
with the california teachers association at the time you were working as a legislative advocate
at at axa i was always impressed with your preparation and the background and research
you did but more so i was impressed as as all the education lobbyists worked together and met
together and did our collaboration particularly with no child left behind it was just wonderful
to figure out ways that we could find consonance and agreement and i was just so impressed with
the ways that you were always reaching out and seeking ways that there could be some common
agreement but more importantly i was impressed by your grace your sense of style and the way that
you approach not only relationships but work but just doing things to do the work together and
to encourage all of us to be together so while everybody is lauding and praising what you do and
expressing great expectations about what you'll be doing next i want to take this opportunity
to offer you some words of advice as you sit as you step away from the board this has been a very
high profile high fidelity high intensity and high energy activity and step over to work with
the county superintendents this is an opportunity to do the thing that i always hear superintendent
thurman say lean in one of the most important things that i've already heard sue say is that
the county superintendents are an important partner for us and the work we're doing as we
move forward where you're leaving us at a very important inflection point because we're turning
a new phase and looking at a new stage in the implementation of the accountability system as
well as the blossoming of the system of support and so this is the inflection point where as an
entity and as a group of stakeholders we need the county superintendent to lean in and that's
something that prodding and leading and guiding is something you've been very good at and something
that you have been very careful with so i encourage you to engage that the county
superintendents to lean in to look at not only how to use their authority but also how to use
their platform their bully pulpit and their position in the relationships they have with
all the schools across the state to move this agenda and to move this process to the next
level because we really will rely on them to do that and to take the reins to blossom and build
out the system of support my second piece of advice is to remember who your friends are
every so often even though linda has already told you she plans to call you ever so often uh
call up some folks just to have a cup of coffee that's something we don't know right now in this
environment we don't have time to do that and we're not allowed to but probably the thing i
appreciated most about you when i first met you at axa is that's the thing you did all the time
we met we worked it out over a cup of coffee we worked it out over lunch so take the time to call
up folks and just take and go out for a cup of coffee and finally and probably most importantly
have fun because if you're not having fun it's just work so i will miss you and i appreciate you
and i've already told you privately i don't have the words or the the the perlative adjectives
to describe how much i honor admire and respect you but you will be missed and i'm just so glad
i'm going to be able to find an excuse when i go to work at cpa to call you as well so thank you
very much and i'm just so happy to know you and so happy to see you taking on this next important
role awesome matt did you want to say a couple things sure i imagine this is very difficult
for karen she's so incredibly humble so i'll be brief karen but i just in the short time that
i've had to get to know you your optimism your positivity your courage your integrity and most
importantly your character is one i respect and admire and i wish you well in your new venture
and i know that the system of support and the kids of california will benefit from your
contribution there as well as your contribution you're leaving here and brooks welcome welcome
aboard it's our paths keep crossing so i'm sure you're going to do wonderful and zade wants to
say a word and then ting i'm a staff walters i just wanted to say that your work on the lcff
and the l cap truly opened the door to welcoming student voices to the decision making process in
school districts and it truly started the next generation of student leaders in the california
education system and i know personally that i don't think i would be in the position that i
am in today if it wasn't for you really looking out for the state of california and for its students
and so for that i'm really thankful for your service and you've clearly touched the hearts
of all the members here on our board and although i wish i could have had the opportunity to work
with you i wish you the best of luck in your future endeavors awesome tang yeah i just wanted
to add two more words to um description of karen perseverance and loyalty also as well i remember
my first conversation with her um about the potential of my being on the on the state board
and i first thing i asked her was are you planning to stay for a while because i know that this is a
difficult job and it can be a revolving door at times so i am so thrilled and um honored to have
been able to work with her these six years almost now um and i um wish you the best of luck karen
and um we're gonna miss you and we hope to stay in touch cynthia you have your hand up
i do and karen i just want to say um how much i will miss you even though i'm new to the board
you have been absolutely phenomenal the amount of time that you took to have conversations with me
and communications so that i was set up for success in that first board meeting will always be
appreciated uh i'm even more excited that you are coming over to see sessa and look forward to just
continue to work in collaboration as we continue to serve the students but again congratulations
to you i will miss working with you under the state board umbrella but i'm again quite excited
that i'll be able to work with you under the success umbrella and i want you to know your
reputation precedes you i knew your name and all the wonderful things about you before i even had
a chance to meet you so again kudos to you and thank you for being such a service to our state
um that's great um i'm gonna ask that we put the public comment slide up now even though the card
is beautiful um so that we can um oh and it looks like you're getting presented with your balloons
which is awesome i don't know who is they're doing that so do they want to say something with
the balloons i don't know if there's is there a speech that goes with the balloons
maybe not but they're gorgeous i don't know how you're going to get those home
so um uh i wasn't planning to speak but thank you so much let me see how i can turn on this video
okay well thank you so much um it's been a pleasure for me to be working with karen the last seven and
a half years she's been delightful she's been one of the best bosses i've ever had um and i know
that i speak for the rest of the staff that we are going to miss her dearly um and um at the same
time with the same breath i'm extremely delighted to have brooks come back and join us so looking
forward to that and um you know it's it um you know her mentorship her patience um her
uh ability to continue to you know she works long days but she always takes another question
from staff and so it's always been extremely appreciated um and i know that we're happy for
her um starting her new her new chapter thank you yeah um i see tony's hand is up and um after that
we uh will go to public comment tony did you want to add a thought madam president um with
your concurrence i was going to ask if the chief deputy uh superintendent stephanie grixson could
say a few words on behalf of cd sure where are you stephanie here in the boardroom thank you so
much superintendent and board president darling ham and i just i have a little bit different
perspective than many of you and working with karen because i was new to cde when i first met
karen coming straight from a district and who knew that curriculum instruction could be such a
highly engaging topic for something and so i just want to say how much i appreciated karen
and being the person that i could learn from when i first started at cde being a mentor as a woman
in leadership and just how real you are and how kind you are on top of being so real because
sometimes being real means that you are telling a truth that's hard to hear but you always did it
with such kindness and so i am truly grateful that you are a role model for many of us
in leadership positions and grateful that i got to learn from you during these highly engaging
times so i just want to say that i really appreciate that i'll get to continue to get
to work with you in your new role with cecessa and continue to learn from you thank you very much
awesome and with that we'll turn to public comment if there are any yes we do do have
some speakers uh speaker you are now being unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the
record yes good afternoon this is mary vixie sandy from the commission on teacher credentialing
karen it's been an utter pleasure to work with you for the last seven years i will miss you so
much um and i'm thrilled to have the opportunity to work with brooks in the future very glad that
you're still going to be in sacramento and i'm looking forward to having coffee regularly when
we can be released from the covid box good luck and godspeed thanks bye that's great
next speaker you're now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
um
thank you well everybody's um captured the wonderful qualities of karen and on behalf of
the ball frost group and our clients it's been such a pleasure working with her i've also known
karen for more years than i want to share right now but uh over the years karen has been such a
wonderful colleague always acting with grace all the qualities and integrity one quick story is
that when i was a new lobbyist um i was supposed to do a presentation in los angeles with another
colleague that we planned somebody um bill chavez for those of you who've been around
he got ill and he could not come with me and so it was the very last minute i asked karen could
you come and of course it was flying down and making the arrangement and she didn't hesitate
she said yes she came down she knocked it out of the park the folks at lake ho and all those
aspiring administrators were so impressed and i just really appreciate karen and throughout the
years um all the meetings and conversations and the wise counsel karen it's been a pleasure and
we really look forward to working with you in your new role thanks
next speaker you're now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
liandra lorraine on behalf of a capital advisors group um and all of our clients
karen we just want to say thank you for um the union service i've had the
pleasure of working with you from the legislature all the way
up to now and looking to continue that relationship with you at success i've always
found you to be a problem solver not a problem maker and you've always handled every situation
with grace i want to thank you for your accessibility for your kindness your willingness
willingness to listen and to solve and on a person on i want to thank you for all your support and
friendship not just this year but for every year that i've known you so we wish you the best we're
excited about working with you at santa we're also very pleased to have brooks coming coming back
and and getting a chance to work with him and and continue the legacy of great executive directors
of the state board thank you
you
speaker you're now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
hi this is robert van worrying from children now i just wanted to take
a minute to join the rest of the advocate and education community and thanking
thank you karen for all of her work as a member of the equity coalition i know there have been
times that there have been challenging policy issues to discuss with the in front of the board
and karen has always been so professional and and clear in in working with us
in resolving these challenging issues that we face so thank you for all of your work
and look forward to working with you in your new capacity thank you speaker
speaker you're now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record please
hello good afternoon this is liz giann i'm the director of legislative and community
affairs at public advocates i'm speaking for myself and my colleagues don aselt
rigel spencer massaro and the rest of the ed team at public advocates karen we have
appreciated so much your collaboration with us and our community partners especially during
such a momentous time in the resetting of california's school accountability system
your accessibility to us and the organizers parents and students as well as your good
guidance have been invaluable to us we want to wish you good luck in your new role and of course
we will continue in our collaboration when you are at sephesta i have to say we're also very
excited about the prospect of working with brook thank you
thank you next speaker you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
next speaker you're now live
good afternoon all this is dina plate from the california charter schools association
i want to just echo so many of the sentiments that have been shared already but
want to reiterate just a couple karen thank you so much for the the grace and the expertise
and your willingness to just embrace all in the process and i look forward to working with you
in your new role and then of course brooks welcome back to the state board we're definitely excited
to work with you this time around thanks so much thank you
next speaker you are now live please state your name and affiliation for the record
leilani i think we lost you if you want to call back in
at this time there are no additional speakers and the expertise and your willingness to
just embrace all in the process and i would a little reprise there
and before we're going to move to let karen say a few words but first kim would love to
say a couple of things you um i just wanted to to say thank you to karen i i think you have led
the state board in what i have to imagine is probably one of the largest and most expansive
periods of change um for for california's educational system with lcff with all the
accountability work um and to have overseen such an incredible body of work um and to have been at
the helm in the midst of some exciting high points but also controversies um what has also
been really apparent is just watching how forthright and fair um and an incredibly expert
person you have been and guide for all of us state board members so i am so grateful for your
calmness in the midst of storms um for long hours incredible leadership and for setting the bar high
for all of us to continue this work um and i i just i can see brooks alan there and welcome
and very excited to be working with you as well terrific okay karen this is the part you've been
writing the center of attention which is not your usual oh but we so appreciate you yes well thank
you you've all been very kind and very generous and so i really didn't focus on this at all that
you were going to do anything until i got the script some of you know we do a script for linda
that lays out the process especially now in this remote environment because there's more pieces of
the process and so i was reading it on tuesday night and patricia had sent it to several of us
on staff and i get to this part this is tribute to karen so i called judy sias and i said okay
what is that about and i think if i had real if i had focused on this earlier i'd seen the script
earlier and i think maybe they didn't send it to me earlier intentionally i could have amended this
little section but anyway so i took a deep breath so okay i'm gonna go on so i said to judy does
this mean i have to say something and she said yeah you better you better get it together so um
anyway i took her advice and i wrote it down because i thought otherwise i won't get it together
so anyway you've all been very kind and very generous i really appreciate it the balloons
are lovely the plant is lovely thank you all very much it truly has been amazing seven and a half
years it's we've really accomplished a lot and many of you linda you included have outlined much
of what we've done it's really been quite amazing but one of the reasons that we've been so successful
is because of the board that we've been able to work with both governors brown and newsome
have selected amazing folks as witnessed today by everything we've worked on today together
to serve in california and this it's a hard board some boards are easy this one isn't a lot of work
on this board i feel very fortunate to have worked with such an esteemed group now and in the past
because as eileen and sue and some of the other folks have been on board patricia rucker for a
long time now we've had some very good folks go through this board it's been a special privilege
to serve under the leadership of linda and my curse before before her i can't imagine
having done this job without their incredible leadership and partnership i feel like that's
been a special gift i knew this was going to be hard
i'm all right i'll take a deep breath here i'm very aware too that we've done what we've done
together wouldn't be possible without the collaboration of the superintendent and his
staff in fact we wouldn't have a board agenda without the department i want to thank tony and
stephanie and the staff of the department for their work with us in years past tom tollex and
glenn price michelle zoom and rich ziger goes back a ways and their leadership teams were
critical partners as well thanks for working so closely with the board this is the hard part
as i said to linda i will get this together transitions are hard because of the people that
leave so i especially want to thank the state board staff past and present wouldn't have been
as successful as we've been accomplished as much as we did or enjoyed the work as much as we have
if it weren't for a strong team many of them are in the room today so thank you i thank you for
taking and responding to my evening and weekend calls text messages and emails when i just had to
know an answer to a burning question of course at that moment it was most important i'm sure
the work can be hard but it's also incredibly rewarding i wouldn't have done this job as long
as i have if it wasn't thank you for your support your professionalism and especially for the last
we shared you're a great team i'm also thrilled that brooks will succeed me in this position
and congratulations brooks and welcome back to the state board thank you
um thank you thank you thank you jaron and welcome welcome to brooks and thanks to all for sharing
those amazing thoughts um and now um going from the sublime to the mundane we are going to move
to the two other items of this agenda beginning with the approval of our draft minutes for the
approval of our draft minutes for the july 2020 state board meeting and then we'll go to the
board member liaison reports so we want to get to the
board minutes and i'm trying to just be sure that we
uh we don't have to have those presented i think we just need a motion to approve them
do i have a motion
i'll move thank you do i have a second i'll second thank you all in favor oh do we need
to do a roll call yes we have to recall okay you're on karen sue aye linda aye zade
stain oh yes to abstain that's right thank you for reminding me cynthia aye jim
hi sorry him and jim i know it's jim jim um matt hi kim
hi jim hi day hi patricia hi elene hi ting hi okay it's approved all right linda this is sue
i'm sorry i realize i should have abstained because i was not present at the july meeting
okay yes okay thank you all right uh so we're going to do our um liaison reports and um i'm
going to urge you to keep them succinct um because we are now headed way into the evening hours if we
stay at the pace we've been uh but we of course interested in them and i want to start with
member sun i'm going to go and reverse alphabetical order that's great i okay so just
really quickly the um california joint workforce uh pathways advisory committee is meeting
in a couple weeks a little bit later in september and i think i've reported our next work is to work
on the california um career technical education plan for california now that we have our perkins
application has been approved and um i wanted just to remind the field that our
the ctig grants are out right now the application is out and i did have it written down somewhere
when it's due and i don't have it in front of me right now i apologize i didn't realize i was
going to go first and then um also the california a12 strong workforce grant application is also out
as well for the field and i'm sorry you don't have my dates with me so uh i'm sure you could
find them on the cte website i mean the cde website thank you all right great vice president
strouse um yeah okay um the instructional quality commission met on august 13th um and we reviewed
edited and revised the draft of the ethnic studies model curriculum it's now out for public comment
and um the iqc will review those comments and recommended edits at the november iqc meeting
they do meet next week um the california practitioners advisory group met on august 14th
we gave a lot of input into the state accountability measures we talked a lot
about the stabilization of the five by five grid we talked about the growth measure which we heard
today and the cci indicators the advisory commission on special education met on august 19th
and 20th and welcomed our new special ed director heather heather calamese um and she gave an update
on the special education division work so they also gave us an update on the learning continuity
plan guidance we talked about disproportionality special education due process mediation and
resolution and there was an update on lpac for 2021 um the special education stakeholder meetings
to update and do our state plan met on august 12th and 26th they said we're talking about
targets for goals for the state performance plan um i have to thank the cde team led by shiloh
duncan bursaril and nora parela they were amazing and helping to facilitate and the members of
stakeholder work group really participated those both those long days of input we talked about
least restrictive environment achievement targets early childhood options and parent participation
special education continues to be a really important area to get input and to make sure
that we're providing the right support the state literacy team met on august 19th and 20th
um we got input on from three separate groups early childhood elementary and secondary
to improve the plan and next week when iqc meets they'll be reviewing the literacy plan
and then it will go out for public comment and come back to iqc before it goes to the state
board for approval following the approval then there will be grants going out to some county
offices to support literacy work in districts and finally um board member board president
darling hammon talked about um positions um that are being posted on the cd website the screening
committee um is is going to be working on openings in advisory commission on charter schools
advisory commission for special ed the practitioners advisory commission a student
member of iqc and a student board member so those all those applications close on the eighth of
october and then the advisory commission will be working really um to to screen them do interviews
and our intent is to make recommendations for appointments at our november meeting
so please i just ask everyone to share with colleagues who you think might be interested
in supporting our work at the state and that ends my liaison report thank you thank you very much
never record
i'm thankful we can see you now yeah okay well um i've already i will connect myself to the
report that's already been made by board member sa and board member strouse concerning the joint
workforce pathways in the iqc i will just report or update that this morning while the board was
meeting um i am the liaison to the cal to the military interstate children's compact commission
that's the organization the advisory committee for the board that implements the state military
compact that is a plan for use to support children who are military dependents as a
milit child who grew up in the military myself this is very very important work
their annual meeting was held this morning from nine to twelve i was not able to attend because
obviously i was here at the board meeting we i want to welcome our new staff liaison kai jackson
who all of you are familiar with from his work that he has already been doing for the superintendent
in the department of education he's taking over that work they basically this was a business
meeting and going over and reviewing the information the information sharing and discussion of issues
the next meeting i don't have that scheduled date but i will make sure i report on that
information at subsequent board meetings i also want to remind you that tomorrow i'll be having
going to the second meeting for the whole child policy study group it's scheduled as a virtual
meeting on september 11th we had our first meeting just after the july board meeting that was an
introductory meeting we had an opportunity just to discuss opening policies and take a look at
what we want to try to accomplish with the work we were doing tomorrow's meeting we're going to
get more into the nuts and bolts of the work that's actually being implemented california was
specifically asked to share some information about the work we're doing to provide support online
for students and on how we're accounting and making contact and reaching out to students
as part of our distance learning activity so that is information i'll be reporting and sharing out
from the content that's already been provided in such detail and so ably from our state
superintendent so i do want to thank you for the timeliness of that information and i will report
back to you on the work in progress going on from that work group meeting at our november
stay for me terrific thank you member rodriguez yes hello thank you
so first of all i want to acknowledge members strouse's tremendous work as a liaison with the
ctc and i'm sure that you were missed and they were surprised to see me although it was you know
good to be back there and you know the my report is mainly about the continuation of the work
actually that was started when president darlene hammond you know back when when the
special education task force in 2015 issued a report and we're coming around the ctc adopted
the new structure for the preliminary education specialist teaching credential and it'll take
effect summer fall 2022 the credential structure is designed to support the vision of one system
for all right which was work that was started a while back for informed by the special education
task force and while there were seven credentials at one point these have been these are five new
credential areas early childhood special education visual impairments deaf and hard of hearing mild
to moderate support needs and extensive support needs and ctc wants to work with the teachers who
are currently already credential and ways to look for the to add the authorizations which would be
either through coursework professional development or prior knowledge demonstrated competence
additionally the universal teaching performance expectation the tb
has established a common foundation for all teachers based on the concept that
teachers are teachers of all students all students are general education students first
and that all students need intervention at different points in their academic career
and so the design team for the education specialist cal tpa has come to consensus
that the education specialist cal tpa will align with key qualities of the general education cal
tpa a task-based structure that is completed at two different times during a candidate's
preliminary preparation program and there was a discussion on the issues with virtual teaching
and three points came up the clinical practice right and the 2021 continues to be 600 hours for
teachers but the focus should be on ensuring that candidates have sufficient experiences
to develop their teaching practices this is for beginning teachers who are you know getting their
teaching credential and then the teacher and administrator induction
was discussed how to focus the induction make sure that it's individualized for each candidate
and then the child development permit the members gave input on how the ctc can best support them
let's see here there there's a work group the that's updating the california standards for
the teaching profession and that is continual and that will they will meet again september november
for the next steps it was a very robust and rich meeting took two days but i'm trying to condense
this for the sake of time and then there was also a wonderful presentation on micro credentials
and micro credentials is a competence-based system that for teachers who are already in the
classroom something that can be done at as a classroom teacher at our own pace and it's a
wonderful way to push the profession forward based on the the needs of our students right so
the credentials would be something that's added on to our our current teaching credential but
with a specialty and one of the wonderful things about the micro credentials is that it's innovative
and it's competency-based therefore as we are rethinking what our students need
this is an innovative way to get us to understand the needs of our students as well
so that's my report thank you terrific thank you member petia brunson
um hi i wanted to share an update on the california statewide early math initiative
and the 2020 institute which was held on august the third and there were educators from all around
the state and from county offices of ed who were sharing in a number of poster sessions and also
larger format conversations about strategies that they are seeing make changes in how educators both
understand the teaching of math but also feel confidence and have strategies to apply everyday
math and integrate it with ele integrate it into the ongoing coursework with children with
disabilities and also making sure that english language learners are brought into this work as
well it was an incredible cross-section of folks from kern modic riverside humble chasta
um president i will not read the full list um but i i think the common thread um is really that
it is about how how do we support teachers um to grow not just the mechanical skills of addition
and counting in the early years but math mindsets um some of the literature i think that we were
looking um at was also um looking at in an international context the idea for example that
um that any group of people might be considered um good or bad at math um is is a something that
doesn't exist in other countries um and also is not considered optional that you could for example
as a fifth grade girl decide to opt out and not be good at math is not really something that's on
the table in lots of other countries and something that we should um invite in california as well um
i i think we are behind on the agenda so i'll just stop there and um was really just glad to
offer support for the state board um for work that is continuing
perfect member novel sure there's a lot going on with cce i'll pull out uh just two highlights
the cc continues to work in collaboration with the cd county office and state board staff
to support and be responsive to lea's and california system of support
in regards to coven 19 pandemic at the august 6th board meeting we affirmed three goals
goal one was direct technical assistance to support lea's and who are receiving direct
technical assistance to address the issues and needs that they have for their students
goal two was professional learning identifying expanding and developing professional learning
resources focused on priority topics and goal three was a system of support which is the
facilitation and development of implementation structures relationships and processes to support
lea's we also have several rfps out right now two of the rfps one of which is data analysis
visualization and content development services that is due august 26th and research and development
support for expansion of the continuity learning playbook and that is due august 28th so if you
want more information those are on the cce website and that will do it i'll bring it to a close
all right thank you member mccullin
i don't have much for report i haven't uh been on long enough or attended uh
attended any other liaison type functions yet but next time i'll have more of a report i hope
all right great thank you um member glover woods well member strass covered quite comprehensively
the past and future work for the ethnic studies model curriculum draft work so i do not have
anything more to add to what she has already shared thank you well thank you both for kind of
moving us forward and keeping us marching member zade patah well you haven't yet had any liaison
responsibilities but you're welcome to make any comments yeah so i guess i've been mainly focusing
on getting the the word out there for the position and applying for the position as a few board
members have mentioned before it's due october 8th so i contributed to an article to encourage
students to apply and i kind of introduced myself in my experience and that article was sent out
in a mailing list to 1100 students across the state and then i've been working with just some
student organizations such as gen up to i guess get the position advertised through their social
media and kind of in beginning preparation with the california association of student councils
for our conference which is october 31st to november 2nd to select next year's student member
or the three finalists for next year student member position terrific member burr
i'll also be brief you heard about my work already this morning on accountability
and on the the federal work and there'll be a couple of items on charters later but no
charter hearings so that's all i have to report and thankfully we don't have to fit
charter hearings in today that was a long one last time i will simply add that most of my
effort has gone to managing this transition from karen to brooks and helping us get to a master
plan for early childhood education that will be released shortly there is a wonderful team of
analysts working from wested the rand corporation and a variety of other organizations in the
consortium to help us launch by october a master plan for early childhood which will look ahead a
number of years to where we want to be at the point where there is a more predictable budget
in place than what we're experiencing this year but we'll also figure out some of the starting
places towards that goal that can be put in place sooner than later and get us moving in a
useful direction so we'll have a lot more to say about that soon kim also serves as a liaison to
that committee and by the time we see each other again we'll be able to talk about it
and with that i think we have deserved a 10-minute break i want to caution you not
to leave the room do not leave the room but do turn off your microphone in your video and we'll
see you at 2 37 okay karen are you there i am here we have everybody can you check
i think we're ready to be um live again and let me check and see if we can be yep
and just to cue people we're going back to item four
slenda we we're live okay very good uh so let's re-establish the quorum uh karen can you call the
roll yes ting
ting here here
patricia here i day here kim
kim here here matt here jim here cynthia here zade here linda here see you here everyone's here
everyone's here
all right um we're going to take up item number four which is the mega assessment item
it includes a summary of developments and updates related to the california assessment of student
performance the cask the english language proficiency assessments the lpac and the
california fitness physical fitness test the pft among other updates there's not any recommended
action as it is being presented for information only this item will be presented by mal vang of
the cde mal hello thank you good afternoon uh chief deputy gregson president darlin hammon and
board members as um president darlin hammon mentioned i'm mal vang director of the assessment
development and administration division before i continue with my item i just want to take this
opportunity to thank uh karen staff walter also for her leadership and support and i want to wish
her all the best in her new role as cecessa so i will continue with my item that again the item
before you today is an information item um in my presentation i will provide sorry it's a little
bit my um in this presentation i will provide program updates on the california assessment
of student performance and progress the english language proficiency assessments for california
and the physical fitness test and then i will show some uh key resources or share some key resources
as well as trainings and educator involvement opportunities then i will finish with some time
for questions sorry
first we'll provide the update on the california assessment of student performance and progress or
casp this slide provides an overview of the assessments within casp and under the general
assessment column we have the smarter balanced english language arts um literacy literacy or
ela and mathematics and about 3.2 million students in grades three through eight and 11 take these
assessments then for students with significant cognitive disabilities whose individualized
education plans or iep specify that they take an alternate assessment are eligible to take the
california alternate assessments or caas for ele and mathematics which last year about 49 000
students are eligible or were eligible to take them in grades three through eight and 11 next
we have the cast or the california science test for about 1 million students in grades five and
about 500 000 students that that take it once in 10th 11th or 12th grade in high school
now the california alternate assessment or caa for science is the alternate assessment
for students with the significant cognitive disabilities whose iep specify that they take
an alternate assessment and last year about 21 000 students were eligible to take the caa for science
in grades five eight and once in high school then we have the csa or the california spanish
assessment in spanish reading language arts and last year there were about 33 500 students in
grades three through eight and about excuse me 5 500 students in high school who were registered
to take the csa so some students such as those who are in bilingual education or spanish or dual
immersion programs take this and they also take the smarter balance test also take this
csa so overall some students can take up to four assessments depending on the grade level
so with the exception of the caa for science the statewide testing window this year for all the
other casp assessments will begin on january 12 2021 and end on july 15 2021
so a large part of the casp is the smarter balance assessment system california did
join the smarter balance assessment consortium in june 2011 as a governing state and we have
worked with the member the other members in the consortium on development of the english language
arts literacy and mathematics assessments which measure the common core state standards
and were adopted by our california state board of education so the three components of the smarter
balance assessment system which are the summative assessments the interim assessments and tools
for teachers are designed to support teaching and learning throughout the year the smarter
balance summative assessments for english language arts and mathematics serve as california's end of
year assessments for these two content areas the smarter balance interims for for english language
arts and math which can be used as strategic times throughout the school year and tools for teachers
which is a great new resource of formative assessment tools and strategies that can be
used to support daily instruction so we'll go into more detail on the interim assessments
and the tools for teachers shortly so first let's look at the overview and overview of the
interim assessments there are three types the focus interim assessment blocks the interim assessment
blocks or you know your ibs and then the which assess let me back up a little bit the focus
interim assessment blocks really assess about one to three targets the interim assessment blocks
overall assesses about one to eight targets and then the interim comprehensive assessments or icas
assess the same targets as the summative assessment so between the three types of interim
assessments there are over 160 interim assessments to choose from about 75 for math and 90 for ela
they were made available to local educational agencies on august 20th and will continue to be
available for to support distance learning throughout the school year which means that
the students or these interim assessments can be administered remotely to students on their devices
and instructions to do so are on the casp.org website
in addition a new tool called the interim assessment item portal was introduced also or
made available in august 2020 through this new portal educators can search for view and print
interim assessment items and the it really does allow users to search for interim assessment
items by grade subject test name claim target and even content standard so this new tool
can be accessed through the tools with teachers website which i will talk about next
and as i came to you in july and shared a little bit about the tools for teachers
it is really the formative assessment component that replaced the digital library and the smarter
balance system and in it there are hundreds of instructional resources for kindergarten through
grade 12 students they are aligned with the common core state standards for english language arts and
math and all resources must adhere to a set of quality criteria for example every instructional
resource is embedded with strategies to implement all components of the formative assessment process
and has embedded accessibility strategies to ensure that the resources can be used meaningfully
with all students and every source a resource also offers differentiation strategies for working with
strategies for working with students with varying levels of need
so really one of the key features is the interim connections playlist for the interim assessment
blocks that i mentioned they provide a description of what students generally know and what
i can do when they are below near or above expectation on that content area also we have
um provide an academic vocabulary as part of that so that students are expect vocabulary that
students are expected to know for that content which can be very helpful in planning instruction
as well so furthermore there are professional learning resources such as videos and use case
scenarios for how to use the interim assessments some other key features i just want to point out
is now it's fully accessible and has a lot of publicly available content before you even need
to log in so other people can look at the site even if they may not have work in a local educational
agency that would have access and there are enhanced ways on the website for educators to
share resources where they're called with their colleagues another benefit is that
california has our own instance of the tools for teachers so we can add resources developed by
california for other subject areas as i will explain later on how we will soon be able to
offer science resources and there is a self registration available for staff who have
and local educational specific work email address that they can self register
or the majority of the people in the system are already registered through our test operations
management system locally so a preview of the tools for teachers website have been available
since june 16th and every digital account holder automatically received that tools for teachers
account at that time so the official grant opening of tools for teachers just want to remind you will
be on september 30th in conjunction with the 10 year anniversary for smarter balance and between
now and then more features and content will be added as well so on that note let's transition
to the california science tests updates as a reminder this is an online assessment as well
many of our assessments are have all transitioned to online assessments and it's administered to
eligible students in grades five eight and one time in high school our high school means high
school for this test means grades 10 11 or 12 so to allow students the chance to become familiar
with the cast we have training and practice tests available on the online practice and training test
portal web page on the casp website students parents and guardians and educators can use
the training tests to view the different item types and practice tests to view the depth and
breadth of the cast content next i would like to provide you an update on the elementary school
science instructional resources aligned with our california next generation science standards
since i mentioned since california has its own instance of the tools for teachers we can add
resources developed by our california educators for the other subjects beyond ele math so tools
for teachers will soon have 38 assessment instructional resources for grades three
okay through five in earth and space sciences life sciences physical sciences and engineering
technology and applications of science so since april we've been developing those resources and
they will have as they were being developed by educators they have these of this goal in
mind is to embed the formative assessment and accessibility strategies that promote opportunities
for three-dimensional learning and emphasize hands-on activities that facilitate peer feedback and
collaboration and then integrate the common core state standards for ele and math into the
resources so cd is planning to have some additional work with educators to develop additional
resources throughout the school year as well onto the california alternate assessment for science
updates this test is for uh is administer with the most significant students with the most
significant cognitive disabilities again whose um individualized education plan indicates that
they use an alternate assessment so test examiners administer four embedded performance tasks
throughout the year two students one-on-one as close to the time of instruction for each
performance task as possible so the first operational caa for science opened on september 8th
and it will be available throughout the year we have updated the exam test examiner tutorial
which can be found on the cde's california alternate assessment for science main webpage
we have also updated the caa for science administration planning guides and version
assignments and these links again can be found on the casp website and the caa main webpage
so now let me take a few minutes and give you some updates on the california on the excuse me on the
english language proficiency assessments for california or alpac
so this slide provides an overview of the assessments under alpac under the general
assessment column the initial alpac is administered to approximately 300 000
newly enrolled students whose primary language is not english and it's based on the home language
survey for students in kindergarten through grade 12 to identify students as english learners or
initial fluent english proficient so the initial alpac testing window is from july 1
2020 through june 30th 2021 so under the alternate assessment column is the initial alternate alpac
i want to say that this is still under development it will be available starting in the 2021-22
school year for assessing eligible newly enrolled students with significant cognitive disabilities
whose primary language is not english again based on the home language survey in kindergarten through
grade 12 so they can use it to identify whether they are english learners or initial fluent english
proficient next we have the summative alpac which is given to about 1.5 million students in
kindergarten through grade 12 who have been identified as english learners based on the
results of the initial alpac and measures a student's progress toward english proficiency
so the results support decisions or is used to make decisions for students to be redesignated
as fluent english proficient the summative alpac testing window is from february 1st through may
31st 2021 for the first time this year eligible english learners in kindergarten through grade 12
with significant cognitive disabilities whose iep specified that they take an alternate assessment
will be able to take a summative alternate alpac operational field test so up to this year we have
not had a statewide alternate assessment for alpac at all
next i'd like to share a few updates about the operational administration of the 2019-20
summative alpac so due to the testing suspension last year many english learner students did not
complete taking the 2019-2020 summative alpac and senate bill 98 approved by the governor on
june 29th 2020 provided and it provided for an extension of the 2019-20 2020 summative alpac
as an optional administration for reclassification purposes and the window has opened from it's being
made available from august 20th through october 30th for english learners to complete their
assessments so that the results can be used for reclassification so if the students were eligible
on may 31st to take the summative they will remain eligible to take the optional summative
alpac so the primary purpose is for reclassification of students who have already met
the remaining criteria however lea's have the discretion to determine which students
will most benefit from the administration so english learners who partially completed the
summative alpac last spring will be able to complete any remaining domains this fall along
with other students who were not able to begin testing at all last spring
on may 31st a snapshot of the eligible english learner students was collected and these students
are available in our test operations management system students who have moved will still be
available in the toms system and coordinators can run their completion status reports to identify
those students the only students who are not available or not eligible are the newly enrolled
or not eligible are the newly enrolled students this year because they should be taking our
initial alpac so lastly lea's will be provided with a cumulative file that includes results
from the spring and the fall for the 2019-2020 summative administrations
as a reminder the alternate alpac blueprints were approved last may at the state board of
education meeting which allow for the continued development and preparations for the alternate
alpac operational field tests scheduled for july no january excuse me through january 12th through
february 16th 2021 so this field test is a census field test meaning that all eligible english
learner students with the most significant cognitive disabilities will be required to
participate and in preparation for this field test we have recommended to local educational agencies
that they hold individual education program team meetings to discuss the students participation
in the coming field test if they are eligible for alternate assessments
so to assist local educational agencies parents guardians and students prepare for this field test
training and practice tests are being developed and in fact the training tests are now available
and the practice tests will be available in november so to prepare the test examiners for
the upcoming field tests virtual administration and scoring training will be available in the
moodle training site this november and we are very excited about the development of this new assessment
as it will provide consistency throughout the state in how english language proficiency
of our english learner students with the most significant cognitive disability is being measured
now i will transition to provide a status on the physical fitness test which is given to
students in grades five seven and nine
contingent upon the approval upon the approval of the governor senate bill
820 proposes to suspend the physical fitness test for the 20 21 2021 school year and require that
the superintendent of public instruction consult with experts and other stakeholders
and to provide recommendations on the purpose and administration of the tests
to the appropriate fiscal and policy committees of the legislature the department of finance and
the state board of education by november 1 2022 so more information will be provided when they
become available so i will transition to share some key resources and highlight them for you
one resource update is the california educator reporting system also known as
sirs we love our acronyms which is the secure website that california
local educational agency staff can use to access individual and aggregate student results from the
smarter balance interim assessments as well as the results from all of our casp and alpac summative
assessments so the historical results from summative assessments through 2018-19 school
year are all available and they are available for the smarter balance ela and math assessments
the california alternate assessments for ela and math the science test the california
spanish assessment and the summative alpac so over the coming months our results from
these 2019-20 assessments that are available will be added to sirs and starting in the spring of
2021 regular feeds of the summative assessment results as they happen will start to occur
weekly for alpac assessments and daily for casp assessments
um again a quick little reminder about the availability of our sirs sandbox training tool
which is which was released last year in july 2019 and it's still publicly available it is a
useful tool to help staff become familiar with the features of sirs in a non-secure environment
so this website has the same structure and features as sirs except all the data is mock data
so in fact there is mock data for all of the assessments that sirs houses results for as i
just mentioned in the previous slide and it is useful for individual and group learning opportunities
another resource update is the smarter balance usability accessibility and accommodations
accessibility and accommodations guidelines document smarter balance maintains and updates
this guide this um the set of guidelines which includes all accessibility resources that are
available for the english language arts and mathematics assessments and the same category
structure is applied to non-smarter balance assessments for consistency purposes
so smarter balance just concluded the most recent guide um guidelines document review cycle and the
updated guidelines are um for the 2020-21 test administration year was published on june 30th
and the link can be found in the item now just some other quick updates about what the updates
what the updates are in the um guides in the guide um we have some we have added some um
embedded expanded items added some non-embedded calculator clarification update on multiplication
tables update on the hundreds number table and scratch paper clarification and also some text
to speech clarification then we've also updated the frequently asked questions
section and added embedded text to speech in spanish beginning in the 2021-22 school year
which will provide one year for us to pilot a new resource
and one more um new and exciting resource is um providing access to the lexile and quantile measures
so these provide access to um research-based tools for educators families and students to learn how
these measures can be used to advance student learning and growth and both in the classroom
and at home so the resource links the assessment results from the smarter balance english language
arts and mathematics with instruction so that teachers can target instruction to students
abilities promote students growth and monitor their progress and effectively communicate student
achievement and evaluate the effectiveness of instructional programs and interventions
so there are three levels three access levels provided to provide the for each of the user groups
so there is free guest access for students where they don't have to have an email address and no
registration required then there's a free basic plus access for families where an email is required
for registration and then free premium access for all california educators so the link to the hub
is https hub.lexile.com the educator hub will be the first set of resources available for california
educators parents and students and through our contractor educational testing service you will
educators will receive more information about how to access this in the coming days
just some overall there's specific lexile tools for english language arts they are find a book
these tools are a tool called analyzer there are word lists there's a career database that allows
users to identify reading demands needed for a desired career which can inform goal setting
for students there's a measures manager a growth planner there are grade level charts
and similar specific quantile tools for mathematics
they are summer math challenge a tool called that a math skills database is a teacher assistant
a tool a math at home tool career database again measures manager there's a find your lesson
a growth planner tool and grade level charts so again more information about access to these
about access to these resources is coming soon
so that was the updates on our assessment programs i will now move on to a brief overview of some
trainings and educator involvement opportunities this fall or to support the use of interim
assessments we continue to provide virtual hand scoring trainings this fall we will offer two
types of virtual workshop series one using a train the trainer model for ele and for
local educational agencies staff trainers and one focus on training teachers who will need to
conduct hand scoring the goals of both trainings will be for participants to understand the design
and items item types of interim assessments and how they work together to support learning
and both trainings will provide level setting for how students writing score writing is scored
and include time for collaboration and hand scoring practice
just the overview of the tools for teachers training opportunities with the grand opening
coming up on september 30th we've done a number of provided some several tools for teachers
professional opportunities and some upcoming ones as well for example on june 22nd our cde
staff provided an overview and demonstration webinar to show the key features on july 28th
smart balance conducted a train the trainer workshop for regional representatives and then
on september 8th two days ago all california educators were invited to a shared practices
webinar that feature california educators sharing their use of resources in the tools for teachers
and this fall cde will offer the interim and formative assessment training series and the
and through the california assessment conference we'll have some virtual sessions on the tools for
teachers with that which that that leads me to our upcoming 2020 virtual california assessment
conference which will be on october 6th and 7th this will be the second year we host the
california assessment conference or cac as we call it we are very excited that president
darlin hampton and superintendent thurman will be able to join us in a welcome session to kick off
the conference and this is really exciting for the participants and for the staff who's been
working on this conference and the primary audience is teachers classroom educators and
site administrators there will be some pre-recorded sessions and live sessions across both dates
there are over 30 assessment sessions developed by the cde and presented by our trainers or
training teams made up of educators across the state there are over 30 shared practice
sessions presented by educators who will share some of the amazing work they are doing tying
assessment to classroom instruction and improve teaching to improve teaching and learning and we
have even made sure that there are plenty of sessions happening after 2 pm for teachers who
cannot get substitutes so registration is about 99 this year since we are going virtual please help
us spread the word and more information can be found at https www.cdecac.org
so where to access trainings and educator involvement opportunities we are constantly
accepting registrations and applications for our trainings and educator involvement opportunities
so to access these opportunities go to the home page of casp.org and alpac.org select the
training tab for the upcoming training activities for each assessment program and then select the
get involved tab for upcoming educator involvement opportunities such as standard setting and item
reviews okay reminder that we are we do have a twitter account and please follow us on twitter
at cde assessments for more ongoing updates so this kind of comes to the conclusion of my
presentation but before i stop for questions i do have a panelist marianne arcella from educational
testing service or ets she would like to say a few words to karen so i'm gonna stop here so she
could say a few words on behalf of ets and the ets partners that support the state with the
california education system assessment system karen i really want to thank you for your
leadership one of the things i mean you have you've accomplished many things you know while you're
here and saw you know the state through a lot of change one of the biggest changes that i was
directly involved with that where i got to work with you a little bit a lot is the california
assessment system and changing over from full paper full on hundred percent online and on top
of that adding a lot of new assessments and so really appreciate your leadership and and all
that you've done for the students of california and we're looking forward you know congratulations
on your new your new gig and we're looking forward to working with you in your new capacity
and we also want to i also want to say a few words of welcoming brooks allenbach and we're
looking forward to working with you as well as with the other new board members thank you
okay so with that i'm going to stop talking and i will be available to take any questions if there
are any first we're going to get the public comment slide up there and members of the public
and members of the public who want to provide comment can call that number
and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in i want to ask ting sun
as an assessment liaison if she has any initial comments before me and then we'll ask board
members if they have any clarifying questions and we'll go to the public comment and come back for
discussion yeah just a real quick comment as you can see even though we did not have our assessments
last spring that the work of this division continues to work to go on and so there's still
a lot of work there thank mal and her staff for the hard work they did and i'm especially excited
that we will now get the lexile and quantile scores as part of the interim assessments
i think that this will provide the field and parents during this time of distance learning
some very actionable tools actionable information and some tools that they can help support their
students and maybe even mitigate some of the learning loss so i'm very very excited that mal
was able to get that for us and so just thank you for your persistence and for your hard work
and getting this to us so quickly and i'll just add my thanks to mal and also recognize the
perseverance of ting in you know figuring out that there was an additional kind of assistance we
could offer districts in this moment and really helping us figure out how that might how that
might work so we're doing as you can see everything we can to help districts figure out how to support
students learn about their learning and build on that even when we don't have at the moment
the large-scale summative test from last year i don't see any hands for clarification questions
at the moment so that being the case we will go ahead to public comment if there is any
we do not have any public speakers for this item all right so if there's no public comment we can
have any other board discussion and this is not an action item so really this is just for our
collective information at this time is there any other board discussion
seeing none mal thank you very very much we are fully informed and we thank you for all the work
that has gone into the items that you presented we're going to move right ahead then to item
five which is the approval of the state seal of civic engagement criteria this item does have an
criteria this item does have an addendum the cde recommends that the state board adopt the state
seal of civic engagement recommended criteria for local use the item is presented by barbara
murchison of the cde nice to see you again barbara take it away nice to be back with you again good
afternoon president arling hammon chief deputy gregson and board members i'm barbara murchison
director of the educator excellence and equity division here at the cde it is my pleasure to
bring to you revised criteria for the state seal of civic engagement for your approval
this is an action item the cde recommends that the state board of education
there we go adopt the criteria for use by local educational agencies the criteria designed to
provide local educational agencies or leas with a framework for making determinations of student
qualifications required to earn the seal based on their own local context once the criteria are
approved the cde will encourage leas to implement the criteria in a manner appropriate for their
own local context to ensure maximum maximum accessibility for all students at all grade levels
including those in alternative school settings
based on your feedback we've made several updates to the criteria and guidance
originally provided to you in july and september of 2019 first i'll quickly review the authorizing
statute through which the criteria and guidance were developed and then i'll share with you some
highlights of our updates to the proposed criteria and guidance here is a bit of the
education code to help ground us in the intent of the legislature it is the intent of the
legislature to establish a state seal of civic engagement to encourage and create pathways for
pupils in elementary and secondary schools to become civically engaged
in democratic governmental institutions at the local state and national levels
california education code requires the state superintendent of public instruction to develop
and recommend to the state board of education criteria for awarding the state seal of civic
engagement students receiving the seal must demonstrate excellence in civics education
and participation and have an understanding of the united states california constitutions
and democratic systems of government the statute requires the superintendent to incorporate the
six proven practices for effective civic learning developed by the education commission of the
states and any and all other best practices for civic learning and engagement the superintendent
was also required to consult with a group of classroom teachers who teach history social
science and secondary schools as part of the criteria development process
the superintendent was required to consider a number of other criteria including completion
of history government and civics classes and participation in community service or
extracurricular activities the statute also provides some flexibility for the superintendent
to develop other requirements as appropriate here are a couple of other key elements from the
statute again to ground us in the legislative intent the statute does say that the criteria
should provide all pupils with the opportunity to earn the seal the statute also provides some
guidance that the seal should recognize outstanding achievement while also remaining
somewhat independent of grades or other established measures of achievement the
seal should also provide benefit to students beyond high school to the extent possible
so now that i've reviewed the statutory requirements i'm going to quickly review the
process through which the draft criteria were developed first the cde conducted an application
process to identify classroom history social science teachers to serve on the state seal of
civic engagement advisory group we walked the advisory group through a set of prompts based
on statute to solicit feedback on what should be included in the criteria and then we conducted a
public comment period around that draft criteria early on we met with members of the advisory
commission on special education to seek their advice around ensuring the seal was accessible
to students with disabilities and during this period we also asked cde staff to review the
draft criteria in particular staff who serve english learners migrant students students in
special education programs foster youth and youth who are homeless to make sure that the
criteria were such that all of these students could potentially earn the seal we also convened
representatives from the power of democracy group the california history social science project
the constitutional rights foundation the promoting authentic college career and civic
readiness assessment systems committee the los angeles county office of education
and the california civic engagement project to help refine those early drafts
we first presented the criteria to the board in july 2019 for feedback and then again
in september 2019 for recommended adoption key feedback received in september 2019 included a
recommendation to look into incorporating civic engagement into the college career indicator
or cci which i will review in a few minutes we have since partnered with the analysis measurement
and accountability reporting division within the cde to convene a civic engagement work group
which is scheduled to meet virtually three times through december 2020 to weigh in on this
recommendation the cde was originally scheduled to present the updated criteria to the board
for adoption in may 2020 but this was delayed due to the coronavirus outbreak please note that
the statutory deadline for the board to adopt reject or modify the seal is january 31st 2021
so cde first presented the criteria to the board on july 10th 2019 and as i shared in september
i think that was one of the most robust conversations i have ever enjoyed from this place
here at at the podium people are very engaged and very excited to have the opportunity to
encourage additional civic engagement amongst our students feedback we received in july 2019
feedback we received in july 2019 included seeking to ensure that the seal is accessible
to all students that it would support continuous civic engagement that it would promote diversity
and inclusion that it would provide multiple opportunities to engage even our youngest student
and that it would support civic engagement across the content areas and there was also
quite a lot of conversation regarding how the seal might be included in the accountability system
some board members suggested that we use this as a local indicator and others thought that it
should be included in the cci the september 2019 presentation also provided us with additional
feedback regarding the criteria and guidance since then the cde has worked with stakeholders
to further modify the criteria and guidance so that it ensures the seal is accessible to
all california students supports continuous and rigorous civic engagement promotes diversity and
inclusion engages even the youngest students supports an interdisciplinary approach and
explicitly recognizes civil disobedience as a form of civic engagement i will provide a
quick summary of some of these updates for you so of particular importance i think to everyone
is the intention that the seal remain accessible to all california students we'd like as many
students as possible to be encouraged to engage in civic affairs so after we created a second path
to include civic engagement in the cci we revisited the seal criteria to ensure that the
criteria for this seal the one the criteria that i'm bringing to you for adoption today
are very clear that the seal should be accessible to as many students as possible first we change
the language of criterion one so it now reads the student must be engaged in academic work in a
productive way we also clarified in the guidance to criteria one to be explicit that students in
alternative school settings are also eligible to earn the seal we recognize that student engagement
the seal we recognize that student engagement and academic work can look very different based
on context and not all students may be on track to complete required high school coursework we
did not want this to be a limited factor for students seeking to earn the seal additionally
criterion four now guides students to demonstrate civic knowledge skills and dispositions through
self-reflection the guidance for criterion four also encourages students to self-reflect
in a variety of formats written and or digital several examples are listed in the guidance
included written reports public presentations podcasts video and other options we made a
similar modification to the guidance for criterion five which now encourages adults to use a variety
of formats to submit recommendations for students applying for the seal while also encouraging lea's
to provide recommendation templates in languages to the common to the local community to the extent
possible we heard your feedback regarding ensuring that civic education is not just the purview of
civics teachers and we strengthened existing language to make it clear that civic education
has a home across the content areas since the statutory language already lays out a rigorous
expectation that students will demonstrate an understanding of the us and california constitutions
and we want to make sure that the seal remains accessible we focused on modifying the guidance
for criterion two to further encourage students and lea's to approach civic engagement in an
interdisciplinary manner this guidance now includes a course in world history or its equivalent
as determined by the lea as a requirement for earning the seal the guidance for criterion two
also now includes specific support for interdisciplinary coursework including economics
law geography ethnic studies and current events among others as well as the ability to apply
this knowledge across multiple settings and circumstances
we also heard a lot of feedback that while flexibility is important in awarding the seal
it should also reflect continuous and rigorous civic engagement so we added language about the
importance of the role of the citizen in a constitutional democracy we also modified the
language for criterion three which now reads participate in one or more informed civic
engagement projects that address real world problems and require students to identify
and inquire into civic needs or problems considered very responses and take action
and reflect on efforts our intention is that this language encourages students to avoid the tendency
to engage in one-off projects instead of focusing on long-term thoughtful civic engagement that
transcends a single class or experience and as you may recall we learned that the term action
civics is somewhat controversial in some parts of the country to the extent that there is some
concern that the term has impeded civic education efforts in some states so for that reason we have
replaced the term action civics with civic engagement
we heard your september 2019 feedback regarding the special place that civil disobedience has in
meaningful civic engagement as we all know events that have transpired in recent months have only
highlighted the significant role that civil disobedience plays in america so we added
additional guidance to criterion three to reflect this the guidance for criterion three
now includes a statement that some acts of civil disobedience such as walkouts or sit-ins may be
considered acts of civic engagement when taken in context of the student's community historic
examples of this include the 1960 greensboro lunch sit-in and the 1963 birmingham children's march
and fall under the category of what congressman john lewis referred to as good trouble
we also refer leas to guidance in criterion five regarding civic mindedness as well as chapter
17 of the 2016 history social science framework which discusses the role of dissent and civil
disobedience in the american democratic system our intention is that this will provide enough
definition that leas can promote examples of civil disobedience when it makes sense within their
own local context additional information on addressing civil disobedience in the classroom
is presented in chapter 17 of the history social science framework
a significant portion of the feedback we received focused on the importance of promoting the
qualities of citizenship and being a good human being in a manner that promotes diversity and
inclusion this has been of heightened importance given the events covid 19 outbreak and movements
for social justice and anti-racism that arose since the last time we presented the criteria
so in addition to the other changes that i've already highlighted for you today
we modified the language of and the guidance for criterion five significantly to promote greater
diversity and inclusivity criterion five now reads exhibit character traits that reflect civic
mindedness and the commitment to positively impact the classroom school community and or
society our intention here is to welcome the vast array of character traits that can indicate civic
mindedness while also emphasizing the positive impact that civic mindedness has not only at
school but in the community and in the larger society we also made significant updates to
further promote diversity and inclusion while helping lea's measure civic mindedness
in the guidance we instruct lea's to consider the extent to which the civic engagement project
exhibit concern for the rights and well-being of all including members of historically disenfranchised
racial and ethnic groups we added language stating that civic mindedness may encompass
a proactive commitment to equity inclusivity racial and ethnic diversity and fairness and
dismantling structures and practices that have previously excluded select groups from civic
participation as examples of evidence of observed character traits of civic mindedness we added
language suggesting that evidence of observed character traits that reflect civic mindedness
may include standing up for oneself or another who is experiencing bullying harassment discrimination
exclusion or unwanted attention we also suggested that when looking for evidence of ongoing civic
engagement lea should consider students demonstrating civic engagement at various points
throughout one's schooling experience by engaging with one or more groups or organizations that
attend to community or societal priorities in addition to forms of engagement that are a required
classroom experience
finally we also heard you say that we should encourage even more children in the earliest
grades to be civically engaged even though students can't be awarded the seal until
completion of a few high school courses our intent is to encourage pathways for people
from elementary schools and up our language on page one of the document states that even
the youngest students can engage in and demonstrate civic knowledge skills and
disposition civic learning opportunities may begin as early as pre-kindergarten elementary
or middle school we also included language in the guidance for criterion three that encourages
lea's and students to form ongoing partnerships with community organizations this can incentivize
ongoing civic engagement for even our youngest students while also continuing to maintain the
seals accessibility by guiding students to acts of civic engagement unique to their community's
needs our updated resources to support civic engagement webpage which we're very proud of
also includes targeted resources for younger students including a section that calls out
resources specifically for students in kindergarten through grade eight
so i want to circle back around to our conversation about officially recognizing civic engagement in
the college career indicator back in the august 2019 information memorandum we shared on this
topic we noted that the criteria would need to be standardized to ensure that the measure
is valid and reliable enough to be included in a state-level indicator integrating civic
level indicator integrating civic engagement into the cci would require extensive developmental
work and would take some time to execute one issue is that the standardization would reduce
the number of eligible students which we feel is inconsistent with the authorizing statute
so in that august 2019 memorandum we recommended exploration of a future advanced seal informed by
the recipients of the basic seal that we're here deliberating today since i last presented the
criteria we have partnered with our friends in the accountability division to convene a civic
engagement work group to go deeper into this possibility of integrating civic engagement
into the cci the group has met once in august already and we are proposing to convene them again
in october and december of this year to really go deep into what it would look like to standardize
measures of civic engagement so that they could be included in the state level indicator we will
we plan to provide an update to the board on progress towards integrating civic engagement
into the cci as part of the annual accountability work plan update in next march 2021
so here are our hopes and dreams for a timeline of when we would be able to integrate a measure of
civic engagement into the cci one thing we have learned through 2020 is that things are subject
to change but you can see here on this slide a timeline where we would meet with our work group
a few times this year and then we can begin to collect data in calpads or calpads and we can
collect data in calpads around how many students are earning the seal it takes a bit as you know
to get data collected through calpads and then we hope if things go according to plan that we
would be able to incorporate some measure of civic engagement into the dashboard by december of 2024
all that said here are five recommended criteria for the state seal please keep in mind that these
criteria provide a framework for local educational agencies to adapt to their own local context
we are very hopeful that many lea's will use them but they are for voluntary use only they are not
binding we hope that they will tailor them in a way that makes sense for their local communities
the student must be engaged in academic work in a productive way demonstrate a competent
understanding of u.s. and california constitutions functions and governance of local governments
tribal government structures and organizations the role of the citizen in constitutional democracy
and democratic principles concepts and processes student must also participate in one or more
informed civic engagement projects that address real world problems and require students to
identify and inquire into civic needs or problems consider varied responses take action and reflect
on efforts they must demonstrate civic knowledge skills and dispositions through self-reflection
and exhibit character traits that reflect civic mindedness and a commitment to positively impact
the classroom school school and the community of california and california and california
community and or society so much more information regarding the seal is available on the cde state
seal of civic engagement webpage including a variety of resources that were used to create
the criteria and again we are really proud to have developed a new webpage our resources to
support civic engagement webpage has been updated we know that folks are in resource
overload a little bit in the era of covid and remote learning so we have reorganized our page
into tabs in an effort to make it easier for different audiences to find what they need on
the page there are specific distance learning resources highlighted right as you land there
as well as the foundational documents to support the work the resources are broken into different
grade spans and organized by the six proven practices of civic learning there are tabs
with resources dedicated for students families and educators so with that i want to thank you
all again for providing such rich helpful feedback in both july and september of last year
we believe that we have managed to incorporate i mean i think about where we were a year ago
and we've got the criteria and we've also got a path going to be able to integrate civic
engagement into the cci so we have come a long way and i also need to thank all of the stakeholders
who have provided us with feedback on various drafts of the criteria and all of the cde staff
members past and present who have helped to shepherd this work over the past two years so
again our recommendation is that the board adopt the recommended criteria for local use
and i would be happy to take any questions at this time
thank you very much barbara we want to put up the public comment slide
and unless there are any clarifying quick clarifying questions now we'll take a discussion
after the public comment and after we've heard from our liaison kim do you want to give us
sort of a little framing where are you kim are you there i am okay great further down in the
hollywood squares yeah so i just wanted to first start by thanking barbara in particular but the
whole cde team for an incredible amount of work i think it's it's a herculean task integrating so
much impassioned feedback but i think for all of us who are board members who are who view this
as part of civic service and civic engagement i think it was demonstrated by how how invested
everyone has been in making sure that we launch this appropriately i think they've also done a
really great job of addressing some of the questions about how to incorporate this into
the accountability conversation and having the two tracks for a basic seal as well as a more
advanced one that will be on a separate sort of work group and calendar has been fantastic
the inclusion of early learners i think is is something that i was also very delighted to see
recognizing that you are not suddenly civic minded upon graduation but that this is a
lifelong learning process that starts early and lastly language around sort of what inclusivity
actually means more concretely to actually sort of say how how that lives and functions in the world
i think the presentation already sort of went through how the cci question will be
answered i also just want to recognize that we got a ton of public comment
and i want to say thank you to the many many students who submitted letters and emails across
the state we got quite a few from and i'm just going to read a sampling from torrance garden
grove oakland santa rosa cerritos san diego san clemeni diablo woodier freemont san jose
los gatos calabasas copertino elk grove san mateo and i will stop reading geographies now
but i i take it all as a endorsement of of a level of student interest and engagement in this topic
which is really healthy and that this practice of even submitting emails and letters of support
is a sure sign of how important it is for folks the last thing that i was going to bring forward
and i think that barbara might have a slide that might be able to be pulled up is is a last piece
of language that i am proposing to wait wait can we wait until after public comment for that
because we're getting beyond clarification okay sorry yes great it will be a discussion and i
want to be sure we get to public comment okay i also want to just fly for folks that we're
going to lose two board members one at six and one at 6 30 we're going to need to
up our pace to get to the votes that have to happen at the end of the day before we lose them
um so let's get to public comment if you if we can um yes and we'll come back to
discussion and we'll have a great discussion about that language
we we currently have uh eight people in this in the queue uh speaker you are now unmuted
please state your name and affiliation for the record please
hi i'm mary yes please go ahead speaker okay mary perry california state pta
and i really want to say that the state seal of civic engagement supports so many of our
organization's goals most specifically our commitment to equity and inclusion for all
students and support for the civic mission of schools the seal can encourage and increase the
capacity of local education agencies to deliver high quality civic learning to every student
but with a special emphasis on students of color those from low-income families and those with
disabilities further this item stresses the importance of civic education being infused
at all grade levels we believe even the youngest students can and should have experiences
that help them see themselves as civic
okay we lost you speaker i am so sorry we we lost you if you'd like to call back we'll try
to get you back in the queue speaker uh please state your name and affiliation for the record
hello is it my line yes go ahead please okay great thank you um hi my name is leticia garcia
on behalf of riverside county superintendent of schools dr judy white we support the recommended
criteria for the state's deal of civic engagement and offer two additional considerations as you
further engage in discussions on how the seal might evolve or be incorporated into the college
and career indicator we ask that you consider the timing of one student's career and their
the timing of when students complete the seal we believe the completion should be earlier in
a student's academic career in order to maximize the benefits of this distinction in college
applications scholarships and career this is especially important for some call some
colleges and universities including the uc will no longer use fat and act test courts for admissions
and second how a student's capacity is consistently measured whether it's through a course grade test
or interview to ensure that all students have access rigor and equity in earning the seal of
civic engagement thank you for your time thank you speaker thank you for calling you are now
unmuted please state your name for the record and affiliation
afternoon my name is joseph all participants are muted
speaker uh we do apologize we had a difficulty i am unmuting you now manually
me good afternoon my name is josh i'm a high school student i am autistic and may
use my place in the comic diaspora so please have pictures of me i'm a freshman and ninth grade
class co-president of san pedro senior high school gifted senior magnet located in san pedro
california i am also part of a superintendent student advisory council for los angeles new
five school district in addition i am a member of congress and loose youth advisory council as well
as an organizing fellow student voice and a member of gen up i am not here on behalf of
this group my comment is my own i'm calling to provide my support on the board of adoption
of the safety of civic engagement civic engagement among youth especially important to me i believe
in utilizing youth voice and influences to influence decisions students must have opportunities to
learn how to create change within their schools and communities and be supported in doing so
particularly students from certain populations populations such as students with sexual needs
foster youth and low-income students african-american youth and students facing homelessness
time you need to hear from all voices and recognize thank you thank you speaker
speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon my name is carlos machado on behalf of the california school boards association
csba appreciates the work of the board and the department on implementing the statute and is
supportive of creating an opportunity for students to be recognized for their civic engagement
activities and their early efforts to shape policy that affects their education community
and beyond thank you again for the time invested in moving this item ahead thank you speaker
next speaker you are now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
good afternoon i'm john transvenia i'm california executive director for generation citizen
who promote action civics and high school civic engagement i want to commend the board and the
staff particularly being able to conduct this meeting in spite of covid we will beat covid
will beat covid but it is exposing inequities and potentially leaving a legacy of cynicism
and mistrust in government that is why it's such a key time to strengthen democracy repair the
health of the body politics and the state seal of civic engagement is a vital and critical tool
to do that not only for this generation but for the next the state seal promotes civic training
and engagement when high school students are forming their identities so part of their
identity should be as members of communities and civic identity is certainly a part of that
i want to associate my remarks also with the previous comments from the representative of
the riverside school district about having this seal being made available earlier in the
student career rather than thank you speaker thank you very much for your leadership
have speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record you are now
unmuted and your time starts now hi this is liz gianna public advocate i am speaking on
behalf of the lcff equity coalition and reinforcing the letter we submitted in support of the
recommendation on the state seal of civic engagement we urge the board though to encourage
the department to build the capacity of lea to implement the seal as recommended by the
packrack working group including by linking various civic engagement education efforts
statewide monitoring and tracking steel participation by student groups to gauge equity
of access and modeling collaboration with community-based organizations thank you thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record you are unmuted
and your time starts now hello my name is michelle alas and i am affiliated with the organization
gen us a student-led education advocacy organization i am also a senior at north
state high school in the mount diablo unified school district in walnut creek california
i'm calling today to urge you to vote yes on item five the california state civic engagement i want
to convince staff on a very well-prepared and thorough presentation i mean for recognizing
that the field would be a starting point in providing avenues for civic learning opportunities
for k-12 students making sure those opportunities are early and frequent and that they are available
to all students this the state field i think would be a great jumping point especially for
combating inadequate provision of civic learning opportunities especially common in schools serving
low-income communities communities of color and immigrant communities and i also urge you to
consider voting to allocate funds specific learning work to ensure a multi-disciplinary approach
and multiple access points thank you so much for your work and for your leadership
and i hope you vote yes on the state field thank you very much speaker next speaker please state
your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello i'm dr erica hudson speaking on behalf of lead a research consortium out of ucr and ucla
that studies and supports access to civic learning opportunities i'm very excited by the leadership
of the state board and cde in developing the state seal of civic engagement and i urge you
to approve it today there is strong evidence in the research that high quality civic learning
opportunities promote both capacities for and commitments to civic engagement
but unfortunately the research also indicates that exposure to civic learning in schools is
infrequent and unequal for example high achieving students white students and students from higher
ses backgrounds often get more exposure to civic learning so this is why a systemic commitment to
civic learning from the state and also lea's is so important to ensure that all students have access
and we believe that the field can help promote this important commitment however a range of
supports will be necessary and the state board and cde can play a critical role in this new research
that our group is conducting we're finding that attention thank you speaker thank you thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record and your time starts now
good afternoon i'm huling lean the executive director of a statewide working group to promote
authentic college career and civic readiness assessment systems or pacris we have been
partnering with cde to support the state seal civic engagement for over two years now because
we really believe the seal represents an important step toward realizing a more holistic
and equitable outcomes for students we have submitted a letter to the board signed by over
30 members representing various stakeholders and organizations to encourage the state board to
approve the state seal civic engagement criteria today we commend the state board and cde for your
thoughtfulness in setting out the student criteria to be as equitable and inclusive as possible i
also want to thank the department for their collaboration and hard work to go through the
so many the many iterations of the criteria to ensure for greater inclusion so please approve
the seal criteria today so that students across california can be recognized for their community
and civic engagement efforts as soon as possible thank you thank you speaker and this concludes
our public comment it's very good um thank you very much um i'm going to urge us to
think quickly about this it's an important topic we spent a lot of time on it i think
we have a lot of interest and support uh in the board uh is there any discussion
and i know kimmy wanted to launch us with at least one piece of discussion discussion
do you want to start us off kim yes um so i i think um what is fantastic is um how much criteria five
um lifts up this idea of civic mindedness as encompassing um an embrace of um the
diversity and inclusion uh that that lives um here in california and and is something
that enables us to sort of think about the common good and work collectively on behalf of the common
good um there's language that i think might be able to be brought up um which and if not i can
oh okay there's amendment language that i'm offering which is um to actually thread the
needle between criteria one and criteria five um which is around the idea of knowledge of our
constitution and this idea of an inclusive society the legislative findings leading up
to this body of work very much emphasize that there are fewer opportunities for low income
students for black and latino students to engage in civic opportunities and civic learning spaces
um notably also i think um obviously and you'll see this following in the parens we're just
following the eg um that our constitution in fact um also talks about broadening um the
franchise as one of the most revered forms of civic engagement so the 15th amendment extended
the franchise um regardless of past conditions of servitude of slavery obviously in the 19th
amendment extending the franchise to women um i think the this language is important i think to
add to thread these these needles and also to connect to these two concepts um and then i guess
i'll i'll just also add of course that the preamble to the constitution starts with what we are
the work of the constitution is about creating a more perfect union and establishing justice um
and that is the actual language of the preamble um i will maybe just conclude by saying i think
uh it's fantastic that good trouble and the john lewis quote is encompassed within the types of
civil disobedience um that is pro-social productive and about engaging students in a different way
um and i will close with the john lewis quote that is not as often read which is that democracy is
not a state it is an act and each generation must do its part to help build what we call
the beloved community a nation and world society at peace with itself what a great way to launch
this discussion um and we've had so much productive discussion about this and barbara i really
appreciate the way in which you so carefully integrated all of that discussion into the item
that's being brought before us um so let's see if there is any further discussion now i assume
kim that the amended language would be part of the motion that you would suggest us to make on the
criteria is there further discussion i see patricia i see cynthia patricia i wanted to raise my hand to
support the suggested amendments that board member patio bronson is making and i also want
to just say especially in the context of what we are witnessing in the news and in events that are
happening in communities around this country i think that the work that has been done on
being more expansive in the definition of civic engagement i i'm hoping that by creating this
definition and creating some flexibility in the criteria that this privileges the opportunity
for more students and not just students like our new student board member to have the opportunity
to earn this particular seal and what i'm hoping is that um it will encourage a broad community
of students in the graduating class to see the seal and to see it on their diploma my goal would
be for high schools to be able to offer this to 100 of their graduating seniors by the time we're
ready to implement this because this is not about academic grading it's about actual participation
and the type of leadership skills that students should be engaged in not only in their schools
for student government activities but for all the other types of activities that create a school
community and that contribute to the types of school climate that about that tend to be the
reasons why many students see their high school years as part of the best parts of their life
thank you very much um cynthia and then sue i first just wanted to start by saying again kudos
to cd staff as well as state board members past and present um for really ensuring accessibility
and inclusivity for all students to be able to access this seal i think it's very very
important as was as kim had stated to ensure that the understanding of civic engagement
does include good trouble if you will and positive acts of civil disobedience and it's
it's wonderful to see that included to understand and again ensure that everyone can have a way that
they are able to engage in the seal itself and also the interdisciplinary approach i just wanted
to throw um just a thought moving forward that as the seal becomes accessible to students it's going
to be really important to support lea's so that they are able to support students to have the
access and to be able to meet the criteria so really looking at what that might look like how
might the system of support be able to possibly help with that are areas that can be used for
further exploration to have the seal and such wonderful criteria without on roads for students
to access them through their schools and their districts won't be as helpful so just want to be
sure that we continue the conversation beyond thank you excellent thank you sue and then eileen
and then jim so i will just echo the
compliments to barbara especially and her staff for incorporating all of the various
work suggestions that we made at different meetings and then also all of the suggestions
that folks have made from the public and i just have a clarifying question kim i'm not i'm just
not sure what where this is intended to go is it meant to be a separate criteria
or it's i'm just i'm just not confused about it it doesn't have track changes so kim why don't you
explain the language following the bullet um is already in the document uh the part that is new
is the parenz which is an illustrative example the eg um don't you just read aloud the part that
would be added to what's already there eg connecting the 15th amendment suffrage
protections to address anti-black racism racism and discrimination against other racial minorities
and immigrants including but not limited to native americans latinx asian americans and
other language minorities protected by the voting rights act and the 19th amendments protection of
women's right to vote thank you so much for the clarification
all right uh was that was that all you had sued that you wanted to offer at this moment
okay then we'll move to eileen and then jim and then zake just a quick comment um barbara to you
and your team um i just so appreciate how you walked through the entire process so that people
can see this is a long time in development and we had a lot of important stakeholder input and i
believe the criteria that we have now come to recommending for adoption really does lay important
guidance for districts and important activities for students to be involved in i'm really proud
of this work and for everyone who's worked so hard on this and i just appreciate you laying
it out talking about what led up and what will come next so thank you very much um again i'm
really supportive of the product that we got to at this point it's great jim yes thank you i just
want to say thank you for all the good work on this i think uh it's been well overdue for to have
something like this a seal of civic engagement i appreciate the criteria too that students are
to demonstrate a competency in the understanding constitutions and as well as tribal governments
and tribal government structures and organizations i on behalf of the over 566 federally recognized
tribes in the united states and over 120 federally recognized tribes in california alone and then
dozens of unrecognized groups also so i really appreciate that and commend all the work on this
on this one thank you terrific and zade you may get the last word before we have a motion
which is very appropriate um well i just really quickly wanted to echo what board member rucker
said i'm just so glad that this seal isn't tied to grades and truly does a phenomenal job of
understanding what civic engagement truly is i think that the the criteria currently is
um both equitable and accessible and i think that the letters that we all receive
kind of serve as a testament to just how much students truly want this deal to not only
incentivize them to be civically engaged but to also recognize them for the for their current
involvement and for the hard work that they're putting into their community so with that being
said i think that um i don't know i'm fully in support of this all right can i get a motion
um so i move to adopt the department's recommended criteria for local use with the addition of uh the
language that appears on screen now okay and do i have a second i will second i second yes thank
you great uh any further discussion all right we're going to call the roll karen okay ting
ting aye allene aye trisha
yes i day yes kim yes matt yes jim yes cynthia yes zade yes linda
aye aye sue talking twice
okay very good we did it we passed it uh and thank you to barbara and all the staff who
worked on it uh this is a really important accomplishment i can tell you that this seal
and what it represents will um have uh an effect across the country there are lots of people
watching this as they think about their own systems of education and accountability and
the fact that we're taking this step i think will as they sometimes say when california sneezes the
country catches a cold well i think this will be a good sneeze that will find its way
into lots and lots of state boardrooms thank you very much barbara and now we're going to move
straight ahead i know we have to really kind of barrel forward um on item number six we
have a public hearing and i want to be sure that we get to that get to and through that public
hearing uh because folks are lined up to present their cases here um eight item uh six is a public
hearing regarding an appeal to transfer territory from the londale esd and sentinel valley union
high school district into the wiseburn usd the cde is recommending that the state board deny the
appeal thus affirming the action of the county committee to approve the proposal to transfer
territory from londale and sentinel valley to the wiseburn usd the cd further recommends that the
state board establish the territory proposed for transfer as the election area for the required
election on the proposal and provide no division of the property funds and obligations of the
londale and sentinel valley if the transfer is approved an election and this item is presented
by larry shirey of the cde i'm sure it will be an excellent and succinct presentation
take it away larry yes it will be i'll do my best to abbreviate it by popular demand and given the
timelines not my strength but we will go through as quickly as we can we need six board members
to vote in any direction for it to for us to have a decision and we want to get there before
we lose a couple sorry i didn't hear i didn't hear you i'm sorry go right ahead i'm just saying we
we need to be sure we get there before we lose board members okay so as as was mentioned this
was a uh an appeal of a territory transfer uh approval by the la county committee
um the issue here is uh 406 homes outlined in yellow on the map currently in the londale
elementary school district and that they have initiated a petition to move the territory the
406 homes into wiseburn unified a couple of interesting background issues that there's
been a long history of open enrollment agreements for students here both londale and wiseburn for
decades have entered into agreements allow students in these areas to attend any district
either district they want a lot of charter high schools in the area about 47 percent of the high
school students attend a charter high school all of wiseburn's high schools three of them are
charter high school sentinel valley in addition to its three comprehensive high schools has two
charter high schools and each of the elementary component districts in that high school district
have at least one including londale um wiseburn used to be a component district of sentinel valley
but the state board approved their unification proposal uh 2013 the petitioners have three
primary reasons for wanting to transfer um as as you can see that they're part of an unincorporated
area that locally they refer to as wiseburn the census bureau calls it del air so we'll use del
air that they claim they're the only residents in this area that are not part of wiseburn school
district we've already talked about the open enrollment um issues and the primary reason is
that the petitioners want to ensure that their neighborhood students have access to wiseburn's
higher performing charter high schools again these are charter high schools but
but wiseburn gives preference to residents of of wiseburn and the remaining slots are very competitive
what the county committee did is as we talked about before in previous issues there are nine
statutory threshold standards that the county committee has to meet has to look at they took
they found that all those standards were met even though and then as they moved into considering
why to approve this they took no formal action to adopt a reason but they've been reviewing
their discussions throughout the meeting they focused a lot on community identity issues
and they noted that even though there's choice out there and the students can go whatever district
they want to uh inter-district transfer students are treated differently than resident students
in terms of having to renew permits every year parents can't vote in district elections etc
lawndale is appealing sentinel valley is also affected here but for reasons that if you want
to know i'll go into but i'm not going to go into right now they have some protections that
came out of the unification issues so the primary reasons are going to be looking at lawndale
lawndale states that there's no reason to approve this territory transfer because there's really no
compelling community identity with wiseburn they claim that the commutes to wiseburn schools are
less safe they are concerned about a permanent loss of the students in this area as well as the
assessed valuation they note that there's a long history of open enrollment agreements as we
discussed so there's really again no reason to do this and they note that it's bad public policy
to use school district reorganizations as a way to to promote promote competition for the
higher performing schools we're going to look at those reasons primarily in the context of the
minimum threshold standards that i mentioned previously and the ones that don't fit in those
standards we'll talk about when i when i briefly go through the reasons to approve or disapprove
the transfer the three conditions in statute that we're going to be looking at our community
identity community identity the school districts are each organized on the basis of a substantial
community identity the issue of there being an equitable equitable division of property and
facilities of in this case the lawndale and sentinel valley districts and that the proposed
reorganization will not have a negative effect on the fiscal status of the of any affected district
regarding the first condition compelling the community identity lawndale argues that the
choice block students are are are already able to participate in all community activities and
transferring to to the new district is not going to change that therefore there is no improvement
in the community identity of this area that in terms of this condition is not part of the standard
is not part of the standard and failure to improve community identity is not a reason to find this
condition not substantially met another component of the community identity is londale's claim that
commutes to the wiseburn schools are less safe due to longer distances in a freeway that exists
between the choice blocks and schools if you want to see the actual distances the table on page 15
of the attachment but we find that commutes are not significantly longer to wiseburn schools and
londale we do acknowledge that freeways exist as they do in almost all urban areas in our state
in this case interstate 405 runs through wiseburn all of wiseburn schools are on the west side of
this freeway that's the that's kind of the basis for londale's concern is that the proposed transfer
area students have to cross the freeway but so do all those students who live just north of the
transfer area again all the all the schools for wiseburn are on the west side i also note that
the freeway as it goes down cuts right through londale all of londale's middle schools are on
the east side of the freeway so it also it also cuts off the students on the west side of the
freeway from attending as an obstacle for londale attendance in middle schools finally there is a
very large shopping center just south of the transfer area that's between the rest of the
londale district and the and and the transfer area all told we don't see a lot of difference
between what district these students are in again freeways busy streets and and shopping centers are
fairly common in urban areas londale also is concerned that the assessed valuation that
they'll lose from this property will affect its ability to secure future bonding
efforts and it exacerbate exacerbate the existing disparity between londale's and wiseburn's
assessed valuation we note that choice blocks does not make up a significant portion of londale's
assessed valuation at 4.3 percent further londale the assessed valuation in the district has has
increased more than 21 percent over the past past five years that's five percent a year which is a
higher rate of growth than was that was projected when this territory transfer proposal was
considered locally the district has just had recent successful bond elections most recently
in march of this year so there is already a potential for bond funds available and if they
run into problems accessing this this these bond funds state board is very good about about
approving waivers to increase the bonding capacity of the district so we find that that condition
also this is the equitable division condition is also met moving into the fiscal effects
the districts report that currently there are 43 choice block students that attend londale and 95
that attend wiseburn for 1920 these 43 students represent less than three less than one percent at
three quarters of a percent of the londale enrollment therefore we don't see this as being
a significant loss in terms of either students or or funding londale is going to argue and has argued
that all 38 students should be considered as a permanent loss if the territory is transferred we
don't see a lot of support for that given that the number of students that have attended wiseburn
from this area over the years has been very consistent so it's a it's a hard to argue
that you're losing funding that you haven't ever had londale also supports open enrollment which
says to us that they have supported losing students in the past from this area as a as we noted
95 of them currently attend wiseburn so we find this fiscal status condition to be substantially met
once so we find that all the conditions as did the county committee are substantially met therefore
we're going to move into some reasons why the state board might want to disapprove or approve
the territory transfer as has already been brought up open enrollment of options already exist
for choice block students londale elementary enrollment has been declining as has been the
case for many districts in the state while the enrollment is increasing in wiseburn it's kind
of an apples and oranges comparison wiseburn for for decades has been a destination district for
a variety of reasons when the state board considered their unification proposal in 2013
49 percent of the k-8 population of wiseburn elementary was on interdistrict transfer
something kind of new for us is the current covid pandemic that that we're current that we're in
the state board members may have some angst about is this a good time to approve approve a territory
transfer we don't see a lot of specifics that we can point to on this especially since when we look
at the process that's going to have to be play play out if the state board allows the transfer to
move forward there will be an election next year and then it won't go into effect until july 1st
2022 so it's two years down the road before we'll actually see the transfer in terms of reasons the
state board might consider to approve the transfer you know one thing we look at a lot is what the
local folks have have already said there is a local determination the county committee has already
approved this transfer the issue that the that the petitioners brought up is the transfer would
ensure that choice block students have access to wiseburn charter schools that's not a real big
issue for us because we don't see the territory transfer process as being a way to to for parents
to choose what schools our kids go to and finally is there some community identity advantages to
moving the territory into wiseburn we've shown these two maps already and they do highlight
a number of community identity issues including the fact that the the area proposed for transfer
is the only area of the dell era incorporated area that's not part of wiseburn and that there
is a a shopping center a large shopping center that separates what the lawndale elementary school
district from from the proposed transfer area so in terms of a quick review of the local actions
the county committee they conducted all the required public hearings
uh district reorganizations are processes under the california
or projects under the california environmental quality act they completed that sequel process
successfully they they considered all minimum threshold standards and found them substantially
met as required by education code as i mentioned we agree with their findings
and
legislative intent exists in the education code about what we need to look at when it comes to
approving a reorganization the statement there is that local educational needs and concerns
shall serve as the basis for future reorganizations in our examination of the
administrative record we find that the county committee did consider such needs and concerns
we've mentioned some of the community identity issues as well as the concerns that county
committee members had about permit students being treated differently than resident students
it's our further opinion that the county committee is better positioned to determine
local educational needs and concerns than than we are here at the state
in summary we find that all minimum threshold conditions are substantially met we find no reason
compelling enough to reverse the county committee's decision to approve the transfer
and we're going to recommend that the as already been stated we recommend that the state board
affirm the approval i'm going to skip this and just go into our recommendation
we recommend that again that the state board affirm the county committee's action to approve
the proposed post the proposed transfer of territory you're required to establish the
territory that in which the election will be held if you do so we recommend that the election area
be the default in statute which is just the area proposed for transfer we don't see any reasons
substantial enough to expand the election area beyond the proposed transfer area there is also
a default in terms of of how the property and funds and obligations of of of londale and
sentinel valley will be divided if the territory transfer is approved given how small how minimal
the number of students are and and the assessed valuation and the fact that these open enrollment
agreements have been in place for a long time we don't believe that there should be any division
of londale and sentinel valley's sentinel valley's property that's also a recommendation that the
that laco made in presenting this to their county committee so if there are clarifying
questions i can take them otherwise after the public hearing public comment i'll be here to
respond to other questions
i think linda's on mute
talking to myself on mute uh thank you very much i don't see any clarifying questions
so i'm going to open the public hearing at 4 25 pm first we will hear from the petitioners who
are composed of the following three groups first the petitioners who live in the neighborhood to
be transferred second the wiseburn usd district that is proposing to receive the territory
and third the los angeles county office of education the petitioners district and county
will have a total of 12 minutes then we will hear from the londale esd and sentinel valley
union high school district the two districts that are i'm sorry union unified school district
the two districts that are opposing the petition together those two districts will also have a total
of 12 minutes after the presentations from both sides there will then be an opportunity for public
comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each so we're going to
begin with the petitioner presentation for 12 minutes take it away petitioners
we see your screen
so we're not yet hearing you thank you
good afternoon i am shavonda weber christmas a chief petitioner for the wiseburn residents
for wiseburn schools choice block petition we petition to transfer our area from the londale
elementary school district and sentinel valley union high school district to the wiseburn
unified school district it's unfortunate that our petition has come to this nevertheless it
is a privilege to be before you today along with the many weighty issues and valiant issues that
you all are dealing with but we are here to share our story here with me today are three other
supporters from the community and the school district i will first turn it over to eddie
urenda an active choice block resident watch leader and parent of a wiseburn unified school
district permit student eddie thank you shavonda good evening board thank you for listening to us
this evening i'll start by saying that the communities are are hard to form in suburban
areas and especially in los angeles yet we formed one and i ask you to consider the commonalities
that the choice blocks have with the wiseburn area in relation to the one that they may not
have with londale elementary and sentinel valley first of all in terms of representation we are
in an unincorporated area of los angeles and represented by a los angeles county supervisor
in terms of protection we are served by the los angeles sheriff department for the entire area
in terms of suffrage our voting is around county issues exclusive of the the school
district issues we are served by a single neighborhood watch
we also get a single newsletter that unifies the news for the school
pool access and facilities to to the pool is a dotted line even though we're in 2020 today
and full district students receive free access to the pool permanent students have a fee access
to access the pool hard to believe in 2020 yet that is the case here we represent 406
households out of the 1624 households in unincorporated los angeles area known as
wiseburn and we share the common zip code of 90250 we're also served by a county library
the aptly named the wiseburn county library this is the way that that we go to school
um the choice block influence the boards that serve both the path and and the organizations
that serve the school including the neighborhood watch the educational foundation and the national
night out we have safety in numbers in terms of the paths that we walk to school four out of the
five choice blocks are surrounded by a walking path and that that traversing of the 405 that's
been mentioned as a security concern we have it's bookended by crossing guards that are present
during school hours when school is in session during normal non-pandemic times of course
that guarantees the safety to our children i live in the southernmost block of the choice blocks
and i feel comfortable in that my children follow a designated walking path with crossing
guards to access school
the last four blocks are no for no further away than than the choice blocks are from the wiseburn
schools again the low accident numbers over the past years we've had three accidents
over the past three years as opposed to 246 accidents over the past three years
crossing rosecrans boulevard a major thoroughfare that is 28 miles in length traversing east to
westbound los angeles county and an important separator between the choice blocks and the
lawndale school district so i'm going to pass on my the speaking time over to shavonda i was going
to talk a little bit about equity and suffrage for the choice blocks shavonda
shavonda you're on mute thank you can you take yourself off mute there we go
it is true that the choice blocks have a lot in common with their neighbors
but being a wise man residence has its own privileges um this little girl anaya here on
the top right of your screen she's very excited and likes what she sees she just can't wait to
get into these schools that are right down the street from her neighbor from her home
she's guaranteed services she thinks she's guaranteed services like early start
walk-in enrollment for kindergarten and if her family moves in even if she's fourth grade or
fifth grade she automatically gets a seat and best of all there's a pool at the high school that's
open to wiseburn and el segundo city residents through a special partnership and there's other
exclusive partnerships that davinci garners like free college that mom and dad really like
certainly on her on our minds today is suffrage and our ability to vote for not to mention to
run for the school board of our own community unfortunately anaya is a choice block kid
just like little jacob here and all the excitement begins to turn to fear
when mom and dad are told oh sorry you're at the wrong school
lesd is then slow to release your child on the permit or they simply deny it
to cause more red tape and then when it's too late to get into wiseburn you hear well maybe
next year maybe third grade maybe when they get to middle school
so parents are stuck and have to search many alternatives to try to figure out and while
they're doing that jacob here is saying excuse me sir um this isn't fun
now this is not just a cute little story my neighbors and i have been living this narrative
collectively for more than 35 years it's real the notion of open enrollment however is not real
it just sounds good londell has not proactively reached out to the choice block residents to give
us a choice or even promote their school but we the people have made our choice clear we want
wiseburn school wiseburn unified however is in demand in 2018-19 more than 10 permit requests
were unfulfilled part of the reason is because there's more school-aged families
moving into the district as our seniors move out there are new developments like fusion and 360
complexes bell south apartments they're havens for young families and they're taking their
rightful seats in wiseburn schools in addition there are restrictions that prevent wiseburn
from accepting students into the local district from local districts like londell sentinella
hawthorne so we understand that londell wants you to block our petition but honestly if you do this
might be the last chance that we get into the lawn into the wiseburn schools londell wants you
to believe that 100 students will bankrupt their district their appeal claimed that
this would be very costly for them it would be very costly for cv usd and that it would be costly
for the residents but the real story for this actually was a nice story it was about children
helping other children but the story that you see right here it just won't fly
i urge you to find out what's really going on ask them what percentage londell residents really
attend i probably consider that number low what percent of non-choice block residents permit out
or never show up that's probably pretty high what proactive steps are taken to fill the seat
well we don't see any they're not coming to our doors probably few
so we also want to urge you not to get caught up in their black box trap you know they tell us that
the assessed valuation is unknown the bond obligation is really high and that they're going
to get stuck you can eliminate that speculation there are experts who have in the materials that
you have before you decided exactly what the assessed valuation is what the obligations are
and they can once again confirm the negligible cost of these um of the area simple logic will
conclude that fewer than one percent of their district being moved away and even 0.5 percent
of sentinela valleys district is not going to deplete these bonds that we've been paying for
all of the children's education in this area is worth far more than that anyway so state board
members i implore you please read between the lines listen to what you're really hearing and
support the recommendation of the california department of education affirm the county committee
on school district organization in la county that approved the choice blocks transfer to
wise burn unified school district and designate an equitable voting area within
the wise burn unified school district
at this point before we close i just want you to hear from some of our biggest supporters
wise burn officials mr banuelos part of the wise burn board of trustees
and dr silver is the superintendent mr brown welles thank you shavonda good afternoon members
of the board of education i am roger banuelos i am currently a wise burn unified school district
board trustee um i have served in this capacity for 11 years as a trustee of the wise burn unified
school district i have had the privilege and opportunity to make many and several presentations
to the county committee and and and district organization as well as to our our overall
community which does include the choice blocks i have done so in the capacity of board president
of vice president and board member in addition in that period of time as a resident of the area
over the last 20 years having lived within holly glenn and in wise burn del air community i have
seen that in this with regards to the petition what i have seen is that what it really comes
down to is how a segment of our community lives and learns in these schools the the the students
that live in the choice blocks attend the same classrooms they play in the very same fields that
my kids have played in in the school district whether it's baseball softball
baseball or softball and we would really encourage that the committee affirm the
recommendation by dde further for the inclusion of the choice blocks thank you
now we will move to the um opposing district presentation
um
hi good afternoon my name is bill schafer i'm a partner with rutan and tucker i and dr betsy
hamilton superintendent wandell elementary school district will speak on behalf of the wandell
school district wandell requests that the state board of education exercise its independent
review and judgment of this matter grant the appeal of wandell and disapprove the territory
transfer petition transferring the choice blocks area from wandell to wise burn there is no
compelling reason for the territory transfer however if the petition is approved the election
area should be for all residents of wandell the remaining property owners will have their property
tax increased by 3.5 percent 3.55 according to the expert evidence that's in the record
and the quality of the educational programs for the remaining students will be diminished
the territory in question has been part of the wandell elementary school district
since 1909 for several decades wandell and wise burn have allowed parents residing in
the territory in question to choose which desk district to send their children we invite the
board's attention to several of the conclusions reached by the county committee staff feasibility
report of july 1st 2016 on page 11 of the staff report the county committee staff concludes the
chief petitioners have not made any credible challenges to the outstanding quality of the
educational programs at the wandell school district petitions to transfer territory are
requests for change to permanent boundaries they should only be undertaken based on evidence of a
compelling reason to make such changes no such compelling reason has been presented in this case
that cannot be mitigated by current collaborative practices of the districts in question
specifically in the offering of permits we submit as found by the county committee
wandell provides an outstanding quality of education this critical fact in and of itself
should control the outcome of the appeal cde's analysis of page 27 also finds no compelling
reasons to transfer the choice blocks from wandell esd and sentinela valley union high
school district to wise burn cde further finds on page 28 that the petitioners desire to gain
an advantage in enrolling their students at the wise burn usd charter high schools is not a
compelling reason for a territory transfer second the county committee staff recommends on page 21
of their report that the petition be denied because access is already assured by the districts and
the uncertain fiscal impact on the districts should the transfer be approved this was back in 2016
regarding the fiscal impact cde states in relevant part it's in in its analysis
on pages 23 to 24 the cde does caution that the current fiscal outlook of the state
as well as the affected districts is unknown and potentially very troublesome
due to covid the covid 19 pandemic cd further observed on page 26 of its analysis
the current covid 19 pandemic may have created a fiscal and educational environment that currently
is not conducive for changing school district boundaries cd continues in this discussion of
covid 19 on page 27 public education in california is currently suffering due to the ongoing covid
19 pandemic future impacts on school districts regarding funding staffing instructional planning
and delivery and facility usage are unknown at this point the cbe may consider that a change
to school district boundaries a resultant effect on funding and student attendance
no matter how minimal is unwarranted in the current environment again although some negative
effects due to covid 19 on the educational programs and fiscal status of every school
in the state are likely londale fully expects that covid 19 will have a material and negative
impact on londale's finances in view of londale's outstanding educational program
this is not the time for boundary change thank you dr besie hamilton the londale superintendent
will now speak
good evening thank you for listening to our concerns this evening the transfer of territory
proposed by the petitioners would permanently remove students who currently reside within the
londale boundaries and as is mentioned previously would result in a potential loss of up to 1.3
million depending on the numbers of students in the area a number of the students residing
in the choice blocks already attend wiseburn schools under the long-standing agreement of
the districts and i would hope that those agreements would continue but i do not have
a current agreement with the with the district a number of transfers is set the number of transfers
is subject to change in any given year based on parental choice once the boundary is changed
there will be no choice and all students would become wiseborn students many districts including
londale are experiencing a significant loss in enrollment due to the pandemic and the
resulting economic crisis if this transfer were approved it would further exacerbate the economic
status of londale only two of the 12 south bay selpa districts are not experiencing significant
drops in enrollment and wiseburn is one of those fortunate districts due to the pandemic homelessness
and poverty have increased in londale and the district enrollment is already 200 students below
our projections this will require budget and staff reductions and a loss of the choice block area
would further cripple londale's ability to provide a quality education the permanent loss of students
would have a tremendous impact on critically needed funding the effect of such a significant
revenue loss would be further aggravated by operation of the lcff funding model itself
much of londale's lcff revenue funding is principally directed in l cap to providing new or
improved services to students socioeconomically disadvantaged el and foster youth and with the
advent of this revenue which is an equity model of funding several londale programs have been added
or enhanced such programs would likely be cut or curtailed should the district suffer a loss of
revenue due to the choice block transfer these programs provide significant support in the
community with nearly 90 percent of its students living in poverty improved programs and services
include all-day kindergarten classes and reduced class sizes in kindergarten through third grade
teacher coaches and language arts and mathematics english learner instructional resource specialists
to provide support for english learners social workers and community liaisons at every school
providing student and family counseling and greater parent engagement in londale schools
increased hours of operation in londale school libraries increased technology in londale's
classrooms and these resources and supports have improved student outcomes significantly
the usc soul prize center for innovation has recognized londale for two consecutive years
for closing achievement gaps for african american latino and english learner students
a territory transfer would jeopardize these successes the loss in revenue caused by the
loss of students in this area would have an immediate adverse impact on all of londale students
the resulting impact impact would be increase in class sizes reduction to elective programs such
as art music and foreign language fewer classified staff to support campus cleanliness and safety
fewer counselors and social workers to support students emotional well-being and reduced access
to school libraries londale is already a distinct disadvantage in bonding capacity when compared to
other local districts londale is largely residential and thus can can access fewer funds
to provide upgraded facilities for our students the loss of this land area is estimated to reduce
the ability to access approximately 750 000 additional dollars to improve facilities for
our students we respectfully request the state board of education disapprove the territory transfer
but if approved establish the election area to be all residents of londale elementary school
district our parents deserve a voice in the future of their children's education thank you very much
for your attention to this matter and consideration of our appeal i would like to introduce dr gregory
o'brien superintendent of the sentinel valley union high school district thank you
thank you president darling hammond esteemed members of the board and members of the audience
i have been the superintendent of sentinel valley union high school district for the past five and
a half years i'd like to make just a few brief comments as you consider this petition i would
ask that you use an equity lens to consider whether this change would make the educational
system more equitable for the students that are most at promise in our community
community the california school dashboard shows that both sentinel valley and londale have
significantly higher counts of students who are socioeconomically disadvantaged english learner
and foster youth than wiseburn and davinci charter schools i understand the arguments made by those
presenting their petition today wiseburn and davinci are doing great things for students
and they are respected partners of ours in the south bay however i cannot support the changing
of long-standing school boundaries for the reasons they have put forward the potential loss of any
ada and bonding capacity will have a direct impact on our at promise students sentinel valley has
worked hard to transform our district and we have 21st century projects that have been completed
recently and i'll give you two of the most important changes that we've seen with regards
to instruction on march 18th of this year we were able to immediately begin distance learning
because 100 percent of our students already had district chromebooks and internet connectivity
why because four years ago we began a forward-thinking systemic digital learning
initiative where every incoming freshman received chromebook and access to the internet
secondly graduation rates are on the rise all three of our comprehensive high schools have
graduation rates above 90 and that includes our hispanic and african-american subgroups
we believe that if the petitioners truly want to improve the education for students we invite them
to join us as we continue our transformation rather than try to break away additionally if you
support this proposal today what would stop any other group from doing the same as gentrification
occurs in our area will it be acceptable for new areas to request they join the higher ses school
districts as well for identification issues in closing homeowners know the district and the
school district for which they are buying into i ask that you please respect the historic boundaries
of both londale and sentinel valley and deny the petitioners request we need your support in our
efforts to eliminate achievement gaps and create a more equitable community for all students we do
not see any benefits to the students and families in the greater community if this petition is
approved thank you for your consideration thank you so at this point the public comment slide
should go up and we'll open the phone line for the public comment queue and while we're waiting
for members of the public to call in i want to ask matt navo our liaison if he has any initial
comments then if there are clarifying questions we can take those and we'll get to public comment
as quickly as possible sure sure you want some just some brief thoughts before we go
your framing comments yes please yeah i'll so although i typically have very strong opinions
regarding district reorganization and this is one of those because the timing is really
tough for londale i think there's a number of clarifying questions that
need to be asked before we can settle on landing on a secure decision but at this point i can't
help but recognize the unique realities that these districts have the unique past history
that they have the reality of the choice blocks and the del air situation that it creates for
the community members that wish to transfer and i can't help deny the fact that we've had
the local county approve and we've had cde review and affirm so with that being said i'm very curious
as to what the public comment will be around this okay are there any brief clarifying questions
at this point from the board members before we go to public comment
okay hearing none then we're going to go ahead and start public comment
yes currently we have four speakers just quick reminder that this is for item six
and if you have spoken on the behalf of either side during the zoom call please do not call again
for the public comment caller you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the
record hello yes you're you're live okay thank you thank you uh my name is dr blake silver
is the superintendent of the wiseburn unified school district i wasn't able to get a chance
to speak publicly but i just want to start off by stating wiseburn has great respect
for lawndale school district sentinel la vali union high school district the boards the staff
and the community they really do a great job to educate their students this choice block petition
is largely based on the sense of community that the residents in the area feel for wiseburn and
i must say the feeling is mutual it's not about an issue that's grounded in educational offerings
or experience but it's a shared sense of community i note that the 406 parcels in wiseburn area
wiseburn area residences that are not included i'm sorry i i note that these 406 parcels in
the choice blocks are not included in wiseburn unified school district and they're the only
parcels in the dell air wiseburn area that are not of the estimated 200 or so students 95 attend
wiseburn usd already in 1920 and it's consistently been in the 80s and 90s i want to share that
wiseburn remains committed to school choice and would honor any residents to transfer
thank thank you thank you thank you to the board next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is maria acosta i am a wiseburn resident for wiseburn schools my child is currently in the
seventh grade our family supports the transfer of the what is designated as the choice blocks
into the wiseburn unified school district we participate in a variety of activities
within our community including the wiseburn watch the national night out you know all the
santa parade you know all these community activities and events and unfortunately those
residents that live in those choice blocks do not feel fully integrated into our community
because they have to jump through hoops to petition to be a part of our school district
so i would like for that the board to consider transferring those 406 households
into the wiseburn unified school district thank you so much for your time
thank you speaker next speaker please speak your name and affiliation for the record your time
starts now yes speaker we can barely hear you are you still with us
yes i'm the next one chris tory yes fabulous i live in the choice blocks and wiseburn school
district and like other speakers we're very active in the community and the sports and the kids
programs and santa and all such i'm pointing out that not it's a gentleman's agreement to be
released because my child was not given a permit released the first time through we walked into
what londell school district and they said we're sorry we do not release white children because
you are statistically and demographically significant and it really did take quite some
hoops to get him released so i'm just pointing out there are situations where they do not honor
always having somebody released thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now yes hello my name is michael johnson i live in the dell air
district and i'd like for you guys to please consider transferring the choice blocks over
wiseburn district it seems unfair that our tax dollars are going to a school district
and then we petition our children into wiseburn that means that our tax dollars
are going towards londale and they're not helping our children in their education in the future
doesn't seem conducive to the community
thank you caller thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time starts now
caller are you there
good afternoon my name is tom johnstone and i am the retired superintendent of wiseburn
and i will comment on community identity as the appeal documents indicate choice block
residents have been waiting to resolve this issue for over 50 years giving that schools are a hub
for the community while choice block residents are a part of the wiseburn community they also
face a tremendous gap namely wiseburn school and they refer to themselves as the orphan blocks
in 2008 choice block residents were poised to file a petition with the county committee this
action would have derailed the larger wiseburn unification effort that was already in its seventh
year so one of my first acts as superintendent i asked them to stand down they unselfishly agreed
to postpone their petition with an assurance from londale and wiseburn that their children
could attend wiseburn schools the result was a formal choice block agreement there was never
any mention verbally or in writing that this was a long-term or perpetual time it was always a time
thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
hello i'm neil goldman a wiseburn governing board member in support of the choice blocks
in reading londale's appeal i'd like to quickly address what paul harvey years ago might have
called the rest of the story as to the revenue picture two significant components were omitted
first londale's argument of the loss of students and revenues was exaggerated
londale's appeal notes the potential loss of all 131 students each year but the rest of the story
in the year of their appeal 91 of those students or 70 percent chose wiseburn
last year 95 students dramatically mitigating any loss and this consistently stays the same
second on the revenue side they conveniently omitted the roughly one and a half million
dollars they receive annually largely because of wiseburn for measure cl the parcel tax
with a large proportion paid for by the commercial tax base in wiseburn in summary please consider
the whole story in your review choice block residents have repeatedly sought this action
for over 50 years please affirm the la county committee ruling and allow these residents local
self-determination thank you thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now hi this is jessica dordy and i live in the wiseburn area
not in the choice blocks but my students and my children they play with kids from the choice
blocks those students and families are part of our district all the potential reasons to disapprove
the transfer have nothing to do with quite frankly what is best for students and the most compelling
reason of all is to do what is best for students which is allow them into this district the only
unifying factor of our district of our area since we are mostly in an unincorporated la county area
is the school district we live together we communicate together we drive and walk to school
together it is quite frankly undemocratic to allow these families a voice in their children's
education a vote and who governs their schools and an opportunity to be full participants in
in their children's education so thank you very much for your consideration
thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts
now
hello my name is carmen bird can you hear me yes please go ahead hi my name is carmen bird
we are in the choice box and we are living in a family home and my grandmother was one of the
first people to be affected by the separation at 80 years old marjorie bird told me the story of
being denied being able to get on the little school bus that would take her to her school in
wiseburn because she lived basically just right outside the boundary and she told me the story
when she was 80 so socially and emotionally it really did stick with her for the rest of her life
so really what what um i'm worried most about is that we live in a village and it doesn't
take a village to raise a child and emotionally time kids are a part of wiseburn time caller
thank you so much
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is chris maddox i'm a resident of the choice blocks in wiseburn it seems to me that
what should be determinative in this issue is that california law says that there are nine
thresholds that need to be met the county committee has already found that all nine of those
thresholds have been substantially met further california law states that local governments
are in the best position to determine whether or not there should be a transfer of school districts
again that just gives further weight to the fact that the county committee has already decided that
all nine thresholds have been substantially met and therefore their decision to approve the transfer
should be affirmed and the appeal should be denied now looking towards the some of the arguments that
the lawndale school district has made there's just no compelling or supportive sporting evidence
to back up those claims first the covid claim this can't this will not go into effect until
at the earliest 2022 which got helping this this pandemic will be long behind us
second they talked about enrollment declining and lesb has been pointed out multiple times thank
you very much thank you caller next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record your time starts now
caller are you there
okay this concludes public comment thank you for the calls
of so i hereby close the public hearing given that there's no other public comment
at 504 and we'll now begin board discussion board members you know please raise your hands
and i don't know matt if you want to start us off with any further thoughts or we'll just open it
up to those who have questions sure i'm happy to start good can you hear me yes okay so larry can
i are you there larry i can ask you a couple clarifying questions yes i'm here so i understand
the dilemma i've read and with great interest the 31 pages that were provided by cde and there's a
couple of things that i just want to clarify the choice block that is in del air essentially under
the current agreements 100 of those choice block students could go to wiseburn
is that the correct understanding that has been what has been stated in during local
county consideration of the issue you know i haven't seen anything in writing that would
state that but that has been an impression that has been been relayed during local consideration
okay so the and i heard several callers say that they attempted to transfer and they were denied
but the reality is is that whatever this agreement is that that gives parameters to this choice block
students can go to wiseburn or londale and there's an agreement between the districts that they can do
that there there is there have been agreements for decades to allow students in this area to
choose what district they want to attend okay how long ago did this process start
um this particular territory transfer i think was started in 2014 or 15 right after the unification
issue you know as you know it takes us a while we have some resource issues and it takes us a while
to hear hear issues that come before the state board so this particular proposal started then
as the superintendent of wiseburn indicated the community members started back in around 2008
during the time that the wiseburn district was undergoing its 12-year process to unify
as dr silver has indicated the superintendent at that time asked the community members to
stand down or maybe get it and wait until the unification proposal was approved by the state
board okay so this this started this is started some time ago and okay and if the state if the
board was to delay this does that start all over um it doesn't start all over you don't have any
timelines in terms of when you need to take action as kind of confirmed by the fact that
we've had this here for four years it simply means that you put you move it down the road
kick the can down the road and and deal with it at a different time you're only and it's term or
or reverse you're not required as are the counties to do this do so in any time frame
okay and the reality is is mad this is judy sias council for the board you would need to hold
another public hearing though at that point if you chose to not take action at this time then
the board would need to hold another public hearing and start the process over at this level
yeah and that seems like a lot to ask being that they're two years away they have to go through
an election so that that particular community is going to have to conduct an election in 2021
to affirm the this decision from the county and the state board correct it's correct okay so
they're two years away so financially things could be different although we're in a unique
situation i agree with you in the sense that it could be different can you talk to me a little
bit about the numbers that londale's proposing in terms of how it affects them i read in the
the initial proposal there seems to be some disagreement in regards to how this financially
affects them and those property owners that would remain in the londale school district as it
pertains to the property taxes all right let's talk we'll talk first about about a state funding
per student state funding right now there are 43 students in the choice block area that attend
londale though londale talked about all 31 as a loss of some one point some million dollars
the the actual you know in terms of the 43 students and the numbers would be closer to about
four hundred and seventy thousand dollars if all those 43 students went to went to wiseburn after
the transfer was complete you know i've been i i don't know how many territory transfers i've
dealt with over the last three and a half decades i'm sure well over a hundred but what you find is
that students who are attending a district like londale their territory is transferred to another
district often many of those kids will are not particularly fond of the idea of leaving their
colleagues they're not their colleagues but their classmates leaving their teachers so they get
grandfathered in to the district that they had previously attended you know we can't say that
for sure but certainly history has indicated that all 43 of those students will not transfer
to wiseburn once the reorganization goes into effect so that you know if they do the total
loss in lcff funding is about four hundred seventy thousand dollars regarding the assessed valuation
issue the londale district indicated that the remaining residents of of londale would be on
the hook to pay a greater share of property taxes i think they indicated that property taxes would
go up 3.55 percent that's somewhat of a misleading statement because the only thing that would go up
would be the the much smaller portion of the property tax that they're paying associated with
with repaying governing bonds or general obligation bonds right now at the time they considered this
at the local at the county level a property owner in a half a million dollar home a home that
assessed that a half million dollars was paying about 217 dollars annually in to pay off the
bonded indebtedness of londale three and a half percent is what about eight dollars annually so
we didn't see that as a particularly significant increase of course there are additional bond
measures that have been approved since the county made it take it take had taken its action but
those are prop 39 bonds and they're capped in terms of how much you know thirty dollars i
believe it is for a hundred hundred thousand dollars assessed valuation so uh you know the
the voters have already have already agreed to uh up to that point so it's certainly things can
change in terms of how how many of the uh the bonds are sold by the district over time um the
more the more bonds that are sold the greater debt greater debt that's established and the
higher the property tax uh associated with the repaying that debt go but as of right now
you know we we don't see it affecting property owners of say a five hundred thousand dollar
assessed value home by more than twelve dollars a year and the election practice in the past has
been that those that are affected by the reorganization are those that vote it's not
been the practice of in the past that it's extended to the entire district no uh you know there have
been a lot of court cases looking at uh i'm not going to go into them but there have been a number
of court cases looking at what it takes to expand the election area the education code provides a
default election area of just the area proposed for reorganization which would be the choice blocks
and typically uh you know we look at some substantial effect on the remaining
lawndale residents if we're going to make a recommendation about expanding the election
area to them so that you don't overwhelm the voters who are most affected by the by the action
and those uh those substantial effects are basically in terms of pretty significant
segregation issues or very significant fiscal issues we don't see okay here and that's why
we're not recommending expansion of the election area okay i think larry thank you for um answering
all those questions i i mean when it gets down to it i think what i'm hearing you say and what i read
correct me if i'm wrong is um cd doesn't necessarily agree with the reasons for the petition
but doesn't also see a substantial reason to disagree with the county committee's decision
to support the petition for reorganization based on the reality that the county is better equipped
than cde is to identify and understand the local factors supporting the district reorganization
that's basically what it comes down to as i understand it that's correct you know we see a
number of reasonable issues uh that the state board and the county committee could have considered
we don't see any compelling reasons uh you know either way but okay the only thing that we're
looking at is that there is a local decision out there and we uh we we pretty strongly believe
that the local folks are in a much better position to to judge what the local conditions are than we
are okay thank you uh board president i'm i'm i i larry's done a great job answering all my questions
i'll make a motion but i am interested in hearing what other board members say well i appreciate you
asking all of those very thoughtful questions which were very informative in terms of helping
all of us understand the situation i'm not seeing any other hands raised at the moment is there any
other um if there's no other uh desire oops i see cynthia's hand has gone up um go ahead cynthia
you're on mute talking to yourself on mute okay thank you and i apologize i will make this very
quick i just had a couple of clarification questions one was regarding the race and
ethnicity the ethnicity of the students in the choice blocks i know we have the data for each
of the districts but um do we have any information on the race and ethnicity breakdown
of the students that are impacted in the choice blocks no no we don't we we did not get the
that level of of the segregation of the racial ethnic demographics of the area
they did not do that at the county either that's a that you know that's a time-consuming process to
do that you know a resource intensity process and that's that's something that we did not that we
did not focus on okay and one other question um as it relates to the number of permits requesting
to uh move from either lawndale or sentinel to wiseburn do we have any information on
how many uh what percentage of those permits are honored um you know that's different differing
positions the lawndale has has reported both at the local level and and uh and and to us that
they don't disapprove any of them uh the uh the residents of as you've heard in the public comment
section um report that there have been some instances where they where their permits have
been turned down so uh we we uh in terms of going back for a few years we did ask that question of
the districts and you know again lawndale reported that uh when we asked the question specifically
that they they approved all permits that were submitted to them okay thank you and and we haven't
i hadn't heard any comments from any of the parents from either the lawndale or sentinel
valley from what i can recall um i didn't know if either of the petitioners have any
well actually there's no need to respond to that i just will make that as a statement
thank you that's and i believe i had i was just going to say as a follow-up to that that's
you know when you have these territory transfer proposals that are considered at the local level
in public hearings the public hearings are going to be dominated by the people who live in the
area it takes a unusual you don't hear from parents or residents of surrounding areas unless
there's something that they believe is going to affect them greatly i was just going to note i
don't know if this is responsive to your question cynthia but i believe in the petitioner's
initial presentation there was reference to um the uncertainty that many people have experienced
about whether they will have their requests approved and seemed as though that was an
unpredictable event is how i heard it are there any other um questions
all right matt i think we're ready for your um motion
okay so i think given the fact that the in theory all of the the the students in the choice blocks
those families could theoretically go to wiseburn should they choose i think that because you have
the county committee that is closer to the experience and understand the historical issues
issues with it with wiseburn and londale and sentinel valley and i think in regards to the
reality that this is the last portion of the dell air community i'm going to recommend that
we affirm the county committee's action so we're going to approve cd's recommendation
affirm the county committee's action to approve the proposed transfer of territory
use the established territory transfer as the election area and that we provide no division
of funds and obligations do i have a second for that motion a second all right who was it who
said that sue okay thank you sue so many squares to look at um any further discussion
if not we'll call the roll karen can you please call the roll for the vote yes sue
aye linda aye
zayed aye cynthia aye kim aye nat aye kim aye by day aye patricia
yes eileen aye ting aye motion carries
okay thank you um you have earned a 10 minute break and we've reclaimed quite a bit of our
time and so we're still pressing to get you out by probably 6 30 so let's take 10 minutes
in that period of time we'll allow the setup for the next item on our agenda and we'll see
you back here at 5 30 actually nine minutes and so i understand that you need a few more
minutes to make your move but we'll see you back shortly so linda um we can resume
okay good well do we have enough people i see uh i day cynthia matt zayed patricia ting and jim
i know that sue is coming back in in a few minutes so we'll see her shortly
here comes eileen excellent all right do you want to call the roll so that we get a quorum
reestablished here eileen patricia
here i day
i day yes i'm here i just my screen was all over the place since i had to find my mute but kim
okay we'll keep going matt here jim here cynthia here zayed here linda here
and then we know sue's going to be back so we'll be back all right great um so we'll take up now
the regular items on proposed consent followed by waivers which include items seven through ten
waiver items one through three and five through eight members of the public wishing to provide
comment on any of these items may do so by calling in now and again we're going to be covering items
seven through ten and then waiver items wl one through three and w five through eight
i'd like to ask board members to please um
okay we've we've done that
so we're ready to take those up and um we're going to go straight to public comment
and yes we have
yes we we have
caller you are now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record please
caller are you there
okay that concludes public comment that was quick given that there's no further public comment i'll
ask for a motion on consent for items seven through ten
i'll move motion thank you do i have a second i'll second thank you patricia rocker seconds
second thank you patricia rocker seconds okay thank you um we'll now hold a roll call vote
karen can you please call the roll yes ting aye eileen
patricia yes i day
yes kim
okay matt yes jim yes cynthia aye zade yes linda yes and sue i don't think she's back yet
okay the motion carries all right um now i'd like to take up our waiver consent calendar which
includes waiver items one through three and five through eight and we'll now open the phone line
for the public comment queue um and i think the slide is still up there for that so um
we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record if you're making
comment is there any public comment there is no public comment at this time
um all right given that there's no other public comment i'll ask for a motion on waivers one
through three and five through eight do i have a motion a motion patricia brockham moves the
waiver items i think i heard ting first but uh patricia would you like to second
sure patricia rocker seconds okay great um we'll now hold a roll call vote karen can you please call
the roll ting yes eileen yes patricia
yes i day
yes
kim
matt hi jim yes cynthia yes zade yes linda yes i don't think sues back yet okay the motion carries
okay so we're moving on to waiver item four uh which is a request by the oakland unified
school district to waive california education code section specific to statutory provisions
for the lease of surplus property the cde is recommending approval with a set of conditions
which we will be briefed on by wine morelos of the cde who is going to present this item
um why are you there good evening madam president this is andrew nave n-4-1 morelos
i'll be making the presentation tonight if that is okay sure um so with that madam president
state superintendent and board members my name is andrew nave i am a manager in the school
facilities and transportation services division and i will be doing a presentation tonight on
waiver number four waiver number four is a request by the oakland unified school district
to waive sections of the law that specify how surplus school sites are sold or leased
specifically the district is requesting to waive certain provisions of statute that would otherwise
require the district to go through a sealed bid process and select the highest bidder instead the
district would like to use a request for proposal process that will provide the district more
flexibility by allowing them to consider other factors besides cost this is generally a standard
type of waiver request that frequently comes before this board and has historically been approved
there are two properties in question one is known as the edward shands adult school and the other
is the tillton child development center both of these properties have been closed since 2010
and are not currently suitable for instructional use in their current condition it is important
to note that oakland unified has received emergency loans and funding from the state to help stabilize
their budget this funding is contingent upon the district establishing a consolidation plan
that supports the sale or lease of surplus property the district did go through
all steps prescribed in statute to declare both sites as surplus two of the bargaining units the
oakland education association and service employees international union chapter 1021 have registered
opposing positions to this waiver request the oea opposes the sale of the properties
due to their belief the district lacks a comprehensive plan to utilize
existing oakland unified facilities for their early childhood and adult education programs
seiu 1021 seconds oea's opposition and they are concerned that the district will try and sell
properties to address these concerns staff is recommending that the board approve
the waiver request with two additional conditions one is that the district holds a public hearing
where members of the public and the bargaining units can discuss possible uses of the surplus
properties and their potential impacts on the respective communities the second condition
is that the waiver only applies to the lease of these properties if the district decides to sell
the properties without using the statutorily prescribed methodology another waiver request
would be required with that cde recommends the board approve the waiver request and i am happy
to answer any questions that you have all right um we will put the public comment slide back up
so that the call-in number and the access code will be displayed
so that we can open the phone line to the public comment queue
and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in i want to ask patricia rucker as our
waiver liaison if she has any initial comments or framing for us well um thank you i want to commend
the staff for the work that they've done both with the associations and reaching out and talking to
them to try to understand exactly the concerns that were being raised in this process as well
as the work they've been doing in the district to develop this waiver this matter is related to
as you heard presented by the staff some other ongoing and separate work and agreements that
had already been under development between the department and this particular lea so i do highly
recommend when we are done with the discussion and we've heard from the stakeholders if there's any
stakeholders who have input to give i do strongly urge and recommend the staff uh the staff uh
recommendation okay um if there are there any clarifying questions just on the facts
before we go to public comment
all right seeing none then we're going to go to public comment are there any commenters
yes currently we have three in the queue speaker please state your name and affiliation for the
record your time starts now i'm waiting for a general public comment is this general public
comment no that's the next item thank you you're welcome next speaker please state
your name and affiliation for the record please your time starts now
this is josh daniels from oakland unified school district general council just calling
support the staff recommendation thank you thank you caller next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record your time starts now good afternoon my name is maria areas i am
calling a parent of a child with special needs and a local taxpayer i would like to ask the
board members to complete audits on local self us as uh there is several caller excuse
caller excuse me this is a comment for waiver item number four i believe you want general public
comment which will come next oh i'm sorry i will hold my my time then thank you okay thank you
you that concludes public comment all right um so uh at this point is there any uh further
discussion from the board or questions i am seeing none uh do i have a motion
record uh patricia wrecker i will move the staff recommendation okay thank you do i have a second
i will second thank you ting i will hold a roll call vote okay sue
sue is she not back okay well she's there she's back sue are you back
yeah i saw her in the queue she's there i know you can't hear her i see her i see her
she might not be able to hear us i don't have computer audio oh
she can see us but she can't talk to us all right
all right i want to put her hand up she's probably gonna have to call back in
and she put her thumb up we could see the thumb yeah i'm not sure she can hear us earlier she had
this problem too and she had to call in she can why don't we go i don't like why don't we come
back to her okay linda hi zade i cynthia i jim yes matt hi kim yes i day i patricia
hi eileen hi ting hi okay sue can you hear us
she sent me a text that she doesn't have computer audio and can't connect via phone
all right well then the motion passes all right um so uh motion passes and now we're going to go
to the public comment slide again as we have it to take up agenda item 11 general public comment
um invited on any matter not included on the printed agenda we'll open up the phone line for
public comment and uh we know we have at least two people in that queue that i hope they're still
there they are we have two speaker please state your name and affiliation and your time start
and your time starts good afternoon good afternoon my name is josh and i am a high
school student i'm autistic so please have patience for me i am a freshman and the ninth
grade class co-president san pedro senior high school gifted theme magnet a school in los angeles
unified school district located in san pedro california i would like to publicly address
the learning continuity and attendance plan it's my understanding that the plan will address the
response to the impact of the COVID-19 pandemic i would like to state my concern with the lack of
student input in the plan i am aware that the lcp is required to obtain feedback from stakeholders
including students finding trouble by the lack of feedback received particularly from student
demographics that we do not normally hear from such as students with children needs
i do not feel that the feedback that was obtained in line with actions that will support students
both in the classroom and during this learning i particularly worry about my fellow students
with social needs English learners students and possibly students having access to support
resources that they need during this learning and be successful must be able to voice our concerns
our needs and our recommendations to make our school experience better while facing this pandemic
thank you thank you thank you very much
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record and your time starts now
hi good afternoon my name is Marianne Grosner and i would like to share some experiences of special
needs families they are struggling with distance learning and many students are experiencing
regression even though districts are starting to bring back the most vulnerable to in-person
learning many are shocked to find that their mainstream child is no longer mainstreamed and
fully secluded from their typical peers districts are radically changing IEPs
some of these kids going to in-person learning are placed into virtual classes which makes absolutely
no sense transportation has been removed from related services someone needs to step in and
help the most vulnerable instead of putting them in seclusion and removing services i also wanted
you to be aware that the for-profit law firm hired by school districts to deny services of special
needs children haven't slowed down and are actively suing students with disabilities
many school districts spend a million dollars or more on legal fees annually this funding could go
to teachers critical programs or even ppe and other necessities to bring back kids to school
safely time thank you speaker thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now hello can you hear me okay yeah
yes we can hear you go ahead please my name is rita louf and i would like the state board of
education to please ask the california department of education to investigate
how special education dollars are being misused by the west end selpa we selpa has spent over
two million dollars on for-profit litigation to deny children special education services
children special education services in most cases the cost of the lawyers is much more
than what the parent is requesting i filed a complaint with the state bar about fff
because they filed a frivolous legal action in federal court over eight dollars and 40 cents
they have three attorneys getting paid up to 290 dollars per hour to get me to pay the district
eight dollars and 40 cents these attorneys are being enabled by the upland unified school
district and we selpa because they are allocating money to these private corporations tom thank you
caller thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time starts now good afternoon my name is maria areas i am from the m & empire the city of
fontana under the fontana unified school district like other parents have testified we parents of
special needs are struggling with their districts as the districts and selpas are misusing our
taxpayer funds that should be going to especially children and their education are going to frivolous
law firms that are fighting parents for just a couple of dollars in my case my district filed
against us just to deny services to my child who has a diagnosis and has a need for several years
we urge your entity to please have cd review each selpa and how they're misusing funds to
file against parents we urge you to look after our special needs community because we're in a
war there's a lot of this community going on and our times are being described thank you thank you
caller this concludes public comment all right if there are no other public comments then i
hereby adjourn our september 2020 state board of education meeting at
5 51 p.m thank you and i look forward to seeing all of you at our november meeting